ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL AG. ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN BERMAN BIGELOW BOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRO BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU CHOI
KANSEN CHU COOLEY. COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DEEP
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES.
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE RIVAS ROBERT.
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SMITH STONE TAKING VOEPEL
WALDRON WEBER WICKS WORD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DAZE PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. TYLER DEEP THE
SHOULD BE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PLEASE BY YOUR HEAD AND
JOIN ME IN TODAY'S PRAYER. AS
WE GATHER HERE TODAY AS MEMBERS
OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY. WE PRAY
AND ASK THAT YOU PROVIDE US
WITH WITH THEM AS WE DO THE
PEOPLE'S WORK. EVERY DAY
CALIFORNIANS ARE FACING SERIOUS
HARDSHIPS DURING THESE
DIFFICULT TIMES. REMIND US OF
ALL THE CALIFORNIANS THAT WE
REPRESENT. LOOK UPON US. FOR
LEADERSHIP AND COMPASSION.
PLEASE PROTECT OUR FRONT LINE
WORKERS ARE POLICE OFFICERS AND
THE FIREFIGHTERS BATTLING
AGAINST DANGEROUS FIRE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. ARE HEALTHCARE
WORKERS WHO ARE KEEPING OUR
MOST VULNERABLE PHASE AND
HEALTHY. ACCENTURE WORKERS WHO
PERFORM CRITICAL DUTIES WHILE
PLACING THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE.
MAY WE BE CHALLENGE TO GIVE OUR
BEST TO THINK OF THOSE WHO HAVE
ENTRUSTED US IN THIS IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITY. AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR PROVIDENCE. LET'S CONTINUE
TO BE FAITHFUL IN YOU THEY GIVE
US THE COURAGE TO MAKE THE
RIGHT DECISION. NOT THE EASY
ONE. A MAN. THANK YOU MISTER
DEEP WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER GALLAGHER. SALUTE
PLEDGE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. TO
SAN. THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JUNE
ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY THE
CINEMATIC NINETY AM THE AUDIBLE
KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO
TEMPORE THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING
TO FOLKS YOU PROGRAM THE DEATHS
OF SISTER KHLO GAVE A MOMENT
READING THE ROLL CALL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEEKS MOVE THE CALL CALL
THE ASSEMBLY MOTION CARRY TIME
OUT OF FIVE AM MISTER CALDERON
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS
THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESIDENT AND
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE AND
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR ILLNESS IN THE
FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
FOR MEDICAL LEAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FRAZIER AND VOEPEL AND
FOR MATERNITY LEAVE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS.
MEMBERS READ
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS AND MISTER
CALDERON. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
SOMETHING MEMBERS REYES
GONZALES JONES SAWYER CERVANTES
AND BONTA TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY
EIGHT TO REMOVE ITEM A FIVE SB
FIFTY ONE HERTZBERG FROM THE
INACTIVE FLE IN ORDER TO THE-
BILL TO THE THIRD READING AND
ALLOW ME TO TAKE UP FOR
AMENDMENTS. TODAY M. MISTER
FLOOR FOR PURPOSE SIR. WE
WITHHOLDING INSTANCE ENOUGH FOR
ROLL CALL. MISTER FLOOR IS
WITHHOLDING MISTER CALDERON
MOVES AND MR BONTA SECONDS. ON
THE RULES SUSPENSION MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE.
CARCLUB IN THE ROLE. CALDERON
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ALL
MEMBERS OF THE RESERVE- MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND MR FLORA NO.
MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. AND MISTER FLORES ASKING
FOR NO VOTE MEMBERS THIS TAKES
.
FORTY ONE. MISTER CALDERON
TESTING FOR I HAVE A. YEAH
MISTER FLORES ASKING FOR NOBLE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
ICE FORTY ONE. THOSE FOURTEEN
THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED MISTER
CALDERON YOU'RE GONNA RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLEASE
MOVE THE FOLLOWING ITEMS TO THE
INACTIVE FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN
S. B. THREE FIFTY SIX REQUIRE
ITEM ONE SIXTY SB TEN TWENTY
NINE PAN. AND ITEM ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN SB ELEVEN THIRTY GONZALEZ.
THE CLERK WILL NOT. THERE IS A
RULES COMMITTEE RESOLUTION OF
THE DATA SUBJECT TO THE JOINT
RULES TO ALLOW AUTHORS TO TAKE
UP LATE AMENDMENTS I ASKED THAT
WE- TAKE UP THE RESOLUTION NOW.
CORKERY RESULT THE JOINT WILL
SIXTY ONE B. SEVENTEEN BE
SUSPENDED TO PERMIT SENATE BILL.
512-757-7680 AND ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE TO BE TAKEN UP FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONSIDERATION OF
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. MISTER
FLORA WHAT PURPOSE WE WITH
WILLIAMS JOHNSON ON THE
SUSPENSION AND ASTRAL CALL THE.
MEMBERS THIS RESOLUTION
SUSPENDS THE JOINT ROLES AND IS
NOT DEBATABLE IT DOES REQUIRE
FIFTY FOUR VOTES THE CLERK.
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AND I AM
MISTER FLORA NO ON THIS
RESOLUTION. THIS WILL TAKE
FIFTY FOUR. ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
ABOUT HER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND MR FLOORS AS HE
FOR NO BUT THIS TAKES FIFTY
FOUR VOTES MEMBERS.
MISTER
CALDERON MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS
I'M GOING TO LIFT THE CALL. ON
THE RULES COMMITTEE RESOLUTION
CARPOOL POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. THIS CALL THE
ROLL REPLACE THE CALL.
MEMBERS
WELL WE HAVE A- MOMENT OF
DOWNTIME. WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH OUR EPARTING
MEMBER TRIBUTES. AND THIS WILL
BE THE LAST COUPLE OF ASSEMBLY
SESSIONS FOR THE HONORABLE
TYLER DEEP. MEMBERS IF WE COULD
HAVE YOUR RESPECTFUL ATTENTION.
MR FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE TRIBUTE TO MR DEEP. I THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT IS THE- A
GREAT PLEASURE TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK. IN FAVOR OF IN IN
SUPPORT OF MY FRIEND TYLER
TODAY IN AND KIND OF WROTE THEM
A LITTLE BIT- YOU KNOW IF HE'S
BEEN HERE A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME AND YEAH CERTAINLY- YOU
KNOW HE'S MADE A LOT OF FRIENDS
AND HE'S- AND HE'S GREAT A LOT
OF FRUSTRATION FOR THE FOLKS AT
OUR SIDE TO. BUT I WAS THOUGH
THAT TYLER IS A GOOD FRIEND AND
NOW HIM THE BEFORE HE WAS
ELECTED AND- HE'S- HE'S ALWAYS
BEEN DEDICATED TO HIS COMMUNITY
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT NO ONE
WILL EVER TAKE THE TITLE FROM
TYLER A BEING THE CHEAPEST
MEMBER IN THE ASSEMBLY AND- AND
HE'LL EVEN AND I DON'T THINK
ANYONE'S EVER GONNA DISPUTE
THAT EITHER- I THINK THE NUMBER
OF TIMES I HAVE GONE TO DINNER
WITH TYLER. I DON'T THINK HE'S
PAID ONCE- IS A MAYBE ONE DAY
HELL YOU'RE ACTUALLY BY MEDIA
YOU KNOW I KNOW BURGER TO MAKE
UP FOR ALL THE OTHER DINNERS
I'VE GOT NO. MAYBE TALK ABOUT
BUT- HE'S ACTUALLY EVEN TO THE
POINT HAVE COMES INTO MY OFFICE
TAKES SODAS AND FOOD FOR MY
OFFICE AND TAKE IT TO HIS
OFFICE SO FOR THE MEMBERS WHO
MET WITH HIM IN HIS OFFICE
YOU'RE PROBABLY DRINKING SODA
AND WATER AND MEAL AND FOOD FOR
MY OFFICE HOURS YOU'RE WELCOME.
BUT I'M- TYLER NO DOUBT- IF ITS
OWN UNIQUE PERSON THERE WILL BE
ANOTHER NOTE WE WILL NEVER MEET
ANYONE ANOTHER KIND OF YEAH
AND- HE IS CERTAINLY HAS
BROUGHT A HE PRESENTS THE
ASSEMBLY WHICH HAS BROUGHT US
SMILES AND LAUGHS- IN ADDITION
TO EVERYTHING ELSE AND SO WE
WILL NO DOUBT FEEL- THE ABSENCE
OF TYLER IN HIS PERSONALITY-
WHEN HE LEAVES BUT HE'S A DEAR
FRIEND COMMITTED TO OUR STATE
COMMITTED TO ART AND TRYING TO
DO THE BEST WE CAN. AND YOU
KNOW I CERTAINLY CONSIDER HIM A
BROTHER AND I WILL CERTAINLY
MISS THEM. WE LEAVE THE
ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU MISTER BALL.
OTHER MEMBERS. MISTER LOWE IN
THE WELL OF THE ASSEMBLY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS WHERE'S WHERE'S TYLER.
ALL RIGHT. WELL I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THEY GIVE YOU THE DIGNITY
TO LOOK AT YOU FACE TO FACE. I
ACTUALLY HEARD ABOUT TYLER
EARLY ON- WHENI WAS A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER- BACK IN MY
EARLY TWENTIES. AND THE REASON
WHY IS BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY
OF US LIKE THAT. BECAUSE WE
WERE TOO YOUNG OR DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH EXPERIENCE. THE RED
SHIRTS AND TIES MEMBERS HAD
CERTAIN TIES ARE OLDER THAN US.
OR THAT WE WERE QUALIFIED. OR
THAT OUR JUDGMENT SHOULD BE
QUESTIONED. AND THERE WAS THIS
GUY NAMED TYLER DEEP WHO IS
SIMILARLY ELECTED AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY THREE. AND THEN WENT ON
TO CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AND VICE
MAYOR. CONTINUE TO SERVICE AS A
MEMBER OF THIS DISTINGUISHED
BODY IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
AND MANY OF US KNOW THAT
PERHAPS TYLER YOU'RE AHEAD OF
YOUR TIME FOR YOUR OWN DISTRICT.
BUT YOU'VE ALWAYS SOUGHT OUT TO
ENSURE THAT THE LOOK FOR
BIPARTISANSHIP AND HAVING AN
OPEN DOOR. ESPECIALLY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS IS A
HYPER POLITICIZED WORLD. AND I
WANT TO GET TO KNOW TYLER EVEN
THAT MUCH MORE AND SO I VISITED
IN IN HIS DISTRICTACTUALLY
CRASHED ONE OF HIS PARTY'S. AND
WHICH HAD A ROOM FULL
COMPLETELY FULL. OF SUPPORTERS.
AND IT WAS LIKE. IT WAS ALMOST
GOD LIKE IN THAT ROOM- BECAUSE
PEOPLE WANTED PICTURES WITH HIM
AND- YOU COULD SEE A SENSE OF
DEEP RESPECT. AND WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THAT OF THE PARTNERSHIP
HE ALSO HAS TAKEN A LEAP OF
FAITHIN REPRESENTING THE SENSE
OF INTEGRITY THAT HE ASKED
HIMSELF. AS THE FIRST IN HIS
EXTENDED FAMILY TO GRADUATE
FROM AN AMERICAN UNIVERSITY.
AND IT'S COMING TO THIS COUNTRY
AND PUBLICLY STATED THAT. HE
AND HIS FAMILY WERE PUBLIC
BENEFICIARIES. OF WELFARE AND
OF THE SOCIAL SAFETY NET THAT
WE HAVE CREATED FOR ALL PEOPLE.
AND THAT WHEN THE CURRENT
OCCUPANT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
SUPPORTED A POLICY THE CHANGE
IN POLICY. TO HAVE TAKEN SELECT.
CERTAIN TYPES OF IMMIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES. HE SPOKE OUT PUBLICLY.
AND WAS THERE FOR CAN BACKLASH
AS WELL. BUT AGAIN MEMBERS IN
THIS ERA IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE SPEAK TRUTH TO POWER. AND
OFTENTIMES THAT OUR OWN
POLITICAL PERIL TO WHICH WE
WILL BE MISSING YOU TYLER. BUT
AGAIN KNOWING THAT WE SERVE
WITH YOU OVER A PERIOD OF TIME.
YOUR SERVICE OF OVER A DECADE-
YOU WILL HAVE MANY MORE
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE VERY NEAR
FUTURE SO. I JUST WANTED. TO
ALLOW AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
REFLECT ON THE VERY SHORT TIME
THAT WE'VE HAD WITH YOU- BUT
KNOW THAT WE'LL BE SEEING MUCH
OF YOU IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO NOT ONLY TO THIS
INTITUTION BUT TO ALL PEOPLE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MR LOW. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. YESTERDAY THE ASSEMBLY
WISHES YOU THE VERY BEST MISTER
GIBSON ALSO WOULD LIKE TO SAY A
FEW WORDS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER- TO TYLER. WHEN
YOU FIRST CAME TO THE ASSEMBLY-
I WAS TRYING TO FIGURE YOU OUT.
TRYING TO FIGURE YOU OUT IN
TERMS OF WHAT. MAKES YOU TICK.
AND LET ME SIMPLY SAY I FIGURED
IT OUT. YOUR MAN. THAT IS LED
BY YOUR CONVICTIONS. YOU ARE
MAN THAT'S LED BY A HIGHER
BEING THAT YOU SUPPORT IF YOU
LOOK UP TO. IN TERMS OF. THE
PERSON THE MAN THAT HE WOULD
WAKE UP LOOK IN THE MIRROR EACH
AND EVERY DAY NOW I RESPECT
THAT THE SHORT TIME THAT WE'VE
HAD HERE IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY
I HAVE ABSOLUTELY GROWN TO
APPRECIATE. YOUR ENTHUSIASM
EVERY TIME I SEE. COMING TO THE
FLOOR W. W. TO YOU IN THE HALL.
HANGING OUT WITH US WHEN WE
WERE ABLE TO HANG OUT- BEFORE
COVERT NINETEEN ENTERED INTO
OUR WORLD. YOU HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
A VERY UPBEAT INDIVIDUAL. I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP I
APPRECIATE YOUR LONG STANDING
IN TERMS OF PROVIDING GREAT
LEADERSHIP TO THE PEOPLE YOU
WHICH YOU REPRESENT YOUR
DISTRICT. VOEPEL IN ASSEMBLY
BUT ALSO PRIOR TO THAT. I
APPRECIATE YOU. AND I
APPRECIATE WHEN YOU TELL ME AND
OTHERS THAT YOU CAN'T BE
SOMEWHERE. WE UNDERSTAND THAT-
YOU COME UP AND TELL US THAT
YOU CAN'T BE THERE ON SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE PUSHING I RESPECT
THAT. AND I RESPECT WHAT MY
MOTHER SAID THAT YOU CAN BE
DISAGREEABLE WITHOUT BEING
DISAGREEABLE. AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO UNDERSTAND
THAT MANTRA AND I CERTAINLY
BELIEVE AS A MAN OF FAITH THAT-
DELAYED DOESN'T MEAN TO NINE.
LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN DELAYED
DOES NOT MEAN DENIED IT JST
MEANS NOT RIGHT NOW I BELIEVE
YOU WILL WRITE A NEW CHAPTER A
NEW NARRATIVE- THAT'S GOING TO-
CATAPULT YOU INTO ANOTHER
DIMENSION TO BE ABLE TO SERVE
AND DO THE THINGS THAT YOU
ENJOY DOING. SO I WISH THAT YOU
WELL AND ALL THAT YOU THAT YOU
DO AND I STILL BELIEVE TYLER D.
THAT THE BEST IS STILL YET TO
COME FOR YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
GIPSON. AND MR COOLEY IS
REQUESTED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SAY A COUPLE WORDS MR COOLEY.
TYLER IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE
ON THIS DAY. I MANY MY
COLLEAGUES MAY NOT KNOW THAT
YOU AND I ACTUALLY MET BEFORE
YOU WERE SWORN IN. IN YOUR
DISTRICT AS I TOOK THE OCCASION
TO WELCOME A NEW MEMBER OF THIS
HOUSE. AND JUST TO TALK ABOUT
SERVICE HERE. AND I WANT TO SAY
I'VE KNOWN. PLENTY OF MEMBERS
WERE ONE FOR MEMBERS TYLER.
THEY'RE HERE FOR A TIME THEY
LEFT THE NEXT SORT OF DISAPPEAR.
WHAT THE CITY'S PERSON MYSELF
FIVE APPRECIATED THE GROUNDING.
IN ISSUES DO YOU HAVE BROUGHT
AS A PUBLIC SERVANT. LEARN
ABOUT PUBLIC SERVICE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. AND THEN YOU FOUND
YOURSELF HERE THIS EPIC SESSION.
WHEN WE HAD THE TUMULT OF
CLOVER TO DEAL WITH. AND THE
RANCOR. AND THE VITRIOL THAT WE
ARE SEEING IN OUR PUBLIC LIFE.
SO TO COME HERE IS RESERVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE WORK OF THIS BODY. TO
LET IT ENTER YOUR SOUL I JUST
KNOW. THAT YOU WILL HAVE A LONG
FUTURE OF SERVING OTHERS BEFORE
YOU. OF WHICH THIS IS A CHAPTER.
AND I KNOW THAT- ONE CANNOT
SERVE DILIGENTLY HERE WITHOUT
BEING CHANGED BY THE EXPERIENCE.
AND SO YOU WILL ALWAYS BE
WELCOME BACK ON THE SCREEN
CORPORATE. YOU'LL ALWAYS BE IN
THAT FRATERNITY OF THOSE FEW
CALIFORNIANS WILL PARKER
STREET. HAVE SERVE THE PUBLIC
TICKET IS GREAT OATH OF OFFICE
IN THIS CHAMBER. SO I JUST WANT
TO SAY I AM SORRY. THAT I WILL
NOT ENTER INTO BEING A MEMBER
WITH YOU- BEYOND THIS SESSION.
BUT I AM GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND OUR HAVE BEEN WHAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE GOT TO KNOW YOU
BEFORE K. FOR. WISH YOU ALL THE
BEST TIME. THANK YOU MR COOLEY
YESTERDAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER- AND MEMBERS FOR
GIVING ME A FEW MINUTES TO
SHARE WITH YOU MY- PARTING
THOUGHTS. WHEN I WAS ASKED BY
ZIGLAR'S OFFICE WHO I WANTED.
SECTION OF. SAY SOMETHING ABOUT
ME I PICK VINCE BECAUSE- I HANG
OUT WITH HIM THE MOST AND I
PICK EVAN BECAUSE- HE WAS OPEN
TO TEACHING ME. AS MUCH AS HE
COULDIN THE LAST TWO YEARS. I
DO WANNA RIGHT OR I DO WANT TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT WITH WITH
STATIC- FOR ME BECAUSE A IT IS
PROBABLY ISN'T AS GENUINE AND I
THINK YOU GUYS DESERVE AT LEAST
GET A GENUINE RESPONSE ON WHEN
I WAS ELECTED. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND CAME HERE IN.
EARLY EARLY JANUARY AND THE AND
AS A WALK FROM THE SHERATON TO
THE CAPITAL I HAD A LOT OF
EXCITEMENT ABOUT. THE
POSSIBILITY OF WHAT. I MAY BE
ABLE TO DO AS A MEMBER OF THE
PARTY. IN TACKLING THE BIG
ISSUES THAT WE AS A STATE IS
FACING. BUT AFTER YOU KNOW THE
FIRST FEW MONTHS. I. I GOT A
SENSE THAT IT WAS IT WAS A-
WITH THE TELL TALE AND I WAS
STRUGGLING TO FIT IN. AND NOT
THAT I WAS LOOKING TO BE- LIKE
OR ANYTHING BUT IT WAS IT WAS
TOUGH BECAUSE- LIKE VINCE
ALLUDED TO. A LOT OF MEMBERS A
LOT OF COLLEAGUES ON MY SIDE I
OVER. FRUSTRATED I REMEMBER.
THE REPUBLICAN WHO WOULD ROLL
THEIR EYES EVERY TIME I
BUILDING COMMITTEE. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME. I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SAY YES TO ANYTHING. THAT
DOCTOR SHIRLEY WEBER ASKED ME
TO DO. AND SHE WAS AT SAN DIEGO
STATE LAW I WAS A COLLEGE
STUDENT. SO IT DOES IT I GUESS
THIS IS. JUST THE REALITY OF
BEING FROM A SWING DISTRICT A
CHANGING DISTRICT CHANGING
COUNTY. AND I TRY MY BEST IN
THESE TWO YEARS TO DO THE BEST
I COULD ALL OF MY DISTRICT AND
NOT JUST FOR ONE GROUP. AND I
THINK I'M A LOT OF MISTAKES.
AND I LEARN FROM IT. SO I'M
GONNA TRY TO MAKE THE BEST OF
THE NEXT FORTY EIGHT HOURS AS
WE VOTE AND CONSIDERS OF THAT
IS A VERY VERY CONSEQUENTIAL
TO. THE STATE I WANT TO. SAY
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS. WHO
TOOK THE TIME TO BE NICE I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT WHEN YOU
KNOW YOU WALK PAST ME ON THE
HALLWAY OR ON THE STREET AND
YOU SAID HI. I APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH THE ASSEMBLY PROFESSIONAL
STAFF. FOR BEING VERY COURTEOUS
AND NEVER NOT ONCE MADE ME FEEL
LIKE SOME SORT OF SOME SORT OF
LIKE SECOND CLASS MEMBERS. AND
ALSO I WANT. TO AT THE STATE
SORRY TO MY TO MY PARENTS. I'VE
LOST ELECTION BEFORE AND I YOU
KNOW IT WILL EVENTUALLY GET
OVER IT. BUT MY BIGGEST
DISAPPOINTMENT IN LOSING THE
PRIMARY WITH MAKING MY PARENTS
VERY SET. THEY THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY. SO HOPEFULLY
I'LL MAKE THE PRESIDENT THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER FOR THAT.
MEMBERS I AM REFERRING THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY ROLE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO. I
DON'T NUMBER TWO. AB EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT EGGMAN TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. ITEM
NUMBER THREE A. B. EIGHT FORTY
SIX BURKE TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. I REMEMBER SIX AB
SEVENTEEN TEN WOULD TO THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE. I DON'T NUMBER SEVEN
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
JONES SAWYER TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. I REMEMBER.
FORTY SEVEN. AB TWO SEVEN SIX.
FRIEDMAN TO THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE. I ITEM
NUMBER. FIFTY SIX AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN PETRIE-NORRIS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER P. FIVE AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN BURKE TO THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE.
I AM NUMBER SIXTY FIVE. AB.
TWENTY ONE OH ONE. TO THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE. AB ITEM
NUMBER NINETY TWO AB NINE SEVEN
NINE HOLDEN TO THE BANKING AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE. I DON'T
NUMBER NINETY THREE AB THIRTEEN
OH FOUR WALDRON OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. AN ITEM
NUMBER NINETY FOUR AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN CERVANTES. TO THE
JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN
THE ECONOMY COMMITTEE.
MISTER
CALDERON YOU WERE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ORAL SEX TODAY TO A THE
FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW COMMITTEES TO HEAR THE
FOLLOWING BILLS BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE HERE AB
SEVENTEEN TEN WHAT TODAY UPON
CALL THE CHAIR IN A ROOM TO BE
ANNOUNCED. BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB NINE
SEVENTY NINE HOLDEN TODAY UPON
CALL OF THE CHAIR AND ROOM TO
BE ANNOUNCED JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND ECONOMY
COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN CERVANTES TODAY
UPON CALL OF THE CHAIR IN A
ROOM TO BE ANNOUNCED. PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB TWENTY ONE
A ONE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE TODAY UPON
CALL OF THE CHAIR AND ROOM TO
BE ANNOUNCED REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB
TWO SEVENTY SIX FRIEDMAN AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BURKE SB
FIFTY ONE DORADO AND SB
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN BRADFORD
TODAY UPON CALL THE CHAIR IN A
ROOM TO BE ANNOUNCED PENDING
RECEIPT. LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE CARILLO AND SB SEVEN
TWENTY ONE PORTANTINO ON MONDAY
AUGUST THIRTY FIRST PHONE CALL
CHAIR. IN A ROOM TO BE
ANNOUNCED. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THE REQUEST IS GRANTED. MEMBERS
RE READING AN ITEM PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
THREE AB THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
PETRIE-NORRIS TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS I'M GOING TO
LET THE CALL. ON THE RULES
COMMITTEE RESOLUTION. CLERICAL
POSTS. ALL MEMBERS ARE WHICH TO
VOTE. SO TWO THIRDS THRESHOLD.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL. TYLER
THE EYES FIFTY FOUR KNOWS.
FOURTEEN THE JOINT ROLES ARE
SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE ARE GOING TO BE
TAKING UP SENATE BILL FIFTY ONE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENT
CLERK WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
WHICH THIS CALL THE RUNS
AMENDMENTS DISCOVERY SENATE
BILL FIFTY ONE OF THE MEMBERS
BY SOME REMEMBER CALDERON
MISTER CALDERON ON THE MEN'S
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS SB FIFTY ONE RAZA WILL
ALLOW THE KALKA BEES TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM TO CONTINUE TO CATALYZE
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT CREATE
THOUSANDS OF HIGHWAYS JOBS BY
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY FOR BUSINESS
PARTICIPATING IN THE CAL
COMPETES TAX GOING TO PROGRAM
THE BILL WILL ALLOW THE PROGRAM
AWARDEES TO APPLY. OR PART OR
ALL OF THEIR AWARD TWO TAX
OFFSETS NOT EXCEEDING TOTAL
STATE TAX LIABILITY PROVIDED
THEY MAKE A LONG TERM HIGHWAY
TO JOB CREATION AND ECONOMIC
INVESTMENT COMMITMENT. WITHIN
THE STATE AND MEET SPECIFIC
CRITERIA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THINGS CALDERON
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
AMENDMENTS AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON HIS MEMBERS ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED
SAY NAY. YES HAVE AT THE MOMENT
SIR DOCTOR BILLS OUT THE
PRINTER BACK ON FILE. AND
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY POINT TWO I RE
REFERRING. SENATE BILL FIFTY
ONE TO RAZA TO THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE AND THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SOME AMENDMENTS.
WELL THE SENATE THIRD READING
FILE THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
TAKING UP AT THIS TIME.
OKAY
MEMBERS WE ARE LOOKING FOR
AUTHORS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE. I SEE DOCTOR
ARAMBULA AT HIS DESK. MEMBERS
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY.
SENATE BILL EIGHT OH THREE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
CALGARY WITH AMENDMENTS. SENATE
BILL EIGHT OH THREE WITH THE
MINUTES BY SIMPLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA. DOCTOR REGULARLY
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
ON SENATE BILL EIGHT OH THREE
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A
STATEWIDE CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
FOR PEER SUPPORT SPECIALIST AND
UNABLE TO THE STATE AND
COUNTIES TO DRAW DOWN FEDERAL
FUNDING. SB EIGHT OH THREE
ADOPTED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AMENDMENTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO EASE
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON SENATE BILL EIGHT OH
THREE. THANK YOU DOCTORING A
SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE
EYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
NOT TO THE BILLS UP TO PRINT.
BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE.
TAKING OF AMENDMENTS ON THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO SB
TWO SEVEN FIVE FOR THE PURPOSE
OF AMENDMENTS CORPORATE WITH
AMANDA SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY
FIVE OF THE MINUTES BY SIMPLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ MS GONZALEZ ON
THE AMENDMENTS. AT MISTER
SPEAKER I ADD THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS WERE AUTHORIZED IN
ASKED FOR BY THE AUTHOR AND
AGREED UPON BY ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
NAINA. THANK YOU RESIDENTS ALL
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE OF THE
AMENDMENTS AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
HEARD ON THE MERITS ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED
SAY NAY. YES SEVENTY MEMBERS
ARE DOTTED BILL SOUTH PRINT. IN
BACK ON FILE. WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE A MISTER DALY'S AMENDMENTS.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
SIX. SENATE BILL ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORPORATE AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FIFTY NINE
OF THE MINUTES BY SIMPLY MEMBER
DALY. MR DALY AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THESE AMENDMENTS TO SP ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE. HELP IMPROVE THIS
BILL THAT SEEKS TO PROVIDE
NECESSARY MEDICAL CARE FOR OUR
FRONT LINE WORKERS FIGHTING.
THE COVERT NINETEEN VIRUS THESE
AMENDMENTS CODIFY RECENT
NEGOTIATION AMONG. THE AUTHOR
IN A VARIETY OF STAKEHOLDERS IN
ORDER TO REMOVE OPPOSITION AND
BRING THE BILL INTO ITS FINAL
FORM. ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
CONTAINS AN URGENCY CLAUSE TO
ENSURE THAT THESE IMPORTANT
PROTECTIONS COME INTO EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS. THANKS
DALY SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE AMENDMENTS. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THIS WILL BE A VOICE
FOR ON THE MOMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR BILLS OUT TO
PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
I BELIEVE
MS KAMLAGER HAS AMENDMENTS.
WE
ARE TAKING UP AMENDMENTS ON THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY NINE SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX FOR THE PURPOSE
OF MANAGEMENT CORPORATE WITH
AMEND SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVENTY
SIX WITH A MINUTES BY SOME
REMEMBER KAMLAGER. IS KAMLAGER
ON THE MINUTES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THE AUTHORS TAKEN
AMENDMENTS WHICH NOW REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION FROM SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED
SAY NAY. YES SEVENTY MEMBERS
ARE DR. BILLS AT THE PRINTED
BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS I BELIEVE
AT THIS TIME WE ARE GOING TO BE
MOVING TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT. CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SEEING AND HERE NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
EIGHTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MULLIN OTHERS RELATIVE TO IRISH
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE IN THE
CONSENT. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. OKAY.
ALL
MEMBERS BETTER DESERVE OUT THIS
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MARKWELL. CLOSE ROLE IN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR I SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS ADOPTED. THE CLERK WILL READ
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR YEAH ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO POSSIBLE SOLUTION EIGHTY
NINE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE BILL FOR THIRTY TWO WITH
URGENCY I SIXTY THREE KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY
THREE NOTES HERE ON THE BILL
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SEVENTEEN I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE BILL
SEVEN TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO SENATE BILL ELEVEN
TWENTY THREE I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTY SEVEN. SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY SIX FIVE
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE BILL
NINE OH NINE WITH URGENCY I
SIXTY THREE DOES YOUR ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY THREE KNOWS ARE
ON THIS SENATE BILL THIRTY
EIGHT I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE BILL
SEVEN OH TWO I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE BILL EIGHT HUNDRED.
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE BILL
NINE OH THREE WITH URGENCY I
SIXTY THREE KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY THREE KNOWS ARE
ON THE BILL SENATE BILL NINE
EIGHTEEN HI I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY
ONE SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
BILL TOOL SEVENTY SIX FIVE
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE BILL
NINE TWENTY EIGHT WITH URGENCY
I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THE
URGENCY I SIXTY THREE KNOWS
YOU'RE ON HE BILL. SENATE BILL
NINE TWENTY NINE WITH URGENCY I
SIXTY THREE KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
AIR AND SEA ICE AND SHE THREE
KNOWS ARE ON THE BILL SENATE
BILL NINE THIRTY I SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO SENATE BILL NINE NINETY
EIGHT I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE BILL TWELVE TWELVE I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN I SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SIX I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE BILL TEN OH THREE
WITH URGENCY I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO THE URGENCY I SIXTY THREE
KNOWS ARE ON THE BILL. SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN OH FIVE I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE I SIXTY
THREE DOES ZERO SENATE BILL
FIVE TWENTY TWO I SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO SENATE BILL FIVE
SEVENTY THREE SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY
THREE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY I SIXTY
THREE KNOWS OR BELIEVES SEVENTY
EIGHT I SIXTY THREE NO. ZERO
ELEVEN FORTY ONE I SIXTY THREE
KNOWS ZERO SENATE BILL ELEVEN.
NINETY I SIX THREE NO SENATE
BILL TWELVE FIVE. I'VE THREE
KNOWS CYNICAL TULSA FOUR. I
SIXTY THREE KNOWS. SENATE BILL
TWELVE ONE URGENCY. I SIXTY
THREE KNOWS ON THE- I SIXTY
THREE KNOWS ARE ON THE- SO BILL
THIRTEEN A- I. THREE NO ZERO
SEVEN FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO CYNICAL
NINE SEVEN. I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE BILL NINE THIRTY TO
WITH URGENCY. I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO THEIR TO SEE I SIXTY THREE
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE BILL. AND
SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY TWO I.
SIXTY THREE KNOWS ZERO THANK
YOU DAVID.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO BE. RECESSING UNDER CALL OF
THE SPEAKER SO THE FOLLOWING
COMMITTEES MAY MEETS. PLEASE
PAY ATTENTION TO THE
ANNOUNCEMENT MEMBERS. IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- TO THE BANKING AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING AT THIS TIME FOLLOWED
BY THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE. AND THEN THE REVENUE
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE WILL
FOLLOW B. AND P. SO AGAIN IN
FORTY TWO OH TWO BANKING AND
FINANCE RIGHT NOW FOLLOWED BY
B. AND P. AND THEN THE REVENUE
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE WILL
THEN MEET. IN FORTY TWO OH TWO
IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN.
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING AT THIS TIME. FOLLOWED
BY THE JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY
COMMITTEE. AND LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING TOMORROW. UPON CALL OF
THE CHAIR MEMBERS WE ARE IN
RECESS UNDER CALL. STAY IN THE
BILL MEMBERS PLEASE STAY IN THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. PLEASE STAY
IN THE CAPITOL BUILDING WE'RE
IN RECESS AND A CALL.
PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO I AM REFERRING. ITEM
ONE FIFTY SEVEN S. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN BY BRADFORD TO THE
REVENUE AND TAX COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WE ARE RE CONVENING
SESSION. HOUSES BACK IN ORDER.
MEMBERS WE ARE WE GET
RECONVENING SESSION HOUSES BACK
IN ORDER.
STRAWBERRIES MISTER
CALDERON FOR WHAT REASON THE
RISE YOU CAN JUST RECOGNIZING
HI MISTER CALDERON HOW ARE YOU
I'M RECOGNIZED AS A CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED I DO REALLY LIKE YOU
YEAH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT-
MISTER SPEAKER I JUST WANT TO
ASK THAT MEMBERS PLEASE COME
DOWN TO THE FLOOR WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK WE KNOW IT'S GOING TO
BE A LATE NIGHT BUT WE NEED TO
START WORKING ON SENATE BILLS
OF ALL MEMBERS CAN REPORT TO
THE FLOOR IMMEDIATELY SO WE CAN
GET WORK DONE. THAT WOULD BE
GREATLY APPRECIATED THANK YOU
THE SECOND KALRA.
MEMBERS
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR SO
WE CAN COMMENCE THE ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS.
YEAH MEMBERS. WE WILL
START RESUME WORK ON THE DAILY
FILE. OF STARTING WITH A FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE FORTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
TWELVE TWENTY BY CENTER OF
BERGEN ACCOLADE OF PEACE
OFFICERS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PARA
QUE HAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SP TWELVE TWENTY ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR UMBERG. WHICH CODIFIES
IN CLARIFIES CASE LAW BY
ESTABLISHING A STATEWIDE
STANDARD FOR THE COMPLIANCE OF
BRADY OBLIGATIONS. BY DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. UNDER BRADY VERSUS
MARYLAND THE SUPREME COURT HELD
THAT THE PROSECUTION HAS A
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION. NOT
ONLY TO DISCLOSE WHAT IS
ALREADY KNOWN TO PROSECUTORS.
BUT ALSO TO LEARN OF ANY SUCH
INFORMATION THAT IS KNOWN TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT GENERALLY.
INCLUDING MATTERS RELATED TO
WITNESS CREDIBILITY EVEN OUT OF
PEACE OFFICERS AND TO MAKE THAT
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO THE
DEFENSE. ALTHOUGH BRADY AND
SUBSEQUENT DECISIONS HAVE BEEN
PUT IN PLACE FOR MANY DECADES.
SOME LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ARE NOT ABLE TO FULLY OBSERVE
ITS REQUIREMENTS ARE COMPLIED
THROUGH. ORGANIZATIONAL POLICY
OR PRACTICE BECAUSE OF THE LACK
OF CLARITY AND CONFUSING
PATCHWORK A VERY POLICIES
ACROSS PROSECUTORIAL
JURISDICTIONS. IN CURRENT LAW
CENTERED STICTION PROVIDE A
ROBUST AD FAIR PROCESS FOR
WHEN OFFICES ARE PUT ON THE
BRADY LIST. AND ALSO OFFERED.
NOTICE TO THE OFFICERS BEFORE
OR AFTER THEY ARE PUT ON THIS
LIST. HOWEVER SOME
JURISDICTIONS HAVE NO PROCESS
WHATSOEVER TO NOTIFY THE
OFFICERS AT ALL. ANOTHER
PROBLEM IS THAT BRADY DOES NOT
PROVIDE A BRIGHT LINE RULE ON
THE TYPES OF INFORMATION THAT
MUST BE REVEALED. AND
APARTMENTS CAN HAVE DIFFICULTY
ESTABLISHING PROTOCOLS AND
COMPILING BREEDING MATERIALS
FROM RECORDS THE BABY'S BED
SPREAD. THROUGHOUT A DEPARTMENT.
IN LOSS JURISDICTION INTER THIS
PROBLEM BY PUTTING FOLKS ON THE
BRADY LIST YOU SHOULD NOT BE ON
IT WELL OTHER JURISDICTIONS
INTERPRET BRADY TOO NARROWLY.
FAILING TO CAPTURE OFFICERS WHO
SHOULD BE ON IT. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS SB TWELVE TWENTY AIMS
TO FOUR STRIKE A DELICATE
BALANCE BETWEEN PROSECUTORS
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATIONS AND
DUE PROCESS PROTECTIONS FOR
PEACE OFFICERS. BECAUSE AS IT
STANDS AT THISMOMENT DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND DEFENSE COUNSEL
DON'T HAVE COMPLETE ACCESS TO
CONSTITUTIONALLY MANDATED
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE. AND
WITHOUT THIS INFORMATION
AVAILABLE PROSECUTORS AND
COUNSEL FOR THE DEFENDANTS ARE
UNAWARE THIS PURPOSE CONTACT
FOR THE OFFICERS TESTIFYING IN
THE CASE. THEREFORE SB TWELVE
TWENTY REQUIRES THESE AGENCIES
TO MAINTAIN PERSONAL RECORDS OF
PEACE OFFICERS TO PROVIDE
PROSECUTING AGENCIES A LIST OF
NAMES AND BADGE NUMBERS OF
OFFICERS EMPLOYED BY THE
AGENCY. IN THE FIVE YEARS
PRECEDING THEIR REQUEST WHO
MEET SPECIFIED CRITERIA IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE BRADY CASE
AND SUBSEQUENT DECISIONS.
PROSECUTING AGENCIES WILL BE
REQUIRED TO KEEP THIS LIST
CONFIDENTIAL EXCEPT AS
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED.
LASTLY SB TWELVE TWENTY
ESTABLISHES MINIMUM DUE PROCESS
STANDARDS FOR OFFICERS BY
REQUIRE PROSECUTING AGENCIES
BEFORE PLACING AN OFFICER'S
NAME ON THE BRADY LIST. TO
NOTIFY THE OFFICER AND PROVIDE
THE OFFICER AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REQUEST THE PROSECUTING AGENCY
REMOVE THE OFFICER FROM THE
LAST. MEMBERS THIS BILL TAKES A
BALANCED APPROACH TO CODIFYING
THE CASE FOR DECISION. YES YOU
WILL SEE AND IF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
OPPONENTS OF THE LEGISLATION
FALL INTO TWO CAMPS. LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS BELIEVE THE
BILL IS TOO BROAD AND THEN
NOTICED AN APPEAL PROVISIONS
GIVEN OFFICERS ARE
INSUFFICIENT. CIVIL LIBERTIES
GROUPS MAY BELIEVE THAT THE
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS AREN'T
BROAD ENOUGH IN THE OFFICER
SHOULD NOT BE ENTITLED TO ANY
NOTIFICATION OR APPEALS
PROCESS. IN ORDER TO ELEVATE.
SOME CONCERNS THE BILL AS
AMENDED. IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
CAN. WITH THE HELP INCREASE.
ALLOCATE IDEAS AND CLARIFY THE
BILL SHALL NOT BE INTERPRETED
TO LIMIT THE PROSECUTORS
DISCOVERED OBLIGATIONS UNDER
BRADY. WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BEAUTIFULLY CRAFTED FINAL
PRODUCT IS FAIR TO BOTH SIDES
SEARCH TO STRENGTHEN THE
ARGUMENT THAT THIS BILL STRIKES
A GOOD BALANCE BETWEEN THE
INTERESTS OF ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
MEMBERS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE-
THANK YOU HIS PARA QUE HAN. SEE
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE
VOTES HIGHS FORTY THREE NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY FIVE SB THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY NINE
BY SENATOR GLAZERS ACCOLADE TO
TAXATION. MISTER GRIFFIN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES. SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE WOULD
PROVIDE THE CURRENT PART
DISTRICT TAXES IN THE CURRENT
AND POTENTIAL CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION TAXES. DO
NOT COUNT AGAINST THE STATEWIDE
2% CAP ON LOCAL SALES AND USE
TAXES. THIS BILL DOES NOT RAISE
TAXES IT JUST CREATES ROOM
UNDER THE STATEWIDE CAP THE
COUNTY AND CITIES WITHIN THE
COUNTY WOULD STILL BE. TO SEEK
VOTER APPROVAL FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SALES TAX MEASURE.
CITIES AND COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE ARE RESPONSIBLE WITH
PROVIDING THEIR CONSTITUENTS
WITH THE NUMBER OF SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TO ADDRESS LOCAL NEEDS.
THIS INCLUDES POLICE AND FIRE
SERVICES HOMELESS SERVICES AND
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES. THESE
SERVICES ARE ESPECALLY
IMPORTANT DURING TIMES OF
CRISIS DO TO COPE WITH CITIES
IN CONTRA COSTA ARE ESTIMATING
LOSSES IN REVENUE OF UP TO
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS. THE
COUNTY ESTIMATES A NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED MILLION REDUCTION IN
ESTIMATED REVENUE YET THE NEED
FOR PUBLIC SERVICES IS LIKELY
TO RISE IN THE AFTERMATH OF
THIS PANDEMIC. THIS BILL IS A
REASONABLE MEASURE TO PROVIDE
AN AVENUE FOR RAISING NECESSARY
FUNDING IN THE COUNTY AGAIN ANY
MEASURES FOR ADDITIONAL SALES
TAXES WOULD STILL REQUIRE VOTER
APPROVAL TO INCREASE SALES TAX
IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. SIMILAR
MEASURES HAVE PASSED IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN RECENT YEARS.
FOUR OTHER COUNTIES AS WELL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON
THING HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THEIR- ALL MEMBERS. GO TO
THEIR TO VOTE. HOME VOTE TO
THEIR VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
VOTE. OUR NOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. FIRST FORTY ONE ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
IT'S A GREAT MOVE THE CALL.
LUDA FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN SP
ONE THIRTY TWO THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY TWO
BY SENATOR WIENER ANOTHER
PERSON ACCOLADE CORRECTIONS. MR
STERN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS SB ONE THIRTY TWO IS A
BILL THAT HAS BEEN WORKED ON
OVER THE LAST YEAR. CENTER
WINNERS BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH CDC ARE TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT CAN IN FACT BE
IMPLEMENTED APPROPRIATELY.
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOUSED IN OUR PRISONS ARE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST AND
SOMETIMES VERY STRUGGLE AND
STRUGGLE A LOT THE LEAD LIVES
THAT ARE CLOSE TO VIOLENCE
OFTENTIMES NOT OF THEIR DOING
BUT OTHERS TO THEM. WHAT SB ONE
THIRTY TWO DOES IS THROUGH THE
INTAKE PROCESS AND OTHER
PROCESSES THAT CDCR ENSURES
THAT PEOPLE ARE CLASSIFIED BY
THEIR GENDER IDENTITY THEIR
ACTUAL GENDER IDENTITY AND GIVE
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY SINCE
THEY'RE IN OUR PRISONS TO
SERVE. IN A IN A SITUATION
WHERE THEY CAN HAVE THE MOST
DIGNITY THE MOST OPPORTUNITY TO
BE SUCCESSFUL ATTEND THE
PROGRAM SAID THEY THAT THEY
NEED TO ATTEND. AND SURVIVE IN
A VERY VERY DIFFICULT SITUATION
THE ONLY OPTION NOW. IS FOR.
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRANSGENDER TO
BE MOVED TO ISOLATION AND THAT
IS NOT FAIR TO THEM IT IS NOT
APPROPRIATE TO THEM AS THEY
SERVE THEIR SENTENCE IT IS NOT
EVEN HUMANE. THIS IS A BILL TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AND IT HAS
BEEN WORKED ON TO ENSURE THAT
IT CAN BE IMPLEMENTED BY CDCR.
AND TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
ISSUES THAT HAD BEEN RAISED.
THIS IS AN AGREEMENT THAT HAS
BEEN REACHED. WITH THE C. R.
AND THE SENATOR TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE FEW TRANSGENDER FOLKS WHO
ARE IN OUR PRISONS. HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SERVE THEIR TIME
WITH DIGNITY WITH SAFETY AND
APPROPRIATE TO THEIR ACTUAL
IDENTITY I FOR YOUR I. HAVE A-
THANK YOU MISTRESS. YOU ARE. ON
THE MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I RISE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY TWO THIS
BILL AIMS TO ENSURE THAT
INCARCERATED TRANS GENDER NON
BINARY AND INTERSEX PEOPLE IN
THE CUSTODY OF CDC ARE ARE NOT
FORCED. TO REMAIN IN FACILITIES
AT SKYROCKET THEIR CHANCES OF
BEING SUBJECTED TO VIOLENCE.
THIS BILL DOES NOT IMPEDETHE
ABILITY OF CDCR TO MAINTAIN
THEIR EXISTING PROTOCOL TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY AND PRIVACY
OF ALL INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY GENDER IDENTITY. SB
ONE THIRTY TWO ALSO DOES NOT
PREVENT ARE FROM THE ANY CARS
OR TO PERSONS REQUEST TO
TRANSFER FACILITIES SHOULD CDC
ARE BE ABLE TO ARTICULATE A
SPECIFIC SECURITY OR MANAGEMENT
CONCERN. IT IS IMPERATIVE TO
NOTE THAT THE BILL YOU SEE
TODAY COMES AFTER CONSTANT
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE SP
ONE THIRTY TWO COALITION THE
AUTHOR NCDC ARE. TRANSGENDER
ODDS ARE HUMAN RIGHTS THANK YOU
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVALS. THANK YOU MISS
RARE THING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER AND THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THERE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS NOTED THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE
THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE. THE
CALL. WILL PASS THE RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN. HAS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
. ONE
TWENTY. LIVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY ONE SB NINE. IT'S.
IT
WING ONE TWENTY ONE FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY ONE SB NINE FORTY
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
NINE FORTY BY CENTERVILLE
ANOTHER PERSON ACCOLADE IN THE
LAND USE POWER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT
SB NINE FORTY BY SENATOR JIM
BELL. A BILL TO AUTHORIZE THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE TO MAKE SMART
ZONING UPDATES THAT WILL
PROTECT OUR OPEN SPACE AND
REDUCE SPRAWL IN MY DISTRICT
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE IS
CURRENTLY WORKING ON AN
AGGRESSIVE PLAN TO UPDATE ITS
ZONE TO INCREASE IN HOUSING AND
URBAN CORE AND AROUND TRANSIT.
IN COMPLY WITH REASON STATE LAW
CHANGES IN ORDER TO STAY IN
COMPLIANCE WITH OTHER STATE
LAWS AND MEET DEADLINES THE
CITY NEEDS AUTHORIZATION TO GET
TO WORK NEXT YEAR SB NINE FORTY
AUTHORIZES CITY AS THOUSAND UPS
OWN HOUSING SIZE. AND THEN USE
THEIR DOWNS ON CAPACITY TO
PROTECT OPEN SPACE LAND BY DOWN
ZONING SITES OUTSIDE OF THE
URBAN AREA THIS BILL IS CRAFTED
TO ENSURE THERE IS NO NET LOSS
ZONING. AND NO DECREASE TO THE
CITY'S HOUSING CAPACITY WITHOUT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISTER KALRA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. HOME
AND VOTED THEIR TO THE- ON
MEMBERS VOTE VERY. YOUR WORK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY FIVE NEWS
HERE THE MEASURE PASSES. WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS ONE
TWENTY TWO. THROUGH. ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. FILEITEM ONE TWENTY
EIGHT S. B. ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT BISON JONES
AN ACCOLADE IN THE CIVIL LAW.
MISTER ROBERTS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- S. B. ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT
IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD A BILL
THAT WAS PULLED FROM CONSENT
FOR CHAPTER IN AMENDMENTS SB
ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT MAKES TO
NARAL CHANGES TO THE NON
JUDICIAL FORECLOSURE LAWS IN
THE CIVIL CODE. FIRST THE BILL
AMENDS HOW PUBLICATION OF
NOTICES OF SALES ARE PRESCRIBED
BY SLIGHTLY EXPANDING WHERE AND
HOW THESE NOTICES ARE PUBLISHED
TO ENCOURAGE MORE COMPETITION
TO HELP REDUCE PLUS THIS BILL
ELIMINATES THE CITY PUBLICATION
REQUIREMENT IN CURRENT LAW AND
INSTEAD ALLOWS NOTICES TO BE
PRINTED ANYWHERE AND THE PUBLIC
NOTICE DISTRICT OR COUNTY WHEN
NECESSARY. THE AUTHORS SPONSORS
HAVE WORKED WITH A CALIFORNIA
NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION AND THEY ARE
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL SECOND THE
BILL ALSO ADDRESSES THE FILING
OF A DECLARATION OF NON
MONETARY STATUS IN LAWSUITS
INVOLVING TRUSTEES WHO ARE
NAMES BECAUSE OF THEIR STATUS
AS A TRUSTEE. A DECLARATION OF
NON MONETARY STATUS TELLS A
CORDON PARTIES THAT THE TRUSTEE
DOES NOT INTEND TO DEFEND THE
ACTION AND WILL BE BOUND BY THE
COURT'S DECISION. HE SAYS NOT
OFF COURSE TREAT THE FILING OF
THESE DECLARATIONS THE SAME. SB
ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT CLARIFIES
THAT THESE DECLARATIONS ARE
FILED WITHOUT A FEE STATEWIDE.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS NO HAS NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER ROBERTS
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
NOTED THERE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
WHERE TWELVE CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TYRONE I SIXTY ONE NEWS HERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES. IF YOU
WANT TO GO. BUT WE WILL MOVE
BACK UP IN FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
TWO SB NINE OH FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL NINE OH
FIVE BY CENTER ARCHULETA AND I
BELIEVE IN THE PRIVACY GONZALEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS SB NINE
OH FIVE PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF
CALIFORNIANS BY NO LONGER
REQUIRING A RESIDENCE ADDRESS
ON A BACKGROUND CHECK.
CALIFORNIA ALLOWS AND
ENCOURAGES ORGANIZATIONS TO
REQUEST ALL OF AN APPLICANT'S
RECORDS OF CONVICTIONS FROM UP
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE IF THE APPLICANT WOULD
BE IN CONTACT WITH A MINOR OR
ANOTHER IN THEIR CARE. THIS IS
A GOOD THING THIS MEASURE IS
PRUDENT AS STEP IN ENSURING
SAFETY OF MINERS OR OTHER
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS HOWEVER
THESE REQUESTS CAN BE EXPLOITED
TO DIVULGE THE LOCATION OF
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE PLYING TO VOLUNTEER IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES SO THE
BACKGROUND CHECK WOULD STILL
APPLY BUT THE ACTUAL ADDRESS OF
THE PERSON BEING CHECKED WOULD
NOT BE ON THAT APPLICATION.
THESE BACKGROUND CHECKS CAN
POTENTIALLY BE USED TO
DISSEMINATE PERSONAL
INFORMATION WITHOUT A PROPER
WARRANT CONSTANT CONSTITUTING
AN UNLAWFUL SEIZURE THE FEAR
THIS PERSONAL INFORMATION BEING
TAKEN EAD INDIVIDUALS TO BE
AFRAID OF VOLUNTEERING IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES DURING THIS COVERED
CRISIS WE NEED MORE VOLUNTEERS
THAN EVER. BY NOT REQUIRING THE
ADDRESS ON THESE BACKGROUND
CHECKS TO BE DIEBOLD'S WE CAN
PROVIDE ASSURANCES TO THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY CAN
VOLUNTEER IN THE COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT RISKING THEIR OWN
SAFETY AND SECURITY BUT IT
WOULD ALSO PROHIBIT THE D. D.
O. G. FROM PROVIDING ANY
INFORMATION RELATED TO THESE
BACKGROUND INQUIRIES TO OTHER
ENTITIES INCLUDING FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES. ABSENT A COURT ORDER
OR WARRANT. IT DOES NOT
OBSTRUCT SORTIES IN THEIR DUTY
KEEP K. SAFE FROM PREDATORS IN
FACT SB NINE OH FIVE WOULD
INTRODUCE A UNIVERSAL CITATION
A BACKGROUND CHECK LANGUAGE
INTO LAW. MEETING THE FBI
STANDARDS IN SIMPLIFYING THE
PROCESS AND REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF REQUESTS FOR FEDERAL
CRIMINAL RECORDS THEIR DENIED
BY THE FBI. A. B. SB NINE OH
FIVE ADDS TO THE EXISTING
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS OF CITIZENS
AND IN. PARTICULAR
UNDOCUMENTED. AND DOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS. WITHIN THE STATE
WITHOUT IMPEDING THE ABILITY OF
THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE TO
INVESTIGATE THOSE INTERACTING
WITH VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
PUT FORWARD BY THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO HAVE THOSE WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED. VOLUNTEER HAVE
COMPLETE BACKGROUND CHECKS BUT
THEY'RE ADDRESS NOT E GIVEN TO
FEDERAL OFFICIALS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. WHERE TO GO.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED ABOUT THIS FIRST FORTY
ONE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW HE VOTER EYES FORTY
FOUR NO ZERO THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS ONE
TWENTY NINE THROUGH ONE THIRTY
FIVE FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY SIX
FIFTY TO EIGHTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT BY SENATOR WIENER
AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. MISS
FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR WIENER THIS
BILL IS A TWO YEAR PILOT FOR A
NO COST ECONOMIC STIMULUS THAT
WILL JUMP START SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS. WHICH
ARE AN ESSENTIAL PART OF OUR
RECOVERY FROM KOBE NINETEEN. WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO DELAY
COMMONSENSE PROJECTS THAT
CREATE JOBS REVIVAL ECONOMIES
IMPROVE TRANSPORTATION CONNECT
COMMUNITIES IMPROVE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC HAS LEFT OUR PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IN
FINANCIAL RUIN AND WE NEED TO
TAKE A CREATIVE APPROACH TO
ENSURING THAT PUBLIC MONEY
GOING INTO TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS THE DUAL
PURPOSE OF PUTTING PEOPLE BACK
TO OUR WORK. AND REALIGNING
INFRASTRUCTURE DECISIONS WITH
CLIMATE AND EQUITY. THIS BILL
WILL EXPEDITE APPROVAL A
PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLE
FACILITIES AS WELL AS CERTAIN
BUS AND LIGHT RAIL
INFRASTRUCTURE BY STREAMLINING
THEM THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT. ALL
PROJECTS CONTRACTED OUT FOR
THIS BILL WILL BE SUBJECT TO
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE GOOD PAY
AND DIGNIFIED WORKING
CONDITIONS FOR CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS. THIS BILL WILL UNLOCK
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GETTING
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AN EX BUT I
CLIMATE FRIENDLY TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR ALL THOSE
BENEFITS I REQUEST WE REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE ON S. B. TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THERE ARE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED EITHER TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. YEAH. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TELEVOTE I FIFTY FIVE NEWS TO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
BACK UP IN FIVE ORDER TO FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO SB SIX
TWENTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY NINE BY
SENATOR REQUIREMENT OTHERS AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
THIS COMMA ARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I'M RISING TO PRESENT
SB SIX TWENTY NINE THE FREEDOM
OF THE PRESS ACT ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR MCGUIRE. UNFORTUNATELY
THROUGHOUT THIS YEAR WE HAVE
SEEN WITH GREAT CLARITY THAT.
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS IS UNDER
ATTACK HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND IN OUR OWN STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ACCORDING TO THE
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS FOUNDATION
AND THE COMMITTEE TO PROTECT
JOURNALISM. JOURNALIST THERE
WERE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
REPORTED AGGRESSIONS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AGAINST MEMBERS OF THE
PRESS WORKING AT FIRST
AMENDMENT EVENTS SUCH AS
MARCHES AND PROTESTS. SO FAR
THIS YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY
THERE HAVE BEEN OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED. THIS LAST MAY IN
CALIFORNIA WE SAW REPORTER
SUFFER FROM DETAINMENTRUBBER
BULLETS TEAR GAS AND GENERAL
OBSTRUCTION FROM FULFILLING.
THEIR DUTY OF GATHERING AND
SHARING THE NEWS AT FIRST I MET
AT FIRST AMENDMENT EVENTS.
CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA MEMBERS
OF THE PRESS ARE GRANTED
PROTECTIONS AS THEY ENTER AREAS
CLOSE BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
DURING NATURAL DISASTERS SUCH
AS FIRES FLOODS IN EARTHQUAKES.
THIS AUTHORIZATION IS CRITICAL
AS IT ALLOWS REPORTERS TO
ATTEND. AND GATHER INFORMATION
ON EVENTS TO RELATE TO THE
PUBLIC AS WELL AS GO OUT DURING
CURFEWS AT TIMES OF NATURAL
DISASTER. WE KNOW THAT THESE
PROTECTIONS SERVE AN ESSENTIAL
PURPOSE HOWEVER THEY DO NOT
EXPRESSLY EXTENDED TO EVENTS
SUCH AS MARCHES RALLIES
DEMONSTRATIONS AND PROTESTS.
DUE TO EVENTS IN MAY AND THIS
AMBIGUITY IN THE LAW SB SIX TO
NINE HAVE BEEN AMENDED TO
EXTEND THESE CRUCIAL
PROTECTIONS TO MEMBERS OF THE
PRESS AND THE INTER AND REPORT
ON EVENTS PROTECTED BY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT. IT DOES SO BY
PROHIBITING LAW ENFORCEMENT
FROM INTENTIONALLY ASSAULTING.
INTERFERING WITH OR OBSTRUCTING
REPORTERS AS THEY FULFILL THEIR
DUTIES AT THESE EVENTS.
ADDITIONALLY SB SIX TO NINE
ALLOWS REPORTERS THE CHANCE TO
CHALLENGE THEIR DETAINMENT OR
LACK OF ACCESS BY WORKING WITH
MANAGEMENT ON SCENE. THIS
LANGUAGE PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
SAFETY NET TO REPORTERS WERE
NOT GRANTED ACCESS OR
INTENTIONALLY DETAINED OR
MISTAKENLY DETAINED. THIS BILL
IS SUPPORTED BY THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION ETHNIC
MEDIA SERVICES AND THE
REPORTERS COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS CONNOR
MISTER JONES ARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX TO NINE. BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
WHICH NEED GRANT PROTECTION TO
MEMBERS OF THE PRESS AND THE
ATTENDANT REPORT ON EVENTS SUCH
AS RALLIES MARCHES AND
DEMONSTRATIONS DURING THIS
YEAR'S BLACK LIVES MATTER AND
ANTI RACISM PROTESTS WE SAW
STARK RISING REPORTED
AGGRESSIONS AGAINST JOURNALISTS
WHO ATTENDED THESE PROTESTS FOR
THE PURPOSE OF REPORTING ON
THEM. IT IS UNACCEPTABLE BACK
IN OUR OWN STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE SEEN REPORTERS
REPEATEDLY IN DERBY INTERESTED
ARE ASSAULTED AS THEY DO THEIR
JOB OF GATHERING OF NEWS AT
THESE EVENTS. THIS BILL WOULD
EXTEND EXISTING AUTHORIZATION
TO REPORTERS AS THEY ENTER
CLOSED AREAS A DEMONSTRATION SO
THEY CAN SAFELY REPORT ON THESE
EVENTS AND AUTHORITY ALREADY
GRANTED IN SITUATIONS OF
NATURAL DISASTERS THESE PAST
FEW MONTHS HAVE DEMONSTRATED
THESE PROTECTIONS ARE URGENTLY
NEEDED AND FOR THAT REASON I
WILL. BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
JONES SAWYER. THE AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISCON THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN. MEMBERS VOTED THIRTY VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS GO TO THE ART OF A.
OUR MEMBERS THIRTY THERE'D
ABOUT THIS CAR'S FORTY ONE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
IT'S GONNA REMOVE THE CALL.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY THIRD
EIGHT SB NINE SEVENTY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
NINE SEVENTY FOUR BY CENTER
DONNA WHEN OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY IS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT SB NINE SEVEN FOUR
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR HER TADO.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW SMALL RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AND BEYOND HAVE
EXPERIENCED DRY WATER WELLS
DURING CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC
DROUGHT AND NON DROUGHT YEARS
FOR THESE COMMUNITIES
UNDERTAKING WATER QUALITY
PROJECTS IS CRITICAL BUT
GUIDELINES ARE BOTH TIME AND
COST PROHIBITIVE. SB NINE SEVEN
FOUR CREATES A NARROWLY CRAFTED
STATUTORY EXEMPTION FOR THE
WATER PROJECTS IN THESE AREAS
WHILE ALSO SAFEGUARDING THE
ENVIRONMENT AND SENSITIVE
HABITATS. THIS BILL HELPS
REDUCE COSTS AND SAVE TIME ON
PROJECTS THAT ADDRESS SAFE
DRINKING WATER CHALLENGES. FOR
STATES DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. SB NINE SEVEN FOUR
IS SPONSORED BY SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES IN THE RURAL
COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON THE- THIRD OF THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING TELEVOTE
ICE FORTY NINE NEWS TO THIS
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY SEVEN SB THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
BY CENTER GALGIANI INOCULATED
MISSING PERSONS. YOUR DAILY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS
PROPOSAL CREATES STATEWIDE
CONSISTENCY FOR THE HANDLING OF
MISSING PERSONS CASES.
CURRENTLY GOVERNING BODIES OF
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CAN EXEMPT
THEMSELVES FROM MISSING PERSONS
REPORT REQUIREMENTS. THE AUTHOR
AND I BELIEVE IT'S PROPER THAT
ALL JURISDICTIONS FALL THE SAME
PROCEDURES OUTLINED IN THE
PENAL CODE TO ENSURE A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER DALY
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF THE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE I FIFTY NINE NEWS
HERE THE MEASURE PASSES. MR
GRAYSON IS PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON SB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS GO
TO DESIRE TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY ONE KNOWS
NINETEENTH MEASURE PASSES. WE
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY AND
VIOLATED ONE THIRTY EIGHT
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
NINE SB SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
ALAN OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY THIS
FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SB SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN MAKES
LARGE SCALE ZERO EMISSIONS MASS
TRANSIT CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS-
DOUBLE TO BE IS IT DESIGNATED
AS ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP
PROJECTS. BY THE GOVERNOR
EXPEDITING THE SECRET JUDICIAL
REVIEW PROCESS AND POTENTIALLY
SPEEDING UP OPERATION BY MONTHS
OR EVEN YEARS. ALTHOUGH
IMPRESSIVE THE SEVENTEEN
PROJECTS DESIGNATED UNDER AB
NINE HUNDRED FOR SPECIALISTS TO
TREATMENT SO FAR. CANNOT
DELIVER THE MAGNITUDE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIANS AS A SUBWAY. LIGHT
RAIL OR OTHER ZERO EMISSIONS
FIXED GUIDEWAY TRANSIT LINES.
NOT ANY TRANSIT PROJECT CAN
QUALIFY FOR A TRUNCATED SECRET
TIMELINE UNDER THIS BILL TO BE
CLEAR. PROJECTS MUST WITHOUT
USING OFFSETS DISPLAYS MILLIONS
OF VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF METRIC
TONS OF GREENHOUSE GASES OVER
THE COURSE OF THEIR OPERATION.
THEY MUST ALSO DEMONSTRATE
INCORPORATION OF CLIMATE
RESILIENCY SUSTAINABILITY AND
MITIGATION PRACTICES INTO THEIR
CONSTRUCTION AND INTO THEIR
DESIGN. THE SOONER
TRANSFORMATIVE ENVIRONMENTALLY
BENEFICIAL TRANSIT PLANS
COMPLETE THE FULL CYCLE PROCESS
THE FASTER THEY WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY DISPLAYS LESS
EFFICIENT AND MORE POLLUTION
INTENSIVE REGIONAL TRIPS. TAKEN
BY PASSENGERS AND PRIVATE
VEHICLES. EACH ADDITIONAL DAY
ROADS ARE CONGESTED AND DRIVERS
TAKE TRIPS ALONE IN THEIR
VEHICLES MASSIVE QUANTITIES OF
CARBON DIOXIDE IT KNOCKS AND
DIESEL PARTICULATES ARE OMITTED
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. OFTEN IN
SOME OF THE WORST POLLUTED
BASINS IN THE COUNTRY. S. B.
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN WILL ALSO GET
PEOPLE TO WORK FASTER RATE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. IT IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND IS
BACKED BY THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN. SEEING AND HEARING
OVER THE DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN ALL MEMBERS
VOTED EITHER TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE TO DO
THEIR TO VOTE. WORK WELL CLOSE
THE ROLLING TELEVOTE ICE FIFTY
SIX KNOWS ONE THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY SB EIGHT NINETY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
EIGHT NINETY FIVE BY SOONER OR
TO ONE ANOTHER SENATE RELATED
ENERGY. FROM US YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS TODAY
I'M PRESENTING SENATE BILL
EIGHT NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR
BARBARA BOB ATUALIZADA. SENATE
BILL EIGHT NINETY FIVE WILL
AMENDED UPDATED A REVOLUTIONARY
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE BILL THAT
ALLOCATES FUNDS FROM HEAVY DUTY
DIESEL EMISSIONS ON VIOLATORS
TO BE SPENT ON A NEW CLEANER
TECHNOLOGY THROUGH THE CREATION
OF A DIESEL EMISSION REDUCTION
FONG. WITH THIS BILL THE DIESEL
EMISSIONS REDUCTION FUND WILL
BE ABLE TO SERVE ITS PURPOSE OF
REDUCING THE HARMFUL DIESEL
POLLUTION IN OUR COMMUNITIES BY
INVESTING AND HEAVY DUTY ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES. THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
AND HAS NO KNOWN OPPOSITION FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
RAMOS SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED TO THIRTY VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELLING VOTE I FIFTY NINE IS
YOUR THE MEASURE PASSES. HAVE
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY ONE. AND FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY TO PASS TEMPORARILY. ON
FILE ITEMS ONE FORTY THREE
THROUGH ONE FORTY SIX SEVEN
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY SEVEN SB
ELEVEN NINETY SIX THE PURPLE
RAIN SENATE BILL ELEVEN NINETY
SIX BY SOONER- BERGEN OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE IN THE PRICE GOUGING.
OUR IF YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN
NINETY SIX ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR AMBER. SB
ELEVEN NINETY SIX IS A
NECESSARY MEASURE TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN STOP PRICE
GOUGING IN THE MIDST OF AN
EMERGENCY. AS WE KNOW TOO WELL
CALIFORNIA IS RIGHT NOW IN THE
MIDST OF AN UNPRECEDENTED
CRISIS UNFORTUNATELY RATHER
THAN SUPPORTING OUR COMMUNITY
THERE ARE THOSE WHO SEE MOMENTS
OF CRISIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPLOIT THEIR NEIGHBORS. AND DO
SO BY CHARGING EXTORTIONATE
AMOUNTS FOR ESSENTIAL GOODS SB
ELEVEN NINETY SIX WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA STOP PROGRESS FROM
HAPPENING. SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX
CLOSES THE PRICE STARTING TO
PULL FROM SELLERS AND CODIFIES
THE GOVERNORS AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S AUTHORITY TO
EXTEND PRICE GOUGING
PROTECTIONS FOR PERIODS. LONGER
THAN THIRTY DAYS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
EVENT. THANK YOU MISS
PENSIONERS MR CHOI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY I STAND TODAY AS A
PROUD TO CALL OR THOUGHT OF THE
SUPPORT. OF S. B. ELEVEN NINETY
SIX SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX IN
TERMS OF TOTAL EXPAND THE PRICE
GOUGING THE FUTURE OF FEDERAL
OR STATE DECLARED THE EMERGENCY
IS SO ALL. AND THEN MIX INSTEAD
OF ARE JUST A FOR THE- COVERED
NINETEEN CRISIS SO WE CURRENTLY
FIND OURSELVES. THIS MERGER ED
SAW BEEN DAMAGED OR D'AMICO
DISEASE SAW ALL BREAK UP TO THE
LIST OF US SPECIFICALLY. IN
DISASTER SO THAT THE TRIGGER
THE PROVISIONS OF THE PRICE
GOUGING CRIMINAL STATUTE A POEM
A DECLARATION. OF WAR EMERGENCY.
COLLEAGUE SB ELEVEN NINE IS A
YEAR BY. MEASURE TO PROTECT OUR
OVER CONSTANT CONSTITUENTS ARE
AND- FOR FEAR OUR IS ARE AS THE
ARE. DE LA OFFICE SO HIS
MARRIAGE IS TALK. TO ENSURE.
THE PEOPLE. THE PEOPLE ARE NOT
NOT TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF- DURING
THE HARSH TIMES. BYOBB PRICE
GOUGING SO. IT IS SO FOR THOSE
REASONS OF THAT ALL RIGHT
RESPECTIVELY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHOICE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE-
HOME MEMBERS VOTE TO THEIR TO
VOTE. RIGHT ALL MEMBERS VOTE TO
THEIR. TO CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE HOW IT ICE THREE ZERO
MEASURE. WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY AND VIOLATE ONE
FORTY EIGHT WE HAVE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEM ONE FORTY NINE
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN A FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY MOVING A FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY ONE SB FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY ONE
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE ACCOLADE IN
THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS. BURKE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS CITIES
AND COUNTIES FACE DISASTROUS
BUDGET DEFICITS IN THE COMING
YEAR DUE THE IMPACTS OF
CORONAVIRUS IT IS CRITICAL THAT
THE STATEMENT TAKES ACTION TO
ENSURE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
MAINTAIN EVERY REVENUE SOURCE
AT THEIR DISPOSAL SB FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE DOES JUST THAT BY
EXTENDING THE SUNSET ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ABILITY TO COLLECT
UTILITY USER TAXES. FROM THE
RETAIL SALES OF PREPAID
WIRELESS TELECOMMUNICATION
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES INTO
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY SIX
THE PASSAGE OF A SEVENTY.
SEVENTY SEEN SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAD
NO WAY FOR COLLECTING YOU YOU
TEASE. ON PREPAID WIRELESS AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN ESTABLISHED
A COLLECTION MECHANISM SIMILAR
TO SALES TAX FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION COLLECTS
LOCALLY. IMPOSE YOU YOU TEASE
FROM RETAIL SALES AND
DISTRIBUTE THOSE REVENUES TO
THE CITY AND COUNTY WHERE THE
PURCHASE TOOK PLACE. DIRECTLY
ONE HUNDRED CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO COLLECT YOU TEASE. ON
PREPAID SIR WIRELESS AND WHICH
HAVE RECEIVED APARTMENT TWENTY
FOUR MILLION IN NEW REVENUES
SINCE THE PROGRAM WAS ENACTED.
THIS MEASURE ONLY APPLIES TO
LOCAL AMPLE IMPOSE VOTER
APPROVED UTILITY USER TAX IS
NOT THE STATE SURCHARGE
PROVISIONS OF AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN. THAT WERE OVERTURNED
BY THE COURTS WITHOUT SB
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE. SEASON
COUNTY SHRINKING BUDGETS WILL
BE REDUCED EVEN MORE ****
FOCUSING. FORCING LOCALS TO
MAKE DIFFICULT DECISIONS TO CUT
CRITICAL SERVICES LIKE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND REPAIR THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TREASURER FIONA MA. ****
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND C. T. I.
A. AND HAS NO. RECEIVE NO NO
ARE ASK AND- THANK YOU MISS
BURKE SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
THERE TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. WHERE
WILL LOWS THE ROLE AND TALLY
VOTER I FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE
THIS MEASURE PASSES. IT WILL
PASS AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY TWO MOVING A FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY THREE SB ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
BY CENTER JONES AN ACCOLADE IN
THE JUVENILES. MISTER JONES
SAWYER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR JONES.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT THE
PROSECUTING ATTORNEY PASAPORTE
A MINOR AND A COURT TO ASSESS
PRIOR COMPETENCY. EVALUATIONS
OF JUVENILE SUBMITTED TO THE
COURT IN A PREVIOUS PROCEEDING.
INFORMATION OBTAINED THROUGH
THIS NEW ALLOWANCE STILL MAY
NOT BE DISSEMINATED TO ANY
OTHER PERSON OR AGENCY EXCEPT
AS NECESSARY TO EVALUATE. THE
MINERS COMPETENCY. ACCESS TO
THE PRIVACY OF RECORD WILL
PROVIDE THE COURT WITH A FULLER
UNDERSTANDING OF USED SOCIAL
AND SERVICE HISTORY.
IDENTIFICATION OF SERVICE GAPS
AND GUIDANCE FROM APPROPRIATE
INTERVENTIONS. THE RECENT
AMENDMENT SIMPLY FIX A DRAFTING
ERROR AND ADDED CHAPLAIN
LANGUAGE FORM FOR THIS BILL. AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY ONE THIS
BILL IS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MISTER JOHNSON
WHERE SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IN THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE IS FIFTY NINE IS
HERE THE MEASURE PASSES.
FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY FOUR SB TWELVE
FORTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE FIFTEEN
FORTY FOUR BY CENTER BRADFORD
NATURALLY IN THE CANNABIS.
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT SB
ONE TWO FOUR FOUR ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR. BRADFORD SB TWELVE
FORTY FOUR IS A TIMELY MEASURE.
THAT INCREASES SAFETY FOR
CANNABIS CONSUMERS OVER THE
LAST SIX MONTHS CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION HAS GROWN
SIGNIFICANTLY GET EXISTING LAW
BLOCKS STATE. AND LOCAL
AGENCIES FROM USING STATE
LICENSED FACILITIES TO TEST.
HEAVY METALS SB TEL FORTY FOUR
CORRECTS THAT OVERSIGHT AND
WILL INCREASE CONSUMER SAFETY
GOOD ACTORS IN THIS INDUSTRY
ALREADY FACE MANY BARRIERS
INCLUDING BEING EXCLUDED FROM
FEDERAL COVER NINETEEN. RELIEF
PROGRAMS THE LEAST WE CAN DO IS
EXPAND PRODUCT TESTING TO
DETERMINE THAT ACTORS AND HALT
THE SALE OF DANGEROUS PRODUCTS
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
BONTA THING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED A VERITABLE. HOME MEMBERS
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WELL
LOWS THE ROLE IN TELLING VOTER
I FIFTY FIVE NEWS HERE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY FIVE SB EIGHT
SIXTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY NINE BY
CIVIL GUARD OTHERS AND I
BELIEVE THE TRIBAL GAMING IN
THE CLEARING YEARS EITHER UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY MISTER
GRAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS
IS THE COMPACT RATIFICATION
BILL CONTAINING SEVERAL
COMPACTS NEGOTIATED TUESDAY TO
CALIFORNIA AND INDIAN TRIBES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THIS IS
BEEN REVIEWED BY BOTH THE
SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE THE
ASSEMBLY GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE AND IS
NOW BEFORE US FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHICH IS MY RECOMMENDATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER GRAY. THING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO VERY VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTE ICE FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY I SAID YOU
KNOW THEY'RE ON THE BILL THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL PASS
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE
FIFTY SIX AND ONE FIFTY SEVEN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
EIGHT SB SIXTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL SIXTY
SEVEN ONE REQUIREMENT OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE IN THE CANNABIS AND
CLEARLY YEARS EITHER UP TO
EXPECT ME LEE. AFTER WHEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE PERCENT SB SIXTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR MCGUIRE WHICH
WILL CLOSE LOOPHOLES IN
CANNABIS APPELLATION OF ORIGIN
PRACTICES. SB SIXTY SEVEN WILL
LIMIT APPELLATIONS OF ORIGIN TO
CANNABIS HAS PLANTED IN GROUND
IN OPEN AIR WITH NO USE OF
ARTIFICIAL LIGHT DURING THE
FLOWERING STAGE OF CULTIVATION.
USUALLY BILL THAT THIS BILL
WILL ADD MARKETING PROTECTIONS
FOR THE CITY OF ORIGIN THAT
MERE EXISTING PROTECTIONS FOR
COUNTY OF ORIGIN. BILLS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
THE INTERNATIONAL CANNABIS
FARMERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
WINE INSTITUTE. THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION AND NO
NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK DOCTOR
WOULD. SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED EITHER TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE IS FIFTY
EIGHT KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE BILL
I FIFTY EIGHT NEWS HERE ON THE
URGENCY OF THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS ONE FIFTY NINE AND. ONE
SIXTY. FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE
S. B. TWO FOURTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL TWO
FOURTEEN BY SENATE DOT ACTUALLY
THE MEDICO AND CLEARING THE
URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY AFTER WOULD YOU ARE
AGAIN RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB
TWO FOURTEEN PROVIDES AN
EMERGENCY IN IMPORTANT
TEMPORARY EXPANSION TO THE
MONEY FOLLOWS THE PERSON
PROGRAM NOTING CALIFORNIA'S.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
TRANSITIONS R. C. C. T. THIS
PROGRAM ASSISTS LOW INCOME
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES SERVE BY MEDIC CAL
IN TRANSITIONING FROM NURSING
FACILITIES AND OTHER
INSTITUTIONS BACK INTO A HOME
OUR COMMUNITY SETTING WITH
SOCIAL SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
FEDERAL ELIGIBILITY AND FUNDING
LIMITS ELIGIBILITY TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE RESIDED IN
AN INSTITUTIONAL SETTING FIRST
NINETY CONSECUTIVE DAYS OR
MORE. THE BILL REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE RESIDED IN AN INPATIENT
FACILITY FORNINETY DAYS OR
LESS TO MOVE PEOPLE OUT OF
NURSING FACILITIES DURING THE
COPA NINETEEN. PANDEMIC TO SAVE
LIVES AND SAVE MONEY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DR WOULD SEE HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY ONE
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE BILL I
SIXTY ONE NEWS HERE ON HERE TO
SEE THE MEASURE PASSES. WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS.
ONE SIXTY TWO THROUGH.
ONE
SIXTY NINE. WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS ONE
SEVENTY THROUGH ONE EIGHTY SIX
WILL GO TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS-PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ACCOLADE THE
BUSINESS A PROFESSION TO MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR. THRILLER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS. THIS IS
A SENATE AND ASSEMBLY CAN BILL
RESPECT ASK DR. SEEING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE. SCRIPT.
ALL MEMBERS. BURKE WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT ICE
FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO THIS MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT SB ONE SEVENTY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY NINE BY
SOON NIELSEN ACRYLATE A STATE
EMPLOYEES. RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ALL RIGHT PRESENT SB
ONE SEVENTY NINE. THIS IS B.
WOULD CREATE THE EXCLUDED
EMPLOYEE ARBITRATION ACT TO
ALLOW EXCLUDED STATE EMPLOYEES
TO REQUEST ARBITRATION AS THE
NEXT STEP IN THE GRIEVANCE
PROCESS. CURRENTLY OF AN
EMPLOYEE FILES A GRIEVANCE THAT
IS REPEATEDLY DENIED AS ALMOST
OUR GRIEVANCES CURRENTLY ARE
THEY HAVE NO OPTION OTHER THAN
TO ESCALATE THE MATTER TO THE
SUPER QUART OR THE STATE
PERSONNEL BOARD TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM SB ONE SEVENTY NINE
WOULDOPTIMIZE AND STREAMLINE
THE GRIEVANCE PROCESS BY
ALLOWING. EXCLUDE EMPLOYEES TO
REQUEST ARBITRATION AFTER
EXHAUSTING THE NORMAL GRIEVANCE
PROCESS SB ONE THREE NINE HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
DURING THE COMMITTEE PROCESS
ARE STRICTLY OUT FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED THIRD OF A- ALL MEMBERS
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I FIFTY THREE KNOWS
THERE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING A FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
NINE SB SIXTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL SIXTY
EIGHT BY CENTER GALGIANI
INOCULATE A HAZARDOUS WASTE. MR
HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
GALGIANI TO PRESENT SB SIXTY
EIGHT. SB SIX DAYS STABILIZE
THE DISPOSAL OF TREATED WOOD
WASTE IN CALIFORNIA BY ENDING
THE SUNSET ON THE TREATED WOOD
WASTE PROGRAM. TREATED WOOD IS
COMMONLY USED FOR CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS UTILITY
POLES GUARDRAILS AND FENCES
BECAUSE IT IS RENEWABLE AND
COST EFFECTIVE. BY CONFIRMING
THE CONTINUED DISPOSAL OF
TREATED WOOD WASTE IN A CLASS
ONE HAZARDOUS WASTE LANDFILL OR
COMPOSITE LINE PORTION OF WITH
SOLID WASTE LANDFILL. SB SIXTY
EIGHT WILL MINIMIZE ILLEGAL
DUMPING UNTREATED WOOD WASTE BY
INCREASING HE NUMBER OF
LANDFILLS THAT WILL ACCEPT
TREATED WOOD WASTE. THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THIS ALSO MAKES
TECHNICAL CHANGES THAT UPDATE
THE DTS SEE WEBSITE TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON HOW TO BEST
HANDLE DISPOSE AND MANAGE
TREATED WOOD WASTE. RECENT
AMENDMENTS WERE REQUIRED THE
DTS THE TO SUBMIT AN INSPECTION
AND COMPLIANCE PLAN TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY TWENTY TWENTY TO.
SB SIXTY EIGHT ENJOYS BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I KNOW
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU MR HOLDEN THING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS THERE TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED EITHER TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED ALREADY
VOTED. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING VOTE I FIFTY
NINE NEWS HERE THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE WILL PASS THIRTEEN A
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY AND. FILE ITEMS ONE
NINETY ONE THROUGH ONE NINETY
FIVE MOVING A FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY SIX SB FIVE FIFTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE FIFTY NINE BY SENATOR
HER TADO AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
IN THE WATER. MISTER DOCTOR
EMILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. GOOD
EVENING MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT ON
SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE NINE BY
SENATOR HER TADO. SENATE BILL
FIVE FIVE NINE AIMS TO ADDRESS
WATER SUPPLY AND SUBSIDENCE
PROBLEMS IN THE SOUTHERN
CENTRAL VALLEY. BY STUDYING THE
REPAIRING OF THE CRUMBLING
FRYING KERN CANAL. IN A STATE
WHERE WATER IS THE LIFEBLOOD OF
OUR COMMUNITIES THIS CANAL IS A
MAJOR ARTERY. WATER YOU DELIVER
SYSTEM THAT STRETCHES A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY TWO MILES LONG. AND
CARRIES WATER FROM FRESNO TO
BAKERSFIELD IT WAS BUILT IN THE
MID NINETEEN HUNDREDS AND IT IS
SENSE LOST 60% OF ITS
CONVEYANCE CAPACITY. IT IS
INCREDIBLY VITAL TO OUR LOCAL
ECONOMY OF THE COMMUNITIES
SURROUNDING REGION IN MY- WHICH
IN TURNS SUPPORTS OUR ENTIRE
STATE. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU TO THANK YOU DR
MUSIGA. MISTER SALAS YOUR
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FIVE
FIVE NINE- WHICH WILL HELP
CONVEY MORE WATER INTO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND REALLY FOR
THEIR ENTIRE STATED WILL HELP
STUDY THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF HOW
WATER MOVES WE KNOW THAT WATER
EQUALS LIFE WATER EQUALS JOBS
WE KNOW THAT. THIS IS AN
ESSENTIAL STEP TO UNDERSTAND
HOW WE IMPROVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE FOR THE PIPELINES. AND I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS WITHOUT
THINKING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT ICE FIFTY ONE NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES. MR
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
THREE AND ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY
FOUR D. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW TO TAKE UP STR
EIGHTY NINE DALY TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADOPTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. WE WILL TURN TO. WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE F. E. R.
EIGHTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY NINE BY SENATE ALLEY
RELATIVE TO THE DEPUTY SHERIFF
BRIAN ISMAEL MEMORIAL HIGHWAY.
MISTER BIGELOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR TO PRESENT S.
C. R. U. D. NINE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR DOLLY. AND MYSELF S. C.
R. EIGHTY NINE HONORS THE LIFE
OF EL DORADO COUNTY DEPUTY
SHERIFF BRIAN ISHMAEL WHO WAS
KILLED IN THE LINE OF DUTY ON
OCTOBER TWENTY THIRD. STR
EIGHTY NINE DESIGNATES A
PORTION OF HIGHWAY FIFTY NEAR
PLACERVILLE AS DEPUTY SHERIFF
BRIAN IS SMALL MORAL HIGHWAY.
AS YOU ALL MAY REMEMBER LAST
YEAR WE RECOGNIZE AN INJURED IN
HIS MEMORY RIGHT HERE ON THIS
FLOOR. THIS IS A COMBINATION
EFFORT TO BRING CLOSURE NOT
ONLY TO HIS WIFE. AND CHILDREN
WHO HE HAD THREE WONDERFUL
CHILDREN. ALSO THE COMMUNITY OF
EL K. WITH THIS I REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE FROM THIS ENTIRE BODY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
BIGELOW SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
ISRAEL WOULD YOU LIKE AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION. SPEAKER
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS NECKER WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS. OF IT THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. MEMBERS THIS IS HER
CO AUTHORS ON S. C. R. EIGHTY
NINE. MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THAT THEIR FIFTY
NINE CO AUTHORS ON THE
ROLL CALL VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS HOME MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. RIGHT
NOW ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO GARNER
VOTES. WHERE WELL. CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTEEN OH ZERO THE RESOLUTIONS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE BACK UP TO THE- NEAR
THE TOP OF THE THIRD READING
FILE TO FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
THREE SB ELEVEN OO TO THE CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL ELEVEN OH
TWO BY CENTER MONNING AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE EMPLOYMENT.
ALL RIGHT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. LAST YEAR MORE THAN
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND FORM
FARMWORKERS REPORTED BY ROUGHLY
A HUNDRED CALIFORNIA GROWERS
AND FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS
UNDER THE AGE TO A FEDERAL VISA
PROGRAM. THIS NUMBER HAS BEEN
INCREASING ANNUALLY FOR THOSE
OF YOU UNFAMILIAR WITH H. TWO
A. PROGRAM HAS MANY OF THE SAME
PROVISIONS AND PROBLEMS THAT
THE INFAMOUS BRACERO PROGRAM
HAD. HI COMMITTEE NOW ALSO
CITED RECENT REPORTS
DOCUMENTING THAT THESE PROBLEMS
CONTINUE TO THIS DAY. THANKS TO
A FARMWORKERS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
LARGELY RECRUITED IN MEXICO ARE
TIED TO A SINGLE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYER. WHO MUST PROVIDE THEM
WITH HOUSING MEALS ENTRANCE TO
WORK SITES MANY H. TWO A.
WORKERS I'VE NEVER BEEN TO
CALIFORNIA BEFORE AND ARE
BELIEVED IN EITHER SPEAK OR
READ ENGLISH. THERE FIRED FOR
ANY REASON THEY'RE SUBJECT TO
IMMEDIATE DEPORTATION WHICH IS
A POWERFUL DISINCENTIVE TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT ANY ABUSIVE
WORKPLACE CONDITIONS THEY ARE
SUBJECTED TO. S. B. ELEVEN OH
TWO REQUIRES AGE TO EMPLOYERS
PROVIDE AGE TO A FARMWORKERS ON
THEIR FIRST DAY AT WORK A
SHORT. COMPREHENSIVE WRITTEN
SUMMARY OF KEY LABOR HOUSING
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND OTHER
CALIFORNIA LAWS IN SPANISH. AND
IF REQUESTED IN ENGLISH. THE
BILL DIRECTS THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER DEVELOP A TEMPLATE
CONTAINING THE SUMMARY AND A
POST ON THE WEBSITE FOR HIS TO
EMPLOYERS TO USE TO COMPLY WITH
THESE NEW DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS. SB ELEVEN- TO
CREATE A SAFER LEGALLY
COMPLIANT WORKPLACE FOR H. AWAY
FARMWORKERS WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
FOR THIS BILL. THIS BILL FROM
SENATOR BILL MONNING. THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR- OWN
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VERY. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO THEIR TO BOTH
READY. YEAH. YEAH. ON MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELEVOTE EYES FORTY ONE NEWS
THIRTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
LIVING FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SIX
SB ONE FORTY SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL ONE FORTY SIX
BY CENTRE BELL AND ACRYLATE IN
THE TRANSPORTATION AND
TERMINALING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
TO THEIR PRESENT SB ONE FORTY
SIX BY SENATOR BELL WHICH WILL
HELP REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES. GARNER PUBLIC
COMMENTS DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
WELL I RESIDENTS ARE BEING
ASKED TO STAY HOME AND ONLY
TRAVEL TO CARRY OUT ESSENTIAL
BUSINESS. REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES ARE
STILL REQUIRED. TO ENSURE
TRANSIT REMAINS IN OPERATION
OUR STREETS AND HIGHWAYS ARE
SUITABLE FOR TRAVEL IN VARIOUS
OTHER STATE REQUIREMENTS ARE
MET. THIS BILL PROVIDES
AGENCIES WITH ADDITIONAL TOOLS
TO CARRY OUT SOME OF THEIR
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT PRACTICES IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
STRATEGIES. SB ONE FORTY SIX
SIMPLY PROVIDES THE NECESSARY
CLARIFICATION THAT REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES HAVE
THE OPTION TO HOLD INFORMAL NON
BROWN ACT MEETINGS
ELECTRONICALLY. WITH PHONE
OPTIONS WHEN THEY'RE DEVELOPING
THE REST YES ONE OF THE THINGS
WE HAVE DISCOVERED DURING THE
PANDEMIC THAT HOLDING MEETINGS
AND HEARINGS OVER THE INTERNET.
HAS ACTUALLY INCREASED PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. THIS MEASURE
HELPS ENSURE SAFE PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT AND BRING TO
EXISTING LAW INTO ALIGNMENT
WITH THE TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE.
TODAY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MULLIN THINKING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I THINK YOU
KNOW THEY'RE THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING A FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN SB TEN SEVENTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL TEN
SEVENTY NINE BY SENATOR SKINNER
ANOTHER SNACK RELATING TO REAL
PROPERTY. MISTER GRAYSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
PRESENT SB TEN SEVENTY NINE ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR SKINNER WHICH
LIMITS CORPORATE OWNERSHIP OF
FORECLOSED PROPERTIES SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE DOES NOT PREVENT
FORECLOSURES RATHER IT HELPS
KEEP PROPERTY OWNERSHIP WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITIES AFTER THEIR-
THEY ARE FORECLOSED UPON THE
GREAT RECESSION RESULTED IN A
WAVE OF FORECLOSURES IN
CALIFORNIA AND BEFORE THE
RECESSION INSTITUTIONAL
LANDLORDS DIDN'T EXIST IN THE
SINGLE FAMILY RENTAL MARKET.
LARGE CORPORATIONS ANOTHER
INVESTORS PURCHASED FORECLOSED
HOMES AT ROCK BOTTOM PRICES AND
MOST PAID IN CASH SINCE THE
GREAT RECESSION RACIAL
DISPARITY IN HOMEOWNERSHIP HAS
GROWN WE ARE SINCE WE ARE
SEEING NOW AS RECENTLY AS JULY
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS COUNT THAT
HOMEOWNER ARE EXPERIENCING%
GREAT DIFFICULTY PAYING THEIR
MORTGAGE AND MANY ARE AT RISK
OF LOSING THEIR HOMES THE
INTENT OF SB TEN SEVENTY NINE
IS TO PREVENT THAT SCENARIO
FROM HAPPENING AGAIN BY
LIMITING. THE ADVANTAGE LARGE
INVESTORS HAVE IN FORECLOSURE
AUCTIONS AND KEEPING
HOMEOWNERSHIP WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES THE BILL
ESTABLISHES A PROCESS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS AND TENANTS TO
PURCHASE FORECLOSED HOMES
SPECIFICALLY SB TEN SEVENTY
NINE PROHIBITS THE BULK SALE OF
FORECLOSED PROPERTIES CREATES A
FORTY FIVE WHEN THE DAY WINDOW
AFTER THE INITIAL OPTION TO
ALLOW PROSPECTIVE OWNER
OCCUPANTS CITIES AND NONPROFITS
TO SUBMIT A HIGHER BID AND
PURCHASE THE PROPERTY.
INTERESTED BIDDERS MUST SUBMIT
A NOTICE OF INTENT TO BID
WITHIN THE FIRST FIFTEEN DAYS
OF A FORTY FIVE DAY WINDOW AND
THEN HAVE FORTY FIVE DAYS TO
COME UP WITH THE FUNDING IF
THERE ARE NO INTERESTED BIDDERS
THE ADDED FORTY FIVE DAYS AVOID
DURING THE INITIAL FORECLOSURE
AUCTION THE SALE IS FINALIZED
IF THE HIGHEST BIDDER IS A
PROSPECTIVE OWNER OCCUPANT.
TENANTS ARE GIVEN PRIORITY
WITHIN THE NEW WINDOW TO
PURCHASE PROPERTY BY MATCHING
THE AUCTION BID PRICE THIS
DISTINCTION IS TO ADDRESS
TENANT DISPLACEMENT THESE NEW
PROVISIONS SUNSET AND FIVE
YEARS WELL LASTLY. THE BILL
INCREASE EXISTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINES ON VACANT
UNMAINTAINED FORECLOSED
PROPERTIES FROM A THOUSAND TO
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE ENJOYS SUPPORT.
FROM THIRTY PLUS ORGANIZATIONS
THANK YOU MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON
MR COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
PAULING'S I'M PLEASED TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL YOU
KNOW HOMEOWNERSHIP IS SUCH A
VITAL ISSUE IN IN A COMMUNITY.
IF YOU LOOK ACROSS ALL THE
STATES CITIES. AND ASK YOURSELF
WHAT IS THE ONE THING. THAT YOU
CAN DO THAT WILL SUPPORT LONG
TERM PROPERTY VALUES AND
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THE
COMMUNITY THAT IS SUPPORT
HOMEOWNERSHIP. AND SO THIS IS A
VERY INNOVATIVE IDEA. TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT YES FOR
BORROWERS BUT ACTUALLY FOR. A
COMMUNITY FABRIC THE LIFE OF
COMMITTEES TO HELP THE CREW THE
DYNAMICS OF COMMITTEESBY
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUAL
HOMEOWNERSHIP ARM. BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN. WHEN THE
ECONOMY FIRST ORDER WOBBLE I
ACTUALLY CONVENE A WORKING
GROUP IN MY CITY HALL ONE NIGHT
FOLKS ON HOMEOWNERSHIP I SAW.
STRESS IN THE SUMMER OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN IN THE ECONOMY
VERY EARLY. IN OUR WORKSHOP IN
RETRO CITY HALL WE CONVENE
SIMULTANEOUSLY PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT HOMEOWNERS. IN ENGLISH
AND SPANISH AND RUSSIAN. HAS
THAT REFLECTED THE CROSS
SECTION OF MY COMMUNITY AND-
THE SORT OF PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
HAVE A LONG TERM PLACE IN OUR
COMMUNITY SO I JUST COMMEND
THE- SERVICE SCANNE FOR THIS
IDEA I THINK IT IS COMPATIBLE
WITH LENDING PRACTICES IT WILL
SUPPORT. PROPERTY VALUES AT
HOME OWNERSHIP WHICH ULTIMATELY
IS SECURITY LETTERS RELY UPON
AND- I THINK JUST GIVEN A
SAFETY VALVE ON BEHALF OF
BORROWERS AND UPHOLDING THE
VERY FABRIC IS A TREMENDOUS
IDEA PRIOR TO ARRIVAL. THANK
YOU MR COOLEY SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER GRAYSON WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK COLLEGE PARK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. OF A- ON MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
OUR MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD VOTE
THIS REQUIRES FORTY ONE. WE
WERE NOTHING. NUMBER OF. THE
GROUP AFTER THAT YEAH YEAH.
OKAY COMMERCE ARE TO VOTE THIS
REQUIRES. FORTY ONE. WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TALLY THOSE EYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS FIFTEEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
EIGHT. SB SEVEN THIRTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
SEVEN THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR
STERN ANOTHER'S MACALINTAL
ELECTIONS AND CLEAR THE YEARS
IS EITHER UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY STERLING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU AGAIN
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ALL
REGISTER CALIFORNIANS WILL
RECEIVE A VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT.
FOR SOME VOTERS THIS WILL BE
ROUTINE BUT FOR OTHERS THIS
WILL BE THE FIRST TIME THEY
CAST THEIR BALLOTS FROM THE
SAFETY OF THEIR HOME. IN AN AGE
OF QUESTIONABLE INFORMATION WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE RECEIVING ONLY
THE MOST RELIABLE AND CORRECT
FACTS ABOUT THE RIGHT TO APPLY
FOR RECEIVE OR RETURN OF VOTE
BY MAIL BALLOT CURRENTLY IT IS
A MISDEMEANOR FOR PERSON TO
DISTRIBUTE INFORMATION WITH AN
INTENT TO DECEIVE VOTERS ABOUT
THE LOCATION. OF POLLING PLACES
ABOUT THE QUALIFICATIONS TO
REGISTER TO VOTE AND THE
QUALIFICATIONS TO VOTE HOWEVER
THE LAW IS SILENT WHEN IT COMES
TO DELIBERATE MISINFORMATION
REGARDING VOTE BY MAIL
QUALIFICATIONS SB SEVEN THIRTY
NINE IS A URGENCY MEASURE WHICH
PROHIBITS A PERSON FROM
INTENTIONALLY DISTRIBUTING
FALSE OR MISLEADING
INFORMATION. ABOUT THE
QUALIFICATION TO APPLY FOR
RECEIVE OVERTURN A VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT ADDITIONALLY THE BILL
ALLOWS RATHER THAN REQUIRES
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TO
INCLUDE BBM APPLICATIONS WITH
COUNTY VOTER INFORMATION GUIDES
FOR THIS ELECTION ONLY. AND I
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MULLIN THING IN HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
USUALLY. WE'LL STRIKE THE ROLE
I'M SORRY TO SEE MR KILEY
SEEKING RECOGNITION IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER. I THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I HAVE
RELUCTANTLY IN THE PAST
SUPPORTED MEASURES TO PROHIBIT.
FALSE INFORMATION ABOUT
ELECTIONS I'M QUITE WARY THOUGH
OF COMING BACK IN EVERY YEAR
EXPANDING THE SCOPE OF
RESTRICTED SPEECH AS IT
PERTAINS TO ELECTIONS I THINK
AT SOME POINT WE RISK A REAL
CHILLING EFFECT AS YOU KNOW THE
VENN DIAGRAM OVERLAPS MORE
BETWEEN OUR CRIMINAL CODE. AND
OUR ELECTION CODE I FEAR THAT
THERE WILL BE A CORRESPONDINGLY
DIMINISHED SPACE FOR AN OPEN
AND UNINHIBITED DEBATE ABOUT
ISSUES THAT ARE OF GREAT PUBLIC
CONCERN SO I'M GONNA HAVE TO
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU
MISTER KILEY NOW SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER AND THE CLERK WILL.
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED THERE TO VOTE. ALL ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO VOTE THIS
REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. OKAY.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED ABOUT THIS
REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR.
FOR MR
MELINDA'S THE CALL
FOR HER TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN SP ONE
THIRTY TWO THE CLERK WILL POST.
ON THE VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY THREE NO
THIRTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
EVEN FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE
SB ELEVEN NINETY THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL ELEVEN NINETY
BY CENTER SENATOR OF ANOTHER'S
AN ACCOLADE TO TENNESSEE. DR
WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I PRESENT
TO YOU TODAY S. B. ELEVEN
NINETY- CONCERNING VICTIMS OF
VIOLENT CRIME AND RACIAL
JUSTICE. AT A TIME IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE NATION IS
CONFRONTED WITH DEADLY- OF
PANDEMICS A NOVEL COLD EXCUSE
ME COLBERT NINETEEN. AN
ENTRANCE RACISM VIOLENCE AND
VIOLENCE IT IS CRITICAL NOW
THAT THE EVER MORE THAN EVER
THAT WE PURSUE A NEW SAFETY
SOLUTION THAT CENTERS THE
EXPERIENCES OF SURVIVORS OF
COLOR. I'M IMPACT PEOPLE FROM
ALL BACKGROUNDS THE BLACK LAB
MIX AND INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE HIGHER RATES OF
SERIOUS. VICTIMIZATION THAN
WHITES CURRENT LAW
UNFORTUNATELY HIS VICTIMS OF
GUN VIOLENCE AND FAMILY MEMBERS
OF HOMICIDE VICTIMS OUT OF
RELOCATION PROVISIONS AFTER
VICTIMIZATION. SB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE SENATOR DORADO WOULD
EXPAND THOSE EXISTING TENANT
STABILIZATION PROVISIONS TO
VICTIMS OF VIOLENT CRIMES LIKE
VICTIMS OF GUN VIOLENCE ARMED
HOME INVASION OR CALL VICTIMS
OF HOMICIDE. THE VICTIMS OF
VIOLENT CRIMES AND THEIR
FAMILIES HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS CAN
TERMINATE A LEASE WITHOUT
PENALTY WITHIN A HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS FOLLOWING A CRIME. SB
ELEVEN NINETY WOULD ENSURE THAT
LANDLORDS DO NOT DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST TENANTS BY REFUSING TO
RENT TO TENANTS FOR BREAKING A
LEASE SUBJECT TO THESE RIGHTS.
THE BILL ALSO EXPANDS A
PROVISIONS TO IMMEDIATE FAMILY
MEMBERS OUTSIDE OF HOUSEHOLDS
THIS IS IMPORTANT URGENT
SITUATIONS LIKE WHEN A VICTIM
WAS SEVERELY INJURED AND NEEDS
ROUND THE CLOCK HERE WHEN
EXTENDED PERIOD AND AN
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBER MUST
RELOCATE. TO PROVIDE THE VICTIM
WITH CARE. THIS BILL FOLLOWS A
RIGOROUS DOCUMENTATION PROGRESS.
COPYRIGHT LAW ALLOWS THE
FOLLOWING FORMS OF
DOCUMENTATION TO BREAK A LEASE
DUE TO VICTIMIZATION. A POLICE
REPORT A RESTRAINING ORDER OR
PROTECTIVE ORDER OR
DOCUMENTATION FROM A HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER THE MYSTIC
VIOLENCE COUNSELLOR SEXUAL
pTRAFFICKING COUNSELOR. INSURING
SAFE AND STABLE HOUSING IS
CRITICAL AND INCENTIVE TO
CALIFORNIA PERCENT FOR RACIAL
AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE. I AM IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN NINETY TO
MAKE THIS VISION A REALITY AND
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO ALSO JOIN ME
IN SUPPORTING A. B. EXCUSE ME.%
SB ELEVEN NINE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU DR WEBER SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
EITHER TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL TWO CARS FORTY ONE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
YEAH. DOCTOR REMOVED THE CALL.
MOVING THE FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
ONE SB FOUR EIGHTY THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL FOUR
EIGHTY BY CENTER ARCHULETA
IMMACULATE AT LAW ENFORCEMENT
UNIFORMS. IF YOU DON'T ARE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY BY
SENATOR BOB ARCHULETA SB FOUR
EIGHTY WILL PROHIBIT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FROM
AUTHORIZED YOU KNOW YOU OFFICER
TO WEAR UNIFORMS BETTER
CAMOUFLAGE OR SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR TO THOSE OF THE UNITED
STATES ARMED FORCES. OR THE
PAST FEW MONTHS A NUMBER OF
PHOTOS AND VIDEOS HAVE
CIRCULATED SHOWING LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY INCLUDING CALIFORNIA
WEARING HEAD TO TOE CAMOUFLAGE
PATTERN UNIFORMS FOR THE
AVERAGE CITIZEN THIS UNIFORMS
BEAR SUCH A STRIKING
RESEMBLANCE THOSE WORN BY THE
MILITARY THAT MANY HAVE TROUBLE
TELLING THE TWO GROUPS APART.
THIS IS WRONG AND OUR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY SHOULD NOT
LOOK LIKE ARMED FORCES
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE TWO GROUPS
ARE VASTLY DIFFERENT ROLES IN
AMERICAN SOCIETY FURTHERMORE
OUTSIDE OF TACTICAL OPERATIONS
WHICH TO BE CLEAR ARE EXEMPT
FROM THIS BILL. THERE'S NO
REASON POLICE OFFICERS SHOULD
BE WEARING A UNIFORM BUT FOR
CONCEALMENT WHILE ON DUTY FOR
EVERY DAY PATROL CRIMES OF THE
PRUSSIAN OR IN IT IN AN EVENT.
OF ANY EVENT NOT ONLY ARE
MILITARY STYLE UNIFORMS THE
INAPPROPRIATE GEAR BUT STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT THE MERE
PRESENCE OF THEM CAN INVITE
FEAR WITHIN THE COMMUNITY THAT
POLICE OFFICERS ARE SERVING. AS
BEFORE EIGHTY WILL MINIMIZE
PUBLIC CONFUSION BY BANNING
POLICE OFFICERS FROM USING
CAMOUFLAGE IN PROVIDING
GUIDELINES FOR PROPER LABELING
AND IDENTIFICATION AS A AN
ADDITIONAL SAFEGUARD FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO REMAIN
COMPLIANT WITH THE BILL
ADDITIONALLY SB FOUR EIGHTY IS
ESTIMATED RESULT IN RELATIVELY
MINOR PASSED THE LAW ENFORCING
AGENCIES AS SEEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
ANALYSIS. FOR THESE REASONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS JONES
SAWYER THING HEARING NO DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS GO
THROUGH THERE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. WHERE
TWELVE CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE EYES FORTY SIX KNOWS
NINE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
FIVE SB TWO OH THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL TWO OH
THREE BY SOONER BROWN FOR
ANOTHER PERSON I BELIEVE IN THE
JUVENILES. ESKOM ARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT. SB TWO ZERO THREE ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR BRADFORD
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE USE UNDER
EIGHTEEN TO CONSULT WITH LEGAL
COUNSEL PRIOR TO WAIVING THEIR
MIRANDA RIGHTS. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE YOU TO ARE FACING
INTERROGATION TO CONSULT WITH
AN ATTORNEY. WHO WILL EXPLAIN
WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE AND WHAT
IT MEANS TO WEIGH THEM. WE KNOW
FROM DECADES OF RESEARCH THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE LESS LIKELY TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR RIGHTS AND THE
CONSEQUENCES THAT WAITING THEM
QUITE A FULL INFLICT ON THEIR
LIVES. AND WE ARE ALL FAMILIAR
WITH THE EXPERIENCES OF
INNOCENT YOUTH WHO HAVE BEEN
PRESSURED INTO GIVING FALSE
CONFESSIONS AND HAVE HAD THEIR
LIVES DEVASTATED. AS A
CONSEQUENCE. ACCORDING TO THE
NATIONAL REGISTRY OF
EXONERATIONS SINCE 198936% OF
PEOPLE WHO FALSELY CONFESSED TO
A CRIME. WERE LATER EXONERATED.
WHO WERE LATER EXONERATED WERE
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN THIS
BILL PROTECTS ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S YOU. AND HELPS
BUILD TRUST IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
THE SAME BILL IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
WITH SB TEN FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR LARA. IN THE MEASURE
WAS ULTIMATELY VETOED. BY
GOVERNOR BROWN. THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED A WEAKER VERSION OF THIS
BILL IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH
WAS AMENDED TO YOUTH UNDER THE
AGE OF SIXTEEN. AND INCLUDED A
SUNSET DATE OF TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE AND REQUIRED A PANEL TO BE
CONVENE TO REVIEW THE EFFECTS
OF THE CHANGE IN THE LAW. THE
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL ARGUES
THAT WE SHOULD WAIT TO HEAR THE
RESULTS OF THIS. REVIEW BUT WE
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO WAIT FOR
SOMETHING THAT WE ALREADY KNOW
YOUNG PEOPLE MUST KNOW THEIR
RIGHTS AND THEY SHOULD NOT BE
ALONE WHEN BEING INTERROGATED.
THIS BILL DOES NOT FORBID
INNOCENT TEENS FROM ENGAGING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IT WOULD
NOT MAKE THEIR STATEMENTS AND
ADMISSIBLE AND IT WOULD NOT
PREVENT LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
USING CONFESSIONS TO ACCOMPLISH
THEIR WORK. SB TWO ZERO THREE
HAVE BROAD SUPPORT FROM A
COALITION. OF ORGANIZATIONS TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS WILL CREATE
GREATER TRUST ACCOUNTABILITY
AND DUE PROCESS. FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THIS BILL IS ALSO
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IS
LEGISLATIVE AGENDA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MISS COM
LONGER SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WHO
VERY BOTH. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
OUT OF A. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE IS FORTY
SEVEN KNOWS TENNIS MEASURE
PASSES. LEVINE A FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY ONE NASTY NINE FOURTEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL NINE FOURTEEN BY CENTER
PORTANTINO WHEN OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE OF FIREARMS TO GABRIEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I AM PLEASED
TODAY TO PRESENT SB NINE
FOURTEEN WHICH WILL REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO VERIFY
THE VALIDITY OF A HUNTING
LICENSE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. WHEN A
PERSON UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE IS USING THE LICENSE TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM. UNDER
CURRENT LAW THERE'S NO
VERIFICATION PROCESS DURING THE
TEN DAY BACKGROUND CHECK
PROCESS TO ENSURE THE VALIDITY
OF SUCH A LICENSE THIS BILL
WILL ADDRESS CIRCUMSTANCES I'M
COVERED IN THE POWER SHOOTING.
INSURING THE BACKGROUND CHECKS
ARE DONE COMPREHENSIVELY SO
THAT THE SAME MISTAKES DO NOT
HAPPEN AGAIN THE SUPPORTED BY
THE SAN DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON SB. NINE FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THERE ARE. MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLIED
ABOUT EYES FORTY TUTORS FIFTEEN
THE MEASURE PASSES. IN A FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY THREE SB NINE
EIGHTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL NINE EIGHTY BY
CENTER OF BERGEN OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO PRIVACY. MR GABRIEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ONCE AGAIN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'M
PLEASED TODAY TO ALSO PRESENT
SB NINE EIGHTY WHICH WOULD
CREATE THE WORLD'S STRONGEST
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS FOR
CONSUMER GENETIC TESTING
SERVICES. CURRENTLY DIRECT TO
COMPANIES ARE NOT REGULATED
UNDER THE HEALTH INSURANCE
PORTABILITY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT WHICH SETS STRICT
GUIDELINES. FOR HOW GENETIC
DATA SHOULD BE HANDLED. DUE TO
THE LACK OF PROTECTIONS OUR OWN
U. S. DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE HAS
ASKED SERVICE MEMBERS TO NOT
USE DIRECT TO CONSUMER GENETIC
TESTING SERVICES. TO THIRD
PARTIES ABILITY TO EXPLOIT
THESE COMPANIES DATABASES. SB
NINE EIGHTY WOULD ADDRESS THIS
CHALLENGE BY CREATING STRICT
GUIDELINES THAT ALLOW CONSUMERS
TO CONTROL THEIR GENETIC DATA
WHILE ALSO ESTABLISHING CIVIL
PENALTIES FOR COMPANIES. THAT
IMPROPERLY DISCLOSE SUCH DATA.
THE BILL STRIKES THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE IN
PROTECTING THE PRIVACY OF
INDIVIDUALS AND ALLOWING FOR
CONSUMERS TO STILL ACCESS
GENETIC TESTING PRODUCTS. WHICH
IS WHY IT SUPPORTED BY BOTH
COMPANIES SUCH AS ANCESTRY AND
TWENTY THREE IN ME AS WELL AS
THEACLU AND THE COALITION FOR
GENETIC DATA PRIVACY. BY
PASSING THIS BILL CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE CODIFYING MANY OF THE
AGREED UPON BEST PRACTICES AND
MAKING IT CLEAR THAT CONSUMERS
SHOULD CONTROLLED GENETIC DATA
WITHOUT FEAR OF EXPLOITATION BY
THIRD PARTIES. THANK YOU AND
RIP QUICK RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE ON SB NINE EIGHTY.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL'S SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THEIR- ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLIED ABOUT EYES FIFTY FIVE
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
EIGHT SB TWELVE OH SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
TWELVE OH SEVEN BY SENATOR
JACKSON AND I BELIEVE IN HEALTH
FACILITIES. MISTER TERRY AND
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS SB TWELVE
OH SEVEN IS A BILL THAT
REQUIRES NURSING HOMES TO HAVE
NINETY SIX HOURS OF BACKUP
POWER. IN THE EVENT OF A POWER
OUTAGE RESULTING FROM AN
EMERGENCY NATURAL DISASTER OF
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF.
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
DEFINITIONS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE SOLAR.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER NAZARIAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS BOTH BOTH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL.
LOWS THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS FORTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES. AND IN A
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FOUR SB
FIVE FOUR OH SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL 46% OF
GRANDMOTHERS AND ACCOLADE
HEALTHCARE AND CLEARLY YEARS
EITHER UPS TAKE FACSIMILE AFTER
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THAT
IN THINKING THAT IS SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS IS AN OMNIBUS
SENATE COMMITTEE BILL TO CODIFY
CLARIFYING CORRECT EXISTING
LAW. I'M WILLING TO GO INTO A
LOT OF DETAIL IF YOU'D LIKE. OR
SIMPLY JUST ASK YOU ARRIVE A.
ALL. I DON'T SEE ANY MIKE
SEPSIS SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE EVERY.
THIRD OF THE- ALL MEMBERS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD VOTE. REQUIRES
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. CARS FIFTY FOUR
ALL MEMBERS VOTED ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. OUR MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
FIFTY FIVE NEWS HERE ON THE
URGENCY I FIFTY FIVE KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE MEASURE THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GONNA
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FIVE SB
FOUR NINETY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL FOUR
NINETY THREE BY SYNTAXIN
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE IN
EDUCATION. GONZALEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SB FOUR NINETY THREE
OUTLINES TRANSPARENT FAIR AND
EQUITABLE PROCESS FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS TO
FOLLOW WHEN RESPONDING TO
INCIDENCES OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT VIOLENCE IN HIGHER
EDUCATION IS PERVASIVE SIXTY
POINT 2% OF WOMEN AND 61% OF
MEN EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COLLEGE IN MORE THAN
ONE IN FIVE WOMEN IN NEARLY ONE
IN EIGHTEEN MEN ARE SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED WHILE IN COLLEGE.
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
GROUPS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE SEXUAL VIOLENCE
INCLUDING WOMEN STUDENTS OF
COLOR AND LGBTQ STUDENTS
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
VIOLENCE NOT ONLY SUFFER
PHYSICALLY AND EMOTIONALLY BUT
ARE DENIED EQUAL ACCESS TO
EDUCATION. AMONG THE MANY
HARMFUL RESULTS OF HARASSMENT
ASSAULT IS A PATCH PUSH OUT
THAT OCCURS WHEN SCHOOLS FAIL
TO TAKE APPROPRIATE STEPS TO
RESPOND TO THESE INCIDENTS AN
ESTIMATED 34% OF STUDENTS
SURVIVORS DROP OUT OF COLLEGE.
EXISTING FEDERAL AND STATE
CIVIL RIGHTS LAW PROHIBITS SEX
DISCRIMINATION IN REQUIRE EQUAL
ACCESS TO EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES IN SCHOOL THAT
RECEIVE GOVERNMENT FUNDING
INCLUDING REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO
RESPOND TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
SEXUAL VIOLENCE HOWEVER THERE
IS INSUFFICIENT STATE LAW OR
AGENCY GUIDANCE REGARDING THE
STEPS THAT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES SHOULD ACCEPT. TO
TAKE. TO RESPOND TO THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS. SB FOUR
NINETY THREE WOULD ENSURE THE
COLLEGES COMPLY WITH EXISTING
LAW AND PROVIDE A FAIR PROCESS
FOR ALL PARTIES PROTECT THE
CIVIL RIGHTS SAFETY AND WELL
BEING OF STUDENTS. AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TAKEN AN ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS ADD CLARITY
REGARDING THE SCOPE OF AN
INSTITUTION'S OBLIGATIONS
ENSURE THE BILL'S REQUIREMENTS
ARE FEASIBLE FOR SCHOOLS TO
IMPLEMENT. THE MEMONS ALSO
CLARIFY THE INTERACTION OF THE
BILL WITH FEDERAL LAW. OVER THE
COURSE OF THIS TO YOUR BILL.
THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND HAS
ENGAGED IN EXTENSIVE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AS A RESULT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY ARE
NOW IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THERE IS NO CURRENT OPPOSITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR EIGHT NINETY THREE AND
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
IT FORWARD. THE NEW TITLE NINE
REGULATIONS ISSUED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAVE BEEN
SEVERELY CRITICIZED THE NOT
ONLY HARMFUL AND RE
TRAUMATIZING TO SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ASSAULT. BUT
ALSO CONTRARY TO THE VERY ANTI
DISCRIMINATION. PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE ENSHRINED IN TITLE
NINE THESE NEW REGULATIONS
REVERSED DECADES OF WORK TO TRY
TO ADDRESS RAMPS SO ASSAULT. IN
HIGHER EDUCATION IN ORDER TO
ENSURE EQUAL ACCESS TO
EDUCATION FOR ALL STUDENTS. FOR
THAT REASON NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND COMMENTS WERE
SUBMITTED OPPOSING THE
REGULATIONS. AND FOR LAWSUITS
HAVE BEEN FILED AS WELL AS AG
BECERRA NOTED THIS IS TWENTY
TWENTY NOT NINETEEN TWENTY. OUR
FOCUS SHOULD BE ON PROTECTING
OUR STUDENTS AND FAMILIES NOT
BURDENING ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS
WITH COMPLICATED BACKWARD
REGULATIONS MEMBERS URGE AYE
VOTE ON SB FOUR NINETY THREE.
THANK YOU MR BONTA SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED A VERY
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE WELL WHO
LOSE THEIR ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE IS FORTY EIGHT NEWS NINE
THIS MEASURE PASSES. MOVING THE
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SIX S. B.
FIVE NINETY TO THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY
TWO BY CENTER WIENER ANOTHER
PERSON I MANAGERS. CAR YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB FIVE
NINETY TWO BY SUNDAR WE
REQUIRES COURTS TO INCLUDE
STATE TAX FILINGS WHEN CREATING
PERSPECTIVE JURY POOLS WITH THE
RECENT POLICE KILLINGS GEORGE
FLOYD BROWN A TAILOR THE RIVER
TOBIN NINETEEN I'LL BREAK A
SEND CLINTON AND THE NATIONAL
CONVERSATION. ABOUT RACISM
ARTICLE JUSTICE SYSTEM SB FIVE
NINETY TWO IS MORE RELEVANT
THAN EVER NOW IS THE TIME TO
REMAKE OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM FROM THE GROUND UP FROM
POLICING TO OUR COURTS AND
SYSTEM OF MASS INCARCERATION.
SB FIVE NINETY TWO IS ONE
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THIS PUZZLE
WE HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO A JURY OF OUR PEERS THAT IS
A TRUE REPRESENTATION OF OUR
DIVERSITY BUT THIS MAY FALL
SHORT WHEN COURTS ONLY USE DMV
RECORDS AND VOTER OF THE SHOWN
TO EXCLUDE LARGE SWATHS OF OUR
POPULATION MAINLY. RACIAL
MINORITIES NOT ONLY DOES THIS
EXCLUSION RESULT IN RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC DISPARITIES IN
CALIFORNIA JURY POOLS IT ALSO
DEPRIVES CALIFORNIA COURTS OF
THOUSANDS OF PROSPECTIVE JURORS
BY EXPANDING THE REQUIRED
SOURCE PROSPECTIVE JURORS TO
INCLUDE A LIST OF STATE TAX
FILERS. SB FIVE HUNDRED TO
ALLOW THE JURY TO BE MORE
INCLUSIVE AND DIVERSE WHILE
JURIES ARE THE BACKBONE OF OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM THEY CAN ONLY
SPEAK WITH THE VOICE AND
AUTHORITY OF THE COMMUNITY THEY
TRULY AND ACCURATELY REFLECT
THAT COMMUNITY. SB FIVE NINETY
TWO IS A COMMONSENSE REFORM TO
OUR JURY SYSTEM THAT ADVANCES
FAIRNESS DIVERSITY AND
LEGITIMACY AND CALIFORNIA'S
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU CALL
C. HEARING NO FURTHER ON THE
CAR WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTE. ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ON. BURKE WELL
WUSTA ROLLING TELEVOTE EYES
FORTY SIX KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE THIRD
READING ASSEMBLY FILE AT THIS
TIME. WORKING CURRENT SERVICE
MEMBERS THERE ARE SEVERAL BILLS
THAT WE WILL TAKE UP AS A
SINGLE GROUP OF BILLS WITH ONE
VOTE. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL
TAKE ONE VOTE ON THE FIRST ITEM
AND THEN SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE ON
THE REMAINING FORTY FOUR ITEMS
THAT HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED BY BOTH CAUCUSES. THE
CLERK WILL READ THE FIRST BILL
ITEM NUMBER. TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
FOUR NINETY NINE. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR NINETY NINE BY SOME
INFORMATION OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
THE STATE GOVERNMENT. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS DESERVE A. YEAH. WHERE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
THE CLERK WILL NOW READ THE
REMAINING BILLS. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX I FIFTY
THREE NO ZERO SUM AGO NINETEEN
FORTY NINE. THERE ARE SOME OF
THE NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. NO
THERE'S SOME LEGAL TWENTY FORTY
FIFTY FOR YOU KNOW THERE ARE
SOME LEGAL TWENTY ONE HUNDRED.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SUM
LEGAL TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FIVE
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
WILL TWENTY SIX SIXTY THREE.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY ONE. YOU KNOW THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY NINE TWENTY.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY FORTY THREE.
ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTY NINETY
NINE. ZERO ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTY
TWO TWENTY THREE NO ZERO SUM
AGO NINE AWAIT EARNERS ADDED I
FIFTY THREE NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE I SIXTY THREE KNOWS
EARLIER TODAY ASSEMBLY GO LIVE
IN. SIXTY ONE SIXTY THREE NINE
ZERO SOME LITTLE TWELVE EIGHTY
ONE. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
FIFTY FIFTY THREE NO ZERO SUM
AGO EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SUM LEGAL
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN. I WAS
THERE ARE SOME OF THE NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE. NO ZERO SOME OF
THE NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR. NO
THERE ARE SOME LEGAL TWENTY
THIRTEEN. NO ZERO SUM AGO.
TWENTY FOURTEEN SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SUM LEGAL TWENTY SIXTY
EIGHT. I KNOW THERE ARE SOME
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY THREE ELEVEN
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SUM LEGAL
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY WILL
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY NINE FIFTY
THREE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE FORTY FOUR CHATTED.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE ON THE MEASURE
I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO ON THE
REGION SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY THREE. ZERO SOME LEGAL
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR. SOME
PEOPLE THIRTY SEVENTY THREE.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
THIRTY THREE SIXTY TWO. THERE
ARE SOME PEOPLE THIRTY THREE
SEVENTY. AS THERE ARE SOME
LEGAL THIRTY THREE SEVENTY TWO.
ZERO SOMETHING CURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE OF SEVEN.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE TWELVE THERE'S SOMETHING
CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
NINETEEN. THERE ARE SOME THE
CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. ZERO AN ASSEMBLY WILL
TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE FIFTY
THREE NO ZERO. SENATE
AMENDMENTS HAVEBEEN TINKERED
IN.
WE'RE GOING TO FILE ITEM
ONE AB CHIU FORTY THE
CARBURETOR ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FORTY BY SIN REMEMBER- ONE
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE THE
VETERANS HOMES WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWO FORTY IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE- IT'S THE
CULMINATION OF YEARS OF WORK
INCLUDING AN AUDIT I REQUEST ON
LEASES AND OTHER THIRD PARTY
USES OF THE VETERANS. HOMES
PROPERTY THIS BILL IMPLEMENTS
THE CHIEF RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
AROSE FROM THE AUDIT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
THOUGH. THANK YOU MESSAGE IRWIN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED A VERITABLE. ALL MEMBERS
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. RIGHT HER
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
COMPARED IN WILL PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS TWO
THROUGH. FOR MOVING THE FILE
ITEM FIVE EIGHTY FIFTEEN FIFTY
ONE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA
ANOTHER'S MEDICALLY THE
PROPERTY ASSESSMENTS. KING I.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
ADDS CONSUMER PROTECTIONS TO
THE PAYS PROGRAM PROVIDING
PROPERTY OWNERS WITH ADDED
TRANSPARENCY IN INFORMATION
ABOUT THE SERIOUS FINANCIAL
INVESTMENT. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES AND THE AMENDMENTS
IN THE SENATE INCLUDE AN OPT
OUT OPTION FOR WRITTEN
DISCLOSURES THAT HAVE REMOVED
ALL OPPOSITION FROM THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND I ARE TONIGHT
VOTE ON AB FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE.
THANK YOU DR EMBARRASSING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. TOM EVERY
THIRTY TO THIRTY VOTE BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALITHA
I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CAN CURTAIN WILL
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
SIX AND SEVEN MOVING TO. FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX THE KERKORIAN. SOME AGO
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE MENTAL HEALTH CARE
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED GOOD
AFTERNOON- MENACE BAKER I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EGGMAN TO PRESENT AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX FOR
CONCURRENCE. AFTER MORE THAN A
DECADE OF CONTINUED
IMPLEMENTATION FEEL THAT THIS
THAT THE DEMONSTRATION PROJECT
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL SO THE BILL
REPEALS THE SUNSET DATE AND THE
LAW STILL REQUIRES REGULAR
REPORTING MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
CORRECTED A DRAFTING AARON
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION TO JULY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO GIVE
COUNTIES MORE TIME. ALSO SINCE
A BILL THAT THIS HOUSE THE
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT ON LPS
WAS RELEASED IN CALLS FOR AN
EXPANSION OF THESE SERVICES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DR AMULET. YOUR
DOCTOR WOULD. ASKING FOR THE
DEBATE ON THE MATTER. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
THERE TO VOTE. IT'S ONLY EIGHT
AND I'M READY MIXING YOU UP ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IN THERE TO
VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORD IN MOVING A FILE ITEM
NINE AB NINETEEN NINETY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
GO NINETEEN NINETY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER AND
OTHERS AND ACCORDING TO
EMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION AND TO
CLEAR THE YEARS HEROES TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED GOOD EVENING MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB NINETEEN
NINETY THREE IS BACK FROM
SENATE CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
INCLUDES AN EMERGENCY CLAUSE IT
ADDS CO AUTHORS MAKE THE
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
CLARIFIED THAT WOULD APPLY TO
WAVER PERSONAL CARE SERVICES.
PROGRAM PROVIDERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU MISS COMMON
C. AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED THERE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS GO TO DO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALONG MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. COMMITTEE BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT VOTE
I SIXTY THREE KNOWS YOU'RE ON
THE MEASURE I FIFTY THREE KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY THE
MEASURE PASSES. WITH A
SENTIMENT I THINK OCCURRED IN.
LEVINE A FILE ITEM TEN AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE THIRTEEN BY SIN REMEMBER
LOW ANOTHER SNACK LINDA
PROFESSIONS OF LOCATIONS HELLO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTEEN IS BIPARTISAN
MEASURE BACK FOR CONCURRENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR LOS SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE USER TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS DESERVE A THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT
VOTE IS FIFTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. WE'RE IN A VIOLATE ELEVEN
AB. TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO THE
CLERK WILL READ SO OF THE TO
ONE FOR TWO SIMPLY GLORIA
ANOTHER AN ACCOLADE AND PUBLIC.
IF YOU ARE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY TWO IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION FROM
THIS. BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VERY VOTE. HOME MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY THREE KNOWS ONCE
AND AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM TWELVE AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GALLAGHER AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE IN THE HOMELESSNESS.
IT'S GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
FOUR IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE AND
AUTHORIZES YUBA AND SUTTER
COUNTIES TO FORM A JOINT
HOMELESS MULTIPLE. MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM. S. SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE CLARIFYING THE
NATURE AND I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
GALLAGHER SAYING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE-
VOTER TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WE'RE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELEVOTE I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE COMPARED IN.
FILE ITEM LOOPBACK AFTER FILE
ITEM FOR AB FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER
ANOTHER IT'S AN ACCOLADE IN THE
CANNABIS IF YOU'RE DOWN FOR YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE
IS BACK FROM CONCURRENT AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE WAS
RECENTLY AMEND IT AND SEND
APPROPRIATIONS ARE CLARIFIED
THAT CANNABIS LICENSEES ARE
ABLE TO WITHDRAW THEIR TRACK
AND TRACE DATA. FROM A
FINANCIAL SERVICE PROVIDER AT
ANY TIME AB FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE
WHICH WOULD ALLOW STATE AND
LOCAL ELECTIONS THE AUTHORITY
SHE SHARE A BUSINESS TRACK AND
TRACE INFORMATION. ANOTHER
REGULATORY INFORMATION WITH THE
BUSINESS BANK ONLY AT THE
EXPLICIT WRITTEN REQUEST OF THE
BUSINESS. THIS BILL WILL HELP
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS BETTER
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND ALSO QUALIFIES
PROTECTIONS UNDER STATE LAW FOR
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS THAT
SERVE TO THE INDUSTRY. SOME
OPPOSITION GROUPS HAVE MADE
CLAIMS AGAINST THIS BILL THAT
ARE NOT REFLECTIVE OF THE
LANGUAGE ABSENT OF TRUTH AND
HAVE GIVEN THAT EVEN GIVEN AS A
LOAN TO ATTACK ONE OF OUR
SUPPORTERS ON THE BASIS OF
THEIR GENDER. AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
FIVE EMPOWERS CANNABIS
BUSINESSES BY GIVING THEM THE
OPTION TO SHARED A TRACK AND
TRACE DATA WITH A FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION OF THEIR CHOICE FOR
THE SOLE PURPOSE OF
FACILITATING FINANCIAL
SERVICES. AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
FIVE DOES NOT GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MORE JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES ANY ADDITIONAL
JURISDICTION BAND ALREADY HAVE
CURRENT ANY LOCAL LICENSING
AUTHORITY CAN RQUIRE A
CANNABIS BUSINESS IN A
JURISDICTION TO SHARED A TRACK
AND TRACE DATA. AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY FIVE DOES NOT REQUIRE
ANY BUSINESS TO TURN OVER THEIR
TRACK AND TRACE INFORMATION TO
ANYONE. THIS BILL IS 1100%
VOLUNTARY AND IS ACTIVATED ONLY
AT THE EXPLICIT REQUEST OF THE
CANNABIS BUSINESS AB FIFTEEN.
TWENTY FIVE DOES NOT GIVE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS ACCESS
TO FINANCIAL INFORMATION
WITHOUT LIMITS ACCORDING TO THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS WILL ONLY HAVE
ACCESS TO INFORMATION THAT IS
REALLY REASONABLY NECESSARY
NECESSARY. TO FACILITATE THE
PROVISION OF FINANCIAL SERVICES
FOR THE LICENSEE MAKING A
REQUEST FOR THAT BANK TO ACCESS
TO TRACK AND TRACE. INFORMATION
A. B. FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE DOES
NOT GIVE FINANCIAL.
INSTITUTIONS THE ABILITY
DEFAULT STEEL OR PROFIT OFF. OF
TRACY OF ALL RECIPES A FIFTY
TWENTY FIVE IST MISTER BECAUSE
FOR CAN BUSINESS. TO RELY ON A
CASH ONLY SYSTEM IS A PUBLIC
SAFETY RISK. THIS BILL WILL
PROP UP THE LEGAL CANNABIS
INDUSTRY MAKING IT EASIER FOR
BUSINESSES TO RUN TO PAY YOUR
TAXES. THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED
BY INDUSTRY GROUPS AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS ALIKE
WHO RECOGNIZED THE NECESSITY OF
THIS LEGISLATION PROVIDES
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL SERVICES.
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR ALBUM. THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER. SEEING MR
LOADED YOU WANT TO BE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
HEARD IN LIVING BACK IN FILE
ORDER TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT BY SOME
WE WERE BELOW IN OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE HEALING ARTS IN THE
CLEAR THERE'S HEROES TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MR LOW YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. MISTER JNES SAWYER
EASIER RECOGNITION NOW. NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS. VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED OUT OF A WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
ONE KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE MEASURE
I SIXTY ONE KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
URGENCY SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
COMPARED IN. FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER AN
ACCOLADE IN JUVENILE COURT
RECORDS. IF YOU'RE JONES ARE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AGAIN. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS WE
SHORTER AB TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
BACK FROM THAN CURRENT
SENTIMENT THREE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND SIMPLY ADDRESSED
CHAPTER IN ISSUES. WITH SB.
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX ARE STRICTLY
AFTER RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
JONES SAWYER SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON A- VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO VERIFY CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THAT I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED IN
MOVING A FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AN
ACCOLADE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES IT'S A GREAT THING YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES- AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN CERTAIN
AREAS EXISTING CRITERIA FOR IHS
US REASSESSMENT EXTENSIONS AND
CONFORMS TO THE HUMAN SERVICES
BUDGET BILL OF TWENTY TWENTY A.
B. TWENTY THREE SEVEN ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE I RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON.
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
THERE TO VOTE. ON THE VOTED TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY
BOTH. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALITHA I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORD IN MOVING A FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE
BY SOME THE MEMORY IS AN
ACCOLADE A CIVIL ACTIONS AND
THE CLEARLY YEARS EITHER UP
SIGNIFICANTLY THREATS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SENATE AMENDMENTS MAKE
THIS AN URGENCY BILL THIS BILL
ALLOWS A LEGAL GUARDIAN TO SEEK
JUSTICE FOR CHILD WAS PASSED
AWAY TO THE WRONGFUL CONDUCT OF
ANOTHER WHEN THE CHILD'S
PARENTS CANNOT DO SO BECAUSE
THEY ARE DECEASED. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS REYES. HEARING
OVER DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. WILL
BE THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS THAT YOU DESIRE TO VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALITHA I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
ON THE MEASURE I SIXTY THREE
NOTES HERE ON THE URGENCY
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARKAN AND
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY THREE BY
SIMPLY REVERTING AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO CLEAR THE ABSENCE EITHER UP
TO TAKE THE COMMUNITY MISTER
KING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY THREE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE BILL EXPAND
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN. HOMELESS
SHELTER PROGRAM STATEWIDE AND
EXTENDS A SUNSET UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY SIX A. B. TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY THREE DOORS BIPARTISAN.
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU MR TANG
THING IN HERE OR FOR THE- ABOUT
TO COURT OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED ERA. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER TO VOTE. WHERE WILL LOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY THREE NOTES HERE ON THE
MEASURE I SIXTY THREE KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED IN
MOVING A FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME LEGAL
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN BY SOME
REMEMBER CHAO ACCOLADE INTO. AN
UNATTENDED CHILDREN. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS- AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE. THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WOULD ALIGN THE BILL
WITH EXISTING MEDICAL CONTROL
POLICIES REGARDING EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS PROVIDING
TRANSPORTATION TO A HOSPITAL
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER
TRAVERSING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN. ON THIS
VOTER TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS TO
FAIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
THIRTY VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TALITHA I SIXTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CAN HEARD IN
LUNA FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE
INOCULATING THE COLLATERAL
RECOVERY. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY NINE LOWERS
BARRIERS TO ENTRY IN THE
COLLATERAL RECOVERY INDUSTRY.
SENATE AMENDMENTS NARROW THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL AND SOLVE
MINOR IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVER.
THANK YOU MR OBERNOLTE AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR FINAL
BILL ON THE FLOOR IS THAT
CORRECT. YES SIR. BURKE WELL
OPEN THE ROLE. HOME MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A. BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING
VOTE I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME MIDDLE TWENTY
NINE SIXTY BUCKS IN THE RIVER
GIPSON ANOTHER'S MACULATUS
SHELTERS GOOD THING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THAT A SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWENTY NINE SIX IS
BACK ON THE FLOOR FOR
CONCURRENCE. THIS MEMBER
SPECIFY REASONABLE ALTERNATIVE
FOR FIRE SAFETY REQUIRE
QUARTERLY INSPECTIONS FOR THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL AND SUNSET
THIS BILL IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY VOTE THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND IS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER GIPSON THING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VERY GOOD. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED VERY VOTE. CLERK WILL
LOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT VOTE I
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE FEATURED IN A
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB THIRTY
TWELVE THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
OF BILL THIRTY TWELVE ISOMER
WOULDN'T RECYCLING INSURANCE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB THIRTY TWELVE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY OPERATIONS
OF THE FAIR PLAN CLEARING HOUSE
AND ADDRESS CHAPTER IN OUT
AMENDMENTS. BILLS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DR
ED SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN TO. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHERE TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED
IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
TWO AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME MIDDLE
THIRTY ONE THIRTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRANDMOTHERS
ACCOLADE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES IN
THE CLINTON YEARS EITHER UPS
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY MR GRAY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER THIS IS THE
ANNUAL ON THE BUS G. O. BILL IT
FIXES SAN FRANCISCO HELPS
NONPROFITS THERE'S OFFICE ISSUE.
THANK YOU MISTER GRACING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER.
WELL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALITA I SIXTEEN OH ZERO ON THE
MEASURE I SIXTEEN IS THERE ON
THE URGENCY. SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY ULE THIRTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR BY SOME MEMBER FRIEDMAN
ANOTHER SNACK LATE TO FIRE
PREVENTION THREE MEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB THIRTY
ONE SIXTY FOUR DIRECT QUALIFIER
IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER. AND AN
ADVISORY WORKING GROUP TO
DEVELOP A PERSONAL LEVEL
WILDFIRE RISK METAL TO HELP
COMMUNITIES UNDERSTAND THE RISK
AND WHAT THEY CAN DO TO REDUCE
THE RISK FROM WILDFIRE. SENATE
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE
CLARIFICATION THE COMMUNITY
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING
NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE AS A
COMMUNITY BUFFER. ALLOWS THE
FIRE CHIEF USE IT DOES IT MEAN
WHEN SERVING ON THE ADVISORY
WORKGROUP SUNSET THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL ON JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. MAKES
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
WITHOUT I REQUEST FULLY. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST IN CURRENT
RECURRING IN THE SENTIMENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN SAYING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE I'M OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL. CALL.
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
HOME VOTED TO IT. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
ROAD ICE IF YOU KNOW ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR
AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE BY
SIMPLY REMOVE LEVINE AN
ACCOLADE TO IMPLEMENT THE
CLEARLY IS EITHER OF THE KICK
ME LEE. I MEAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS WE ADDED
URGENCY TO THIS BILL WHICH
PROMOTES AGE APPROPRIATE
DISCUSSIONS AMONG MINERS AND
THEIR PARENTS OR GUARDIANS
ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION AND CREATE A SAFER
WORKPLACE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR LOW SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE IN
THE MATTER. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
EITHER TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS GO
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE I SIXTY THREE KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. WE
HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
TWENTY FIVE. LEVINE A FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX AB SIX FORTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOMETHING REAL
SIX FORTY SIX BY SOME MEMBER
MCCARTY ANOTHER SNACK LEADING
TO ELECTIONS MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THIS IS A COMPANION
MEASURE TO ACA SIX NOW PROP
pBALLOT RELATED VOTING RIGHTS
FOR FORMERLY INCARCERATED.
TECHNICAL MOMENTS FROM THE
SENATE ASK FOR YOUR CONCURRENCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR MCCARTY
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE RAW. NUMBERS
VOTER TO VOTE. HOME VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. OUR MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THOSE
EYES FORTY FOUR KNOWS A LEVIN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED
IN. LITTLE. PASS AND RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN. WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEMS
TWENTY EIGHT THROUGH THIRTY ONE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO
AB TWENTY FIFTY FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KAMLAGER ANOTHER PERSON
ACCORDING TO EMERGENCY SERVICES
COMMA ARE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
GOOD EVENING MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FIFTY FOR THE
CRISIS ACT ESTABLISHES A PILOT
PROGRAM TO SCALE UP COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AS FIRST
RESPONDERS. I MEMBERS CLARIFIED
THAT THE TYPES OF EMERGENCY
RESPONSES TO CRISIS SITUATIONS
ARE THOSE THAT ARE NOT RELATED
TO OR DO NOT REQUIRE A FIRE
DEPARTMENT OR EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICE RESPONSE. AMENDMENTS
ALSO ADDED CRITERIA FOR GRANTEE
ELIGIBILITY THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
KAMLAGER SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL. MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE A. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALITHA I SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONFERRED IN WE HAVE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ AN
ACCOLADE IN THE BUSINESS. MS
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THIS IS A GOOD BILL- MADAM
SPEAKER AND I HAD THE
AMENDMENTS SIMPLIFY THE BILL
IT'S STILL HAS THE SUPPORT OF
THE CALIFORNIA RSTAURANT
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR. FEDERATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
BOTH. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED ALREADY VOTED. BURKE WILL
LOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY I SIXTY
ONE NO SIX SENTIMENTS ARE
COMPARED AND WE HAVE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEMS THIRTY FIVE AND
THIRTY SIX WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS FILE
ITEM THIRTY SEVEN A MOVE TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AND
ACCORDING TO CIVIL ACTIONS IT'S
JUST DOWN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY THREE WHICH I'M
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY
PROTECTS FARMERS FROM HAVING
THEIR HOME FORCIBLY SOLD IN
ORDER TO SATISFY A JUDGMENT.
FROM A CAN FOR A CONSUMER DEBT
SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFIED
EXEMPTIONS IN CERTAIN
CATEGORIES AND AFTER GO SHE
ASIANS WITH THE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CREDIT
UNION WE- THEY ADDED AMENDMENT
WITH THAT TO CAP THE DEBTS OWED
TO THOSE FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. IT'S RECEIVE NO
NO VOTES AND I ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTER CONCURRENT. THANK YOU
MISTRESS. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED A VERITABLE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. WHERE WILL LOWS THE
ROLE IN TELLING VOTE I FIFTY
FIVE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENT.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COULD
HURT IN. HAVING BACKUP THE FILE
ITEM THIRTY SEVEN AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY THE CLERK WILL
RANGE CYNICAL TWENTY THREE
SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN ACCOLADE THE MENTAL
HEALTH. MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. SO I'VE SO MANY
HERE MADAM SPEAKER MR
MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE READING
THIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH MATTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
IN MOTHERS AND CHILDREN SAN
AMENDMENTS PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY
TO HELP ENSURE COMPLIANCE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND VOTE.
THANK YOU MR MAIN SINGH THERE
FOR DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE- EVERY
THIRTY TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED ALREADY VOTED.
CLERK WILL LOSE THE ROLLING
TALITHA ICD THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED
IN WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE
ITEM THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY NINE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO BY
SIMPLY WERE MURATSUCHI ANOTHER
PERSON ACCOLADE IN THE
COSMETICS MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
INTERESTED YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO IS MY- TOXICS
FREE COSMETICS ACT. TO BAN THE
SALE OF COSMETICS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA CONTAIN TWENTY
FOUR TOXIC CHEMICALS THIS IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE SENATE WITH NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER. DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW YOU VOTE I FIFTY NINE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
COMPARED IN WE HAVE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEMS FORTY ONE
THROUGH FORTY FIVE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM FORTY SIX AB SEVENTY
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY BY SUMMER BERMAN
ANOTHER RECYCLING PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION BERMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB SEVENTY IS A GOOD
BILL IT WOULD PREVENT- PREVENT
COVERT FOR PROFIT COLLEGES FROM
EVADING STATE OVERSIGHT
DECEIVING STUDENTS BY REQUIRING
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO VERIFY
WHETHER AN INSTITUTION THAT
CLAIMS TO BE A NONPROFIT
COLLEGE IS ACTUALLY OPERATING
AS A NONPROFIT. SENATE
AMENDMENTS REMOVE OPPOSITION
AND DELAY A SECTIONS OPERATIVE
DATE BY. ONE YEAR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR BERMAN.
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
INCURRED IN. PASS AND RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN MOVING TO
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB THREE
SEVENTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SEVENTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARK STONE
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
STUDENT LOANS. STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. THIS BILL
IS THE STUDENT BORROWER BILL OF
RIGHTS SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS EVEN THOUGH IT PASSED
OFFICE FLOOR WITH FIFTY NINE
VOTES WE STRUGGLED A BIT IN THE
SENATE. AND TOOK SOME
AMENDMENTS SUBSTANTIAL
AMENDMENTS WHAT WE DID IS THAT
A RIGHT TO CURE THE PERIOD FOR
THOSE STUDENTS SERVICERS WE'VE
EXEMPTED FEDERALLY. CHARTERED
CREDIT UNIONS AND PROVIDED SOME
OF THE EXEMPTIONS THAT THE
BANKING INDUSTRY. WAS ASKING
FOR THIS IS A BILL THAT
PROTECTS. STUDENT BORROWERS IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE FRANKLY NO
ONE ELSE IS LOOKING OUT FOR
THEM. I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
IN CONCURRENCE WITH THOSE
SENTIMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
SENSING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. VERY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALITHA FIVE FIFTY ONE
KNOWS TEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE.
INCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FORTY NINE NINE FOR THE WILL RE.
SOME PEOPLE NINE OH FOUR BY
CHOWING ACCOLADE A SEARCH
WARRANT SHALL YOU ARE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AB
NINE OH FOUR WILL CLARIFY THE
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES CANNOT USE
TRACKING SOFTWARE TO TRACK THE
MOVEMENT OF A PERSON OR OBJECT
WITHOUT THE WARRANT THE SENATE
MEMONS REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAO'S
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE- MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALITHA I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCORD
N. WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE
ITEMS FIFTY. THROUGH FIFTY TWO.
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM FIFTY THREE WE'VE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM FIFTY
FOUR. WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE. WE
HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEMS
FIFTY SIX. THROUGH. FIFTY
EIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY NINE AB NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
LEGAL NINETEEN FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE TO EMERGENCY
SERVICES SALAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU BETTER
FIGURE MEMBERS THIS BILL
RECOGNIZE OUR BRAVE PUBLIC
SAFETY DISPATCHERS FOR THE
LIFESAVING WORK THAT THEY
PERFORM EVERY DAY BY
RECLASSIFYING RECLASSIFYING
THEM AS FIRST RESPONDERS SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL
NATURE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
SALAS SAYING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS.
OF THE- HOME MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRTY VOTE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALITHA I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
IRVING TO FILE ITEM SIXTY AB
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY GO NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU AN ACCOLADE OF CHILD
ABUSE OR NEGLECT IF YOU'RE
KANSEN CHU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKERS ARE
MEMBERS AB NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
WILL MAKE SURE. THAT ONE A
REPORT OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN
THE WORKPLACE IS BROUGHT UP BY
A MINOR. THE COMPLAINT WILL BE
MADE TO A TRAINED MANDATED
REPORTER. SO THAT ALL OF THEIR
RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW WOULD BE
PROTECTED. THE SENATE AMENDMENT
INCLUDE NARROW THE BILL. TO
BUSINESS OFF FIVE OR MORE
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE COVERED
UNDER THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT OF
HOUSING ACT. ALSO SPECIFIED A
MANDATED REPORTER. MANDATED
REPORTER REQUIREMENT. IS FULL
ADULT SUPERVISOR. ALSO PROVIDE
A DEFINITION OF HUMAN RESOURCES
EMPLOYEES FRONT X. SIX THINGS
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PREVENTION
PAUL. ALLOW THE EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE TRAINING
THROUGH THE FREE ONLINE
TRAINING FOR. FOR MANDATED
REPORTERS BY THE OFFICE OF
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION IN THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. THIS WILL HAVE NO
OPPOSITION. AND I ASK FOR YOUR
RIVALS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHOOSING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED AMERICA. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE FIVE FIFTEEN OH
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORDANT WE HAVE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE
THROUGH SIXTY FOUR WILL PASS
AND RETAIN AND FILE ITEM. SIXTY
FIVE. WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH
FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN X. MOVING
TO FILE ITEM.
I THINK IF I LET
HIM SIXTY SEVEN AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME AGO TWENTY TO
SEVENTY FIVE BY SIMPLY MEMBERS
HEARING ANOTHER SNACK LATER
HOMELESSNESS IN THE COMING
YEARS EITHER OF STICK FACT
MERELY. CAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AMENDMENTS AND SENATE WERE
ADDED TO INCLUDE AN URGENCY
CLAUSE- THIS MEASURE HAS
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL
MEMBERS OF THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED EITHER TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY NINE IS
HERE ON THE MEASURE IS FIFTY
NINE NEWS HERE ON THE URGENCY
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED
IN WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH
VIOLATING SIXTY EIGHT MOVING TO
FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE AB TWENTY
THREE FOURTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 23-14 BY
SOME REMEMBER ALMOST ANOTHER
SNACK LATER VOTERS AROUND US
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
THANK YOUMADAM SPEAKER- AB
TWENTY THREE FOURTEEN IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL AIMS
TO INCREASE NATIVE AMERICAN
VOTER ASSESS ABILITY. TO THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS BY
ESTABLISHING AND NATIVE
AMERICAN VOTING ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU MR
RAMA SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. OF. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE FIVE SIXTEEN OH ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED
IN WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE
ITEM SEVENTY FILE ITEM SEVENTY
ONE AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AN
ACCOLADE TO FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS THIS RACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. ON BEHALF
OF THE MOTHER. OF BABY ELOISE.
MOST OF YOU KNOW HER IS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS I'M
PRESENTING TO YOU AB TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY FOUR WHICH WILL
REMOVE LIMITATIONS ON LICENSING
OF DEBT SETTLEMENT COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA SENATE AMENDMENTS
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION THIS
BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
ON BABY ELOISE MOTHER'S BEHALF
I REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER AS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO BEAR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIRTY VOTE.
WHERE QUAYLE FLOWS THE ROLE AND
TALITHA I FIFTIES YOU KNOW ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED
IN. I MEAN WE HAVE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO AND
EVEN IF I LIVE SEVENTY THREE AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID CHIU
ANOTHER IT'S AN ACCOLADE IN THE
FIREARMS DAVID CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWENTY FORTY SEVEN
IS BACK IN CONCURRENCE THIS IS
A BILL THAT WILL ASSIST LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SOLVING GUN
RELATED CRIMES BE A MICRO
STAMPING TECHNOLOGY AND REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF ACCIDENTAL GUN
DEATHS AND INJURIES. AND THE
SENATE WE TOOK ONE TECHNICAL
MEMBER TO UPDATE GUN VIOLENCE
STATISTICS AND ADD CO AUTHORS
AND WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU MR
CHIU SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
ROAD THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED A VERY VOTE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING VOTE
EYES FORTY THREE KNOWS THIRTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED
IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FOUR AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME LEGAL
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW AN ACCOLADE THE
PUBLIC TRANSIT. HELLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU MR LOW SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED EITHER
TO VOTE. ALL EMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS FIFTY ONE KNOWS NINE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FIVE AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOR
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY GO
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN AN
ACCOLADE TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LOTTERY IN MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION OF FORTY CLEARLY
OR SEE THEIR ARTISTIC PICKING
ME LEE. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR WOULD
IT WITHOUT CREATING A MANDATE
ALLOW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS TO USE THE RESTRICTED
LOTTERY FUNDS. TO PROVIDE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE TO STUDENTS. THE
MOMENT STICKING THE SENATE
ADDED URGENCY CLAUSE ENABLING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
IMMEDIATELY ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF VULNERABLE STUDENTS DURING
THE CURRENT CRISIS. THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
BERMAN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
MOVED VERY TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY EIGHT
NOTES ONE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
COMPARED IN. I FIFTY EIGHT
KNOWS ONE OF THE URGENCY. WE
HAVE THE BEST A FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SIX MOVING TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME LEGAL TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GAVE ANOTHER
SNACK LATER FIREARMS. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THE BILL
WILL STRENGTHEN AND CLARIFY
CALIFORNIA LAW REGARDING GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS AND
WAS AMENDED IN THE SENATE TO
FURTHER CLARIFY THE PROCESS FOR
RECOGNIZING OUT OF STATE G.
VERREAUX'S THIS BILL PASSED THE
SENATE WITH UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL. VERY VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY GOOD.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING TELEVOTE
ICE FIFTY NINE NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE COULD BE HEARD
IN WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH
HIGHLIGHTED SEVENTY EIGHT
THROUGH EIGHTY MOVING THE FILE
ITEM EIGHTY ONE AB THIRTY NINE
TO THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
THIRTY NINETY TWO BY SO MEMBER
WEEKS ANOTHER SNACK LATEST
ELECTIONS YOUR CHAO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WAKES AND
PRESENT AB THIRTY NINETY TWO.
FULL CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS AB THIRTY NINETY TWO
REVISED CLAIMS BASED ON SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND OTHER INAPPROPRIATE
CONTACT COMMUNICATION OR
ACTIVITY OF A SEXUAL NATURE
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE BARRED
UNDER CURREN STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR ONE YEAR. THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ADDED CO
AUTHORS AND WORK NON
SUBSTANTIVE THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HOUSE NO REGISTER OPPOSITION
AYE ASTORIA AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAO SAYING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED VERA ALL MEMBERS
VOTED THIRD VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
GO TO THIRTY VOTE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING VOTE
I FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM EIGHTY TWO WE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEMS EIGHTY THREE
THROUGH EIGHTY NINE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM NINETY EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
BY SOME MEMBER WEEKS ANOTHER
WHICH ACTUALLY THE LAND USE.
THREE US YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER-
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
REQUIRES THAT METROPOLITAN
JURISTIC ALLOCATE 25% OF THE
MODERATE. AND MODERATE OR ABOVE
MODERATE A MODERATE HOUSING TO
MULTI FAMILY. PRODUCTION BY-
INSURING THAT WE CREATE MORE
MULTI MULTI FAMILY OPTIONS FOR
RESIDENTS WE ADDRESSING THE
INEQUITY IN OUR MORE FLUENT
AREAS OF THE STATE THIS IS A
BILL. BY OUR COLLEAGUE MISS
BUFFY WICKS THE BILL SPONSORED
BY CALIFORNIA BE SUPPORTED BY
SUPER. SB AT HOME CALIFORNIA
FOR A HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
ASSOCIATION AND I CA
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
ABOUT. THANK YOU MYSTERY
VESTING IN HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THAT SKEWS ME MISTER
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE NOT AS A-
REPRESENT OF A DISTRICT THAT
INCLUDES SOME OF THOSE AFFLUENT
COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL TAKES
AWAY LOCAL CONTROL I OPPOSE
THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MERECE. NOW SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS GO
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ONMEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ON NUMBER
THIRTY THIRD OF A.
OUR MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD ABOUT THIS
REQUIRES FORTY ONE. THE THREE
OF US MOVE THE CALL. MOVING TO
FILE ITEM NINETY ONE AB SEVEN
THIRTY TO THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME LEGAL SEVEN THIRTY TWO BY
SUMMER BONTA ANOTHER SNACK LANE
TO INCARCERATED PERSONS AROUND
TOO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB SEVEN THIRTY TWO
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE IT WILL
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE FOR
INCARCERATED PREGNANT
CALIFORNIANS IN COUNTY JAILS
AND STATE PRISONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR BONTA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
VERY VOTE THE CLERK. WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
FIFTIES YOU KNOW ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS NINETY TWO THROUGH NINETY
FOUR MOVING A FILE ITEM NINETY
FIVE AB FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME LEGAL
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT BY SOME OF
YOUR RECORDS. AND ACCOLADES
CANNABIS. MISTER CLARK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
MODIFIES THE LAB VARIANTS IN
CANNABIS TESTING. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS CHAPLAIN AT
ISSUE FOR WITH NO OPPOSITION
THERE'S BEEN BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIDE HOME. THANK YOU.
ALTHOUGH THE. THANK YOU DR WORK
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. BURKE
WILL LOSE THEIR ALL HOWYOU
VOTE IS FIFTY KNOWS ONCE AND
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN WE
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY AND FILE
ITEM NINETY SIX MOVED TO FILE
ITEM NINETY SEVEN AB TWENTY
FORTY THREE THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FORTY THREE
BY SOMEBODY MEMBER ROBERT AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO APPOINT A
CLEARLY WAS EITHER OF TECHNICAL
MEETING. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MATT SPEAKER
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE AD.
URGENCY CROSSES LEGISLATION.
MADE SOME. SOME TECHNICAL
CHANGES THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILLS THE AGRICULTURAL
WORKPLACE HEALTH AND SAFETY
ACT. HIS BELT THIS BILL PASSED
THE SENATE. WITH THIRTY THREE
VOTES AND THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION. RESPECT AS WE ARE
ABOUT THANK YOU MAN'S BIG.
THANK YOU MYSTERY THIS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. CALL VOTE WHERE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I DON'T KNOW NEVER MIND
CLERK WILL NOT CLOSE FOR ALL.
FIFTY FOUR. HOME MEMBERS VOTED
THERE TO VOTE. THIS. OKAY. OUR
MEMBERS VOTED ABOUT THIS
REQUIRES. FIFTY FOUR. BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY FIVE NO
ZERO ONE THE MEASURE I FIFTY
FIVE NEWS HERE ON THE URGENCY
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. MILLION A FILE ITEM NINETY
EIGHT AB TWENTY NINE TO THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND
ACTUALLY INTO EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE EMPLOYEES. MR
RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
A. B. TWENTY NINETY TWO AMENDS
IN THE SENATE STOP WAS A
VOLUNTARY SUBSIDIZED. PP
PERJURE PROGRAM FOR PRIVATE
SECTOR EMTS AND PARAMEDICS TO
BUY PROTECTIVE BODY GEAR. THESE
ARE MEMBERS REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER RODRIGUEZ SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED VERY TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY NO
SEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
INCURRED IN LIVING A FILE ITEM
NINETY NINE AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AN
ACCOLADE HIGHER EDUCATION
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS. RODRIGUEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE PRESENT AB
TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN WHICH IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE
CONCURRENCE THE SENATE MEMBERS
ARE TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
REGARDING LABOR RELATIONS IN
HIGHER EDUCATION RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
RODRIGUEZ SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS NOTED THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND RISE FORTY
SIX NO ELEVEN. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED AND
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TO EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY ACCESS TO HEALTH
SERVICES. SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED I THINK YOU MAY
SPEAKER AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN
OF BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AFTER
TAKING CLARIFYING THE MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE THIS BILL PROVIDE
MEDICAL DIRECT PORTS SERVICES
THE TGI COMMUNITY THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER SPEAKER EFFECT
LAST RIVAL. THANK YOU MR
SANTIAGO SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED A VERITABLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALITHA HIGHS FORTY FOUR
NEWS EIGHT SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MISTER RIVAS IS
PREPARED TO LET THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM NINETY AB SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE CORP WILL POST. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF A. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESERT ABODE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES. HIGHS FORTY
ONE KNOWS THIRTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED IN.
MOVING BACK ON THE FILE TO FILE
ITEM ONE OH ONE AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY TO SEVENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
ANOTHER SNACK LATER PUBLIC
HEALTH. THREATS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU. AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY SIX ADDRESSES THE
STATE'S POOR TRACK RECORD OF
ENSURING THAT THE CHILDREN.
MOST AT RISK. OF LEAD POISONING
ARE SCREENED AND TESTED FOR
LEAD EXPOSURE. SENATE
AMENDMENTS COMBINED THIS
MEASURE WITH EIGHTY TWENTY TO
SEVENTY NINE CRISTINA GARCIA.
AND AB TWENTY TWO. SEVENTY
SEVEN. AND AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN SALAS AND MAKE
OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES EARLIER
THIS YEAR REPORT OF THE STATE
AUDITOR FOUND MORE THAN ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION CHILDREN
COVERED BY MEDICARE OR DIDNOT
RECEIVE PROPER LEAD TESTS AND
CONCLUDED THAT ONLY 20% 27% OF
MEDICAL CHILDREN RECEIVE THE
TEST AS REQUIRED THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THESE ISSUES AND
PROTECTS CHILDREN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS RACING IN
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. VERY VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALITHA
I SIXTY FOUR NEWS ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE COMPARED IN.
THIS CONGRESS PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY TWO SB SIX TWENTY NINE
THE COR PROPOSED. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DARE TO VOTE. BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS
FIVE. THIS MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM WATER TO AB. TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN THE COURT WILL
READ SOME BILL TWO TWO A SEVEN
ASSEMBLY EGGMAN ANOTHER
NEGLIGENCE. FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I'M
HONORED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN THE BILL
ADDRESSES A FEW DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF OUR SOLID WASTE
STREAM INCLUDING CLEANING UP
AND UPDATING REFERENCES TO THE
GREAT ABILITY STANDARDS IN OUR
TRUTH IN ADVERTISING LAWS.
ADDING AN INTERNATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED STANDARD FOR
DEGRADABLE AGRICULTURAL FILM
EXTENDING THE TIMELINE BY SEVEN
MONTHS FOR THE STATEWIDE
COMMISSION ON RECYCLING MARKETS
AND CURBSIDE RECYCLING TO
FINALIZE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
INCREASED PUBLIC PARTICIPATION.
EXTENDING THE DEADLINE FOR
THEME PARKS TO INSTALL COMPOST
BINS FOR ONE YEAR DUE TO
BECAUSE OF IT THIS BILL HAS
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY SO FAR IN
BOTH HOUSES AND IS SUPPORTED BY
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS SOME IN
THE PLASTIC INDUSTRY THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU AND MORE
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON THE
RIVER VERY GOOD. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
NUMBER THIRTY THIRD OF THE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE INCURRED IN. MISTER MULLIN
IS PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY EIGHT SB
SEVEN THIRTY NINE THE CLERK
WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
EITHER TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS SIXTY ONE KNOWS ONE
OF THE MEASURE I SIXTY ONE
KNOWS ONE OF THE URGENCY BETTER
PASSES. MILLION BACK TO THE
FILE. FILE ITEM ONE OH THREE AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO OF THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI ANAK
LEYVA FIREARMS. G. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU THIS BILL
WILL AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TO LEVY FINES
AGAINST BAD ACTOR GUN DEALERS
IT'S SPONSORED BY THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN IS SUPPORTED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI SAYING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. VERITABLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IN THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DEVOTED TO CARS
FORTY ONE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW YOU VOTE HIGHS
FORTY TWO KNOWS FOURTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE TINKERED IN
LIVING A FILE ITEM ONE OH FOUR
AB TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME LEGAL
TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE ANOTHER SNACK
LATER HOUSING. THIS BURKE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AB TWENTY FOUR
OH FIVE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
AMENITY KITS AND EXPAND THE
RIGHT HOUSING FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES TO ALL INDIVIDUALS AND
REMOVE THE LOCAL MANDATE
AMENDMENTS SIMPLY SIMPLIFY THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS WITHIN
THE BILLS WELL HOUSING SHOULD
BE A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT FOR ALL
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST WE CAN
CURRENT. AMENDMENTS AND- THANK
YOU MISS BURKE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. VOTE WHERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ON MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR
VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS FIFTY
SIX KNOWS FIVE SENTIMENTS ARE
COMPARED IN. WE DIVIDE ONE OF
FIVE AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME MIDDLE
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE IN LAND USE FACTOR
BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY ONE. WILL ENABLE
NUMBER MOBILE COMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDERS PRINCIPLE BACKUP
POWER GENERATORS. AN EXISTING
CELL SITES MORE QUICKLY THAN
EXPECTED IN THE SENATE I
SATISFIED CONCERNS OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
WHERE RESOURCES BOARD. AND THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY.
PROBABLY REQUESTED I'VE ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER KIRK SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF
IT. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLIED ABOUT ICE FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE COULD HURT IN MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE OR SIX AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME LEGAL TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARK STONE AND ACTUALLY THE
JUVENILES DOWN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS ANOTHER
IN THE SERIES OF RECORD SEALING
BILLS THAT WERE DOING SENATE
AMENDMENTS. GIVE ACCESS TO
CERTAIN OF THESE JUVENILE
RECORDS TO PROSECUTING
ATTORNEYS SO THAT THEY CAN MEET
THEIR BRADY OBLIGATIONS WITH
THAT IS RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE. VOTE IN CONCURRENCE OF
SENATE AMENDMENTS. HOME THANK
YOU MR STERN C. AND HEARING
FURTHER TO ON THE MATTER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED EITHER TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTER
EYES FORTY FIVE NOTES ELEVEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM ONE OH SEVEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME REAL
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE VICE
ADMIRAL DAHLE ANOTHER RECYCLING
THE PUBLIC WORKS I DON'T KNOW
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MINISTRY
GRAVY TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE
DEFINES PUBLIC WORKS TO INCLUDE
CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY.
PROJECTS THAT RECEIVE FUNDING
THROUGH CONDUIT REVENUE BONDS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS PROVIDE AN
EXEMPTION FOR SMALLER CHARTER
SCHOOLS. AND WE MUST ENSURE
THAT THOSE WORKING ON OUR
SCHOOL FACILITIES ARE SKILLED
AND TRAINED. AND QUALIFIED AND
RECIEVE PREVAILING WAGES THIS
BILL SPONSORED BY THE STATE
BILLION AND TRADES AND
CONSTRUCTION COUNCIL
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED AMERICA. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. OUR MEMBERS VOTED VERY
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY
KNOWS NINE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MOVING THE
FILE ITEM ONE AWAIT AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY TWO THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WEBER ANOTHER RESPECTFULLY INTO
EMPLOYMENT. CALIFORNIA DOCTOR
ARE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR CHAMBER YES MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS ARE AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY TWO IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE. THERE
WERE MINOR AND TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS MADE TO THE BILL IT
IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
DR WEBER SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS GO
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING
THAT I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED AND WE
TO FILE ITEM ONE OR NINE AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY GOAL THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER ANOTHER RECYCLING
THE STATE GOVERNMENT ACTOR EVER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RISING. AND
FORK ON CONCURRENCE OF AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE WHICH IS
A TASK FORCE TO STUDY DEVELOP
REPARATION PROPOSALS FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS THAT SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING AND I RESPECTFULLY
AND WAS A- PASSED OUT OF THE
SENATE WHAT A BIPARTISAN VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BILL
FOR AB. TWENTY THIRTY ONE TO
ONE. THANK YOU DR WEBER SEEING
NO FURTHER ON THE CLERK WILL
THE ROLE. REMEMBER VOTED
AMERICA. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. OUR MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THAT FIVE FIFTY JUNE KNOWS NINE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED
IS A CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER- MEMBERS IF YOU HAD A
BILL THAT WAS PASSED RECENTLY
BY THE SENATE. IT'S COMING OVER
SO PLEASE TALK YOUR STAFF TO
GET TALKING POINTS HE BE
PREPARED TO TAKE UP THE BILL
TONIGHT. OKAY THANK YOU. MR
GALLAGHER FOR WHAT PURPOSE TO
RISE.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN AB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY RULE ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GALLAGHER AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO BUSINESS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL GRANT NOTICE
OF RECONSIDERATION TO FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTEEN AB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT. MISTER GALLERY MAY OPEN
OKAY. MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
IS UP AGAIN FOR CONCURRENCE
WITH SENATE AMENDMENTS- THIS
BILL. IS DESIGNED TO PROTECT
AGAINST THE THIS THE CYBER
BULLYING AND ABUSE THAT WE HAVE
SEEN OF OUR YOUTH- ON SOCIAL
MEDIA- AGAIN THIS IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE IT- THERE IS NO
FORMAL OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
IT HAS HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
HAVE HEARD THE CONCERNS FROM
THE LGBT CAUCUS AND WE CONTINUE
TO WORK TOGETHER IN ADDRESSING
THE ISSUE OF CONCERN IN. REGARD
TO LGBTQ YOUTH- AND THEIR
ACCESS TO RESOURCES GOING
FORWARD SO I WITHOUT ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
GALLAGHER. SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THERE TO VOTE. HOME
RESULT WHO DESERVE IT. RIGHT.
PAUL MEMBERS THIRTY TO THEIR TO
VOTE. MORE. WELL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS
FORTY FOUR KNOWS THREE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN.
MEMBERS I AM REFERRING THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO AB
SIXTY NINETEEN TO THE HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE AB FOUR THIRTY FOUR
DAY LEAD TO THE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE. AB SIXTY FIVE
RAPISTS OF THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR MAIENSCHEIN TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE AB ELEVEN
NINETY SIX GIVEN THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE AB FIFTEEN OH
SIX MCCARTY TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONE CRISTINA GARCIA TO
THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN EDUARDO
GARCIA TO THE UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE AND AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE
BOERNER HORVATH TO THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO
TWO EIGHT. THE FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO MEET
HEALTH COMMITTEE HERE AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR MAIN SHINE IN AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
PETRIE-NORRIS ON MONDAY AUGUST
THIRTY FIRST AT NINE AM. IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- TO LABOR
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE TO HEAR A.
B. SIX EIGHTY FIVE REYES ON
MONDAY AUGUST THIRTY FIRST AT
EIGHT THIRTY AM. AND ROOM FOR
THIRTY SEVEN. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE WILL BE ENTERTAINING
ROAD CHANGES AT THIS TIME MISS
GONZALES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR CHAMBER FOR A VOTE
CHANGES THANK YOU SB FIVE
NINETY TWO WIENER FROM NO TO
HIGH. BURKE CHANGES GONZALEZ
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY TWO NO
TO A HIGH. ANY OTHER MEMBERS
SEEK RECOGNITION. MR FONG YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
CHAMBER- FONG AB SEVEN THIRTY
TWO I DID NOT MONNING. FONG
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN THIRTY TWO
I TO NOT VOTING. THIS IS
CARRIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR CHAMBER. SB FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE ACCIDENTAL NOTE TO MY-
CARRILLO SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE NO T<c.cyan>. MISTER</c>
O'DONNELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
RELIGION FOR- DAHLE FILE ITEM
FOUR AB- FIFTEEN OR TWENTY
FIVE- FROM I TO THE NETWORK.
O'DONNELL ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
TWENTY FIVE I TO NOT VOTING.
SCHOLAR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AS
WE DO EIGHTY EIGHT NOTE NOT
VOTING. THIS CONNOR CAN YOU
REPEAT THAT PLEASE FOR THE
CLERK SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT. NO
I'M NOT VOTING. FOR HIM LONGER
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY EIGHT NO
TO NOT VOTING. SURE JANUARY
SECOND AYE SKINNER CHAMBER
THANK YOU VENTURE. A MINUTE
LATER SB NINE FOURTEEN FROM
NOTED NOT VOTING. CHEN SENATE
BILL NINE FOURTEEN NO TO NOT
VOTING. ANY OTHER MEMBERS SEEK
RECOGNITION PROVIDE CHANGES
THIS TIME.
MR LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YEAH I'D LIKE TO
HAVE A VOTE CHANGE FOR A. B.
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE FROM NO
TO OBTAIN. PRO CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY IN SOME OF ALL
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE THOUGH TO
NOT VOTING.
MISTER BERNIE
RECOGNIZED. FOR VOTE CHANGE
THANK YOU. AB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT I TO KNOW. WILL CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT I TO
KNOW. BAKER BERMAN. MEMBERS OF
THEIR OTHER VOTE CHANGES-
PLEASE GOING TO THE BACK OF A
CHAMBER BE HAPPY TO TAKE THOSE
AT THIS TIME.
OKAY MISTER
CALDERON YOU RECOGNIZE ME DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AFTER
MEMBERS THAT ARE IN THEIR
OFFICES- WE DID A BATCH. OF
ABOUT FORTY SOME BILLS. IF YOU
ARE NOT HERE ON THE FLOOR WHEN
WE DID THAT VOTE YOU CAN ADD ON
WHILE WE'RE STILL HERE TO JUST
ONE BILL WHICH IS A MAYES BILL.
IF YOU IF WE SHUT DOWN AND YOU
DIDN'T ADD ON TO THAT BILL
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO ADD ON TO
EVERY VOTE INDIVIDUALLY. SO I
JUST WANT TO RECOMMEND TO ALL
THE MEMBERS IN OUR OFFICES TO
CALM DOWN BEFORE WE ADJOURN.
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY OUT
ON TO THOSE BILLS THAT COULD BE
ONE ACTION RATHER THAN FORTY
PLUS DIFFERENT ACTIONS. THANK
YOU. THAT KIND OF GIVES
MAJORITY. THANK YOU.
NUMBER
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING. TO TAKE
NOTE. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SOME OF OUR ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. SO IF YOU COULD PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR AT
THIS TIME WE ARE NOT LIFTING
THE CALL WE'RE JUST TAKING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO DO ARE GERMANS
IN MEMORY. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS ARE GRANTED PERMISSION
TO SPEAK ON IN GERMANY MEMORY.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF DOLORES
VELASCO WHO PASSED AWAY ON
WEDNESDAY AUGUST FIFTH. AT THE
AGE OF EIGHTY FIVE THE LAWRENCE
COMMITTED HER LIFE TO THE
SERVICE OF OTHERS AND WAS A
TRAILBLAZER OF THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS OF AMERICA MOVEMENT.
SHE SPENT DECADES DOCUMENTING
THE LIVES OF THE FILIPINO
MONOLOGUES AND THE MEMORIES OF
HER BELOVED HUSBAND UFW LEADER.
PETE VELASCO. GLORIOUS AND
NEUBAUER KNOWN FONDLY AS DOLLY
BY HER FRIENDS WAS BORN IN
BALTIMORE MARYLAND. IN NINETEEN
THIRTY FOUR AND TAUGHT FIRST
GRADE AT A CONVENT BEFORE
MEETING. HER HUSBAND THE
RENOWNED IN STORY UFW LEADER
PEOPLE OSCO. ADMIRING THEIR%
DEEP LOVE FOR EACH OTHER SAYS
ARE CHAVEZ WOULD OFTEN JOKE OF
HIS NEXT DOOR NEIGHBOR SAYING
PEOPLE LASKO WAS A GREAT
ORGANIZER BECAUSE HE ORGANIZED
A NUN TO BECOME. HIS WIFE.
INDEED THE LARA SHARED THAT
SAME LOVE AND DEVOTION THAT SHE
HAD FOR HER HUSBAND WITH HER
COMMUNITY. AND ACTIVE SUPPORTER
OF THE U. F. W. IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE DELANO GRAPE STRIKE.
DOLLARS TO BRING FOOD MONEY AND
CLOTHING TO THE BOYCOTTERS
EVERY WEEK. LATER SHE WOULD
CHRONILE THE MONOLOGUES
CONTRIBUTIONS AND REGULARLY
SHARED HISTORICAL ITEMS AND
DOCUMENTS DURING TOURS OF I'VE
BY ANY VILLAGE. AND WITH
VISITING STUDENTS RESEARCHERS
AND FILMMAKERS. AT THE NATIONAL
CHAVEZ CENTER IN LA PAZ. AS A
FAITH LEADER DOOR SCHOOL
GENERATIONS OF CHILDREN IN AND
OUT. SIDE IN AND OUTSIDE OF A
PASSED THROUGH THE CATHOLIC
CATECHISM. PREPARING THEM FOR
FIRST COMMUNION CONFIRMATION.
THROUGH HER LIFE OF ACTIVISM
DIVORCES FAITH NEVER FALTERED
AND HER VIBRANT VISION OF
COMMUNITY NEVER RECEDED. SHE IS
REMEMBERED AS A CARING FUNNY
THOUGHTFUL LEADER WHO ALWAYS
SENT A BIRTHDAY CARD. AND WHO
NEVER MISSED A CHANCE TO
EXPRESS LOVE. AND KINDNESS
MEMBERS BEACON MEMBERS I ASK
THAT WE. ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
THE LOSS OF VASCO. THANK YOU
BONTA. THIS ROUND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR THE GERMAN
OF MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IN COLLEGE ONCE AGAIN I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A
MODEL HI- CANNOM RODRIGUEZ. HE
WAS A RESIDENT OF OAKLAND HE
DIED ON AUGUST FOURTH IN
MINDORO PHILIPPINES AT THE
YOUNG AGE OF TWENTY TWO. I'M
NOT A PASSED AWAY WHILE LIVING
AND WORKING IN THE PHILIPPINES
WHERE HE MOVED TWO YEARS AGO TO
LIVE OUT HIS COMMITMENT TO
SOCIAL JUSTICE. HE WORKED IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE MOST
MARGINALIZED FILIPINO PEOPLE
WHO LIVE WITH FARMERS AND
MAGGIE ON INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES IN THE MINDORO
ISLAND AND FIGHT IN SUCH
SOLIDARITY WITH THEM FOR THEIR
LANDS. AND FOR THEIR
LIVELIHOODS WELL IN OAKLAND HE
WAS A LEADER IN OUR COMMUNITY
ACCOMPLISHING SO MUCH AS A
STUDENT AT LANEY COLLEGE HE
FOUGHT AGAINST GENTRIFICATION
AND FOR ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND BEFORE MOVING TO
THE PHILIPPINES HE WAS ACTIVE
IN THE MOVEMENT FOR BLACK LIVES
AS A BIRACIAL BIRACIAL BLACK
YOUNG MAN HIS LEADERSHIP AND
COMMITMENT TO SOCIAL JUSTICE
SHINED. IN HIS ADVOCACY FOR HIS
PEOPLE AMATO'S LIFE WAS SHORT
LIVED BUT IT WAS A LIFE WELL
LIVED FILLED WITH PURPOSE
SERVICE ACTIVISM AND LOVE.
MODEL'S LIFE IS A TRUE EXAMPLE
OF HOW ONE CAN LIVE THEIR LIFE
IN SERVICE TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIVES OF OTHERS MY
HEART GOES OUT TO DR ROBIN
RODRIGUEZ. AMATO'S MOTHER WHO
IS AN ESTEEMED PROFESSOR AND
ACTIVIST. WHO'S CLEARLY
INFLUENCE THE MODELS PASSION
AND HIS LOVE FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE
AMAG HEART GOES OUT TO ALL
THOSE LOVED ONES AND TO EACH
HEART THAT HE TOUCHED I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURNMENT ME OF A
MODEL HI- CANAM. RODRIGUEZ MR
BONTA YOUR RECOGNIZED THIRTY
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE TO
JENNA MEMORY OF DR BURKE LUBIN
WHO PASSED AWAY ON JUNE TWENTY
SEVENTH AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
ONE HE WAS A PIONEER IN
CHILDREN'S MEDICINE AND LEFT A
LASTING LGACY IN OAKLAND AND
THE ENTIRE BAY AREA AND FAR
BEYOND HE'S BORN IN THE BRONX
NEW YORK IN NINETEEN THIRTY
NINE AND GREW UP IN BELLEVUE
PENNSYLVANIA OUTSIDE OF
PITTSBURGH THE SON OF A GROCER
HE LEARNED. LIFE LESSONS ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF HARD WORK WE
NEED TO TREAT EVERYONE WITH
RESPECT AND THE VALUE OF
HELPING THOSE IN NEED HE WAS
ALSO AN EXCELLENT DRUMMER AND
JAZZ ENTHUSIAST HE WON SEVERAL
STATE HONORS AND EVEN PERFORMED
WITH THE RENOWNED JAZZ ARTIST
THE LONEY S. MONK. DUCK LIVING
JOINED OPEN AT CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE AS THE CHIEF OF
HEPATOLOGY ONCOLOGY BE SOON
LAUNCHED A RESEARCH PROGRAM
THAT BECAME CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
OPEN RESEARCH INSTITUTE AS A
SCIENTIST HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL
IN NUMEROUS BREAKTHROUGHS
PARTICULARLY IN BLOOD DISEASES
THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
MOST NOTABLY SICKLE CELL
DISEASE. HIS ADVOCACY FOR
CONDUCTING SICKLE CELL
SCREENING AT BIRTH LED TO
CALIFORNIA REQUIRING SUCH
SCREENING ROUTINELY FOR ALL
NEWBORNS IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
HEWAS CHOSEN TO BE PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
OAKLAND BECOMING THE FIRST
PEDIATRICIAN TO SERVE AS THE
CEO OF A CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN
CALIFORNIA. HE WAS A CARING
PERSON WITH AN UNCEASING
PASSION FOR CHILDREN AND HIS
COMMUNITY HE EXPIRED MANY
PHYSICIANS WHO WE MENTOR DURING
HIS TIME WITH CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL OAKLAND AND HE
INSPIRED ME WITH HIS DEVOTION
TO CHILDREN IS IMMEASURABLE
WARMTH AND KINDNESS AND JUST
HIS BEAUTY AS A PERSON HIS
LEGACY PARTICULARLY IN THE EAST
BAY. AND A SERVICE THE CHILDREN
IN THE COMMUNITY WILL FOREVER
BE REMEMBERED I ASKED WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF DR BURKE
LUPIN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER BONTA. MITHRAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS TO THEIR RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MY BELOVED
UNCLE OIL GOMEZ. THE DEATHS
CAUSED BY COPD NINETEEN ARE SO
MUCH MORE THAN DAILY STATISTICS
BUT DON'T FULLY CAPTURE THE
EMOTION AND PAIN OR THE TRAGEDY
BEHIND EACH STEP. BECAUSE
BEHIND EACH DEATH AND ILLNESS
IS A LIFE STORY A FAMILY AND
THE LEGACY. IT IS MORE THAN A
PANDEMIC YES IT'S PERSONAL. TWO
AND A HALF WEEKS AFTER BEING
DIAGNOSED WITH COPD NINETEEN MY
UNCLE DEHLORAN SUCCUMBED TO THE
DISEASE THAT HAS CLAIMED THE
LIVES OF MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS. HOSPITALIZED
THOUSANDS MORE SHUT DOWN
BUSINESSES CHURCHES AND SCHOOLS
AND KEPT US AWAY FROM FRIENDS
COLLEAGUES AND LOVED ONES. WELL
OUR GOMEZ WAS BORN ON JULY
THIRTEENTH NINETEEN FORTY TWO
AND HOW DOES THE PEOPLE ON HOW
THE SCHOOL MAY HE GO. THE
SEVENTH OF EIGHT CHILDREN. MY
DAD I'D SAY THIS WAS THE FIRST
BORN. THEIR FATHER DIED WHEN
OIL WAS JUST EIGHT YEARS OLD
AND EVENTUALLY HIS MOTHER MY
GRANDMOTHER. MOVED TO THE U. S.
AND SETTLED IN SAN BERNARDINO.
GROWING UP IN SAMPOERNA DINO HE
WORKED HARD TO GET HIS PIECE OF
THE AMERICAN DREAM. AND
EVENTUALLY PURCHASED A PLYMOUTH
HEARING. I WAS HIS PRIDE AND
JOY THROUGHOUT HIS EARLY YEARS.
AND THAT HE ONLY ENTRUSTED WITH
MY FATHER TO WATCH FOR HIM
WHILE HE WAS AWAY SERVING IN
VIETNAM. WHEN HE WAS IN HIS
EARLY TWENTIES HIS FRIENDS WERE
DRAFTED DURING THE VIETNAM WAR.
AND THIS PIC TO SENSE OF DUTY.
WHICH CALLED HIM TO ENLIST IN
THE U. S. ARMY. IN LATE A YEAR
LATER YEARS WHEN HE WAS UNABLE
TO REMEMBER MANY THINGS ABOUT
HIS LIFE. BECAUSE OF DEMENTIA.
HE WOULD ALWAYS SHARE DETAILED
MEMORIES FROM HIS TIME IN THE
ARMY SERVING HIS COUNTRY.
NEARLY FIFTY YEARS AFTER HIS
SERVICE TO HIS COUNTRY. HE
INFORMED US THAT HE WANTED TO
BECOME A US CITIZEN. WE HAD
ALWAYS ASSUMED HE WAS A U. S.
CITIZEN NOT KNOWING HE HAD
SERVED IN THE U. S. ARMY AS A
PERMANENT LEGAL RESIDENT. IT
WAS MY FIRST ELECTION CAMPAIGN
FOR ASSEMBLY THAT INSPIRED HIM
TO BEGIN THE PROCESS TO BECOME
A US CITIZEN. BECAUSE HE
INTENDED TO VOTE FOR ME IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. ON MAY
EIGHTEENTH. TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN HE WAS SWORN IN AS A U.
S. CITIZEN. AND AFTERWARD VOTED
IN THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
ELECTION SENDING ME HIS NIECE
TO SACRAMENTO ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THE AWARD WAS A HARD WORKER AND
SPENT LOTS OF TIME WITH FAMILY
ESPECIALLY SIBLINGS AND
COUSINS. HE ALSO HAD MANY
FRIENDS AND WAS OFTEN THE LIFE
OF THE PARTY. IT WAS A
JOKESTER. HE COULD DISH IT OUT
AND RECEIVE IT. HE ENJOYED
PEOPLE'S COMPANY. HE LOVED TO
SING AND REMEMBER THE WORDS OF
TOO MANY SONGS EVEN DURING HIS
FORGET FOR YEARS. ELEVEN
MARIACHI MUSIC. IT WASN'T A
GREAT DANCER BUT I LOVE TO GET
ON THE DANCE FLOOR HE WAS PROUD
OF ALL OF US HE LOVED US. HE
LOVED LIFE. AND NOW HE HAS BEEN
TAKEN AWAY BY COVERT NINETEEN.
EVERYONE OF THE THOUSANDS WHOSE
LIFE HAS BEEN PLAYING BY COVERT
NINETEEN HAS A STORY. WAS LOVED
BY FAMILY AND FRIENDS HAD
DREAMS AND ASPIRATIONS. JUST
LIKE MIGHT BE A HORN. SO YES
WHEN I ASKED THAT WE WERE MASKS
IN PUBLIC THAT WE MAINTAIN OUR
SOCIAL DISTANCE. THAT WE WASH
OUR HANDS THAT WE WORK TOGETHER
TO FLATTEN THE CURVE THAT WE
LOOK OUT FOR ONE ANOTHER YES
IT'S PERSONAL. MY UNCLE LEAVES
BEHIND HIS SISTER. SORT OF ONCE
YOU KNOW GOMEZ OF WHAT A LOT
HOW TO HELP YOU SCHOOL IN
MEXICO. AND HIS BROTHER ARTHUR
GOMES OF COLTON. HE ALSO LEAVES
BEHIND HIS FAVORITE SISTER IN
LAW WHO CARED FOR HIS WELL
BEING TO THE END OF MY MOTHER.
JESSE GOMEZ. OR IS THAT ALMOST
LIKE YOU GOT THROUGH THAT THE
LIST ALTHOUGH THE CALIFORNIA IN
ORDER THEM TO GET IT GET IT OFF
THE- OLD KOREAN. CAN FOR YOU
SEE ALL THIS WAS IN COURT BUT
THE IMPORTANT GOAL READ. ME
DEAL FOR US ALL THE OTHER THAN
THE KIDS TO GO TO THOUGHTLESSLY
NEEDLES. YET ANOTHER SIGN UP
ANALYTICAL SAMPLE. THEY LEVY
THEM. LEVINE A SPITTING OUT OF
THIS YOUNG MAN THIS FOR MY THEM.
SO ONCE YOU'RE NOT GOING AYE
WELL. A HIGHLY SCHOOL. YOU SORT
OF. ON WILL GOING THE CAUSE ON.
PLEASE ME IN A JOURNEY IN THE
MAIL OF MY BILL. THE OPRAH.
GOMEZ THANK MR S. R.
CONDOLENCES ARE WITH YOU YOUR
ANTI FAMILY LOSS OF YOUR UNCLE
WELL AS THE FAMILY MEMBERS OF
EVERYONE WHO'S LOST THEIR LIVES
TO THIS VIRUS. MISS GONZALES
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF IRENE MENA I REMAINS
BORN IN LOGAN HEIGHTS ON JUNE
THE THIRD NINETEEN TWENTY NINE
AND LIVED HER ENTIRE LIFE IN MY
DISTRICT ATTENDING BURBANK
ELEMENTARY LOGAN ELEMENTARY
MEMORIAL JUNIOR HIGH IN SAN
DIEGO HIGH SCHOOL. BY NINETEEN
FORTY NINE I RING GOT HER FIRST
JOB AT CONVAIR IRCRAFT AND
WORKED AS A CUTTER FOR AIRPLANE
PARTS. BY NINETEEN SIXTY NINE
THE CHICANO MOVEMENT WAS IN%
FULL SWING AND I RE DID NOT
HESITATE TO DO HER PART FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND ENGAGE IN
MULTIPLE EVENTS THAT CEMENTED
SANDY GOES HISTORY WITHIN THE
CHICANO MOVEMENT. ON APRIL
TWENTY SECOND NINETEEN SEVENTY
EVERY MAN I WAS PRESENT DURING
THE TWELVE DAY OCCUPATION OF
CHICANO PARK. BECAME OF THE
FOUNDING MEMBERS OF THE CHICANO
PARK STEERING COMMITTEE. LATER
THAT YEAR SHE ALSO PLAYED AN
INSTRUMENTAL ROLE IN THE
TAKEOVER OF THE BIG NEIGHBOR.
WHICH LED TO THE CREATION THE
CHICANO FREE CLINIC. NOW KNOWN
AS LOGAN HEIGHTS FAMILY HEALTH
CENTER. I RAN ALSO HELPED
OCCUPY THE FORD BUILDING IN
BALBOA PARK WHICH LED TO THE
CITY GIVING AN ABANDONED WATER
TANK TO THE CHICANA COMMUNITY.
TO CREATE A CULTURAL ARTS SPACE
KNOWN AS THE CENTER COLLUDED
WHILE PHILADELPHIA. THROUGHOUT
THAT TIME IRENE WAS A DEDICATED
MEMBER THE SAN DIEGO BROWN
BRACE WHICH LATER BECAME KNOWN
AS THE NATIONAL BROWN BRAZEN
HAS LINE. SHE WAS ONE OF THE
LONGEST SERVING MEMBERS WHICH
EARNED HER THE TITLE OF
HONORARY GRANDMOTHER OF THE
BROWN BERETS. THE CHAIRMEN GAVE
HER THIS TITLE ISSUE WOULD HELP
IRON UNIFORMS INCLUDING SHOT
GUNS. I READ ALSO BENEFITED
HEARD THE LEFT COMMUNITY IS A
BILINGUAL TEACHER'S AIDE A
CAMBER SIR FOR SEIU. AND AID TO
SENIORS FOR THE CHICANO
FEDERATION AND EVEN WORKING ON
THE CAMPAIGN FOR PETER CHECK ON
FOR CITY COUNCIL WHO LATER
BECAME THE FIRST LATINO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OUT OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY SERVING IN MY
SEAT. THAT I HOLD TODAY. SHE
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF
NINETY ONE AND IS SURVIVED BY
TEN CHILDREN. THIRTY THREE
GRANDCHILDRENSIXTY EIGHT GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND NINETEEN
GREAT GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. AS I
CLOSE I'D LIKE TO LEAVE YOU ALL
WITH A QUOTE FROM IRENE HERSELF.
NOTHING WAS EVER GIVEN TO US WE
HAD TO FIGHT FOR IT IT WAS NO
ONE PERSON WHO DID IT. IT WAS A
COLLECTIVE OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT EQUAL RIGHTS WE
HAD TO ORGANIZE AND GO TO
MEETING AFTER MEETING AFTER
MEETING TO BE HEARD. WE MARCH
PROTEST AND WROTE LETTERS FOR
THEM TO LISTEN TO OUR DEMANDS
FOR HEALTH EDUCATION AND
COMMUNITY CENTERS. I REMAIN
OPTIMISM SAID PLEASE JOIN ME IN
A JOURNEY IN HER SWEET MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALES. MISTER
JONES SAWYER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
MEMBERS TODAY ARE ROGER JOHN IN
THE MEMORY OF MY GOOD FRIEND MR
LESS ROBERSON. LESLIE LAST TO
ROME ROBERSON WAS BORN ON JUNE
SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE IN LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
TO LESLIE AND RUBEN RUBY TEAM
ROBERSON LESS IS A LOT MARK WAS
A LONG TIME ANGELINO. LET'S
ATTENDED PALISADES HIGH SCHOOL
AND GRADUATED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE. HE WAS AN AVID
BASEBALL PLAYER HE LATER EARNED
HIS DEGREE IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION FROM CSU
NORTHRIDGE AND UNIVERSITY OF
PHOENIX. LESS DEDICATED HIS
LIFE TO BEING A LOVING FONG.
AND AMAZING SUN AND SERVING THE
COMMUNITY THROUGH HIS WORKS IN
POLITICS LESS WAS ALWAYS THE
LIFE OF ANY OCCASION HE WAS A
WELCOMING AND JOYOUS SPIRIT TO
EVERYONE HE MET. LOOK LESS WAS
MOST FULFILLED THROUGH HIS WORK
IN POLITICS HE SERVED AS A
SENATE FEEL REPRESENTATIVE FOR
THEN STATE SENATOR THERESA USE
AS WELL AS BEING A WORKSOURCE
DISABILITIES COORDINATOR. LESS
WITHIN ADVOCATE FOR VOTING AND
ASSISTED. ON ISSUES WITHIN HIS
COMMUNITY. LESS A SEPARATE
CRISIS EARLY AGING WITH A
DEVOUT CHRISTIAN AND FAITHFULLY
ATTENDED SUNDAY SERVICES AT
WEST ANGELES CHURCH AND
OCCASIONALLY A GREATER NEW
VISION WITH MOTHER RUBY. HE
SPENT HIS TIME IS FREE TIME
ATTENDING USC FOOTBALL GAMES
WITH ME. DODGER GAMES AND JAZZ
FESTIVALS HE ALSO ENJOYED
BARBECUING AND BOXING AND
IDOLIZED MUHAMMAD ALI. LET'S
ALSO RAN FOR OFFICE HE RAN FOR
ASSEMBLY TO FORTY SEVEN EIGHTY
WHICH IS NOW THE FIFTY FOURTH
A. D. N. ON ONE OF HIS SLOGANS
LESS FOR. LESS TALK MORE ACTION.
LET'S PASSED AWAY ON MAY
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY AT
OLYMPIA OLYMPIA MEDICAL CENTER
LOS IS SURVIVED BY HIS DAUGHTER
RYAN MOTHER RUBY SISTER LISA
NEPHEWS DIALING. AND SHANE THE
LOVE OF HIS LIFE COMMITTEE
ALONG WITH OF HIS FRIENDS AND
FAMILY THE WORLD LOST A GREAT
MAN AND I HUMBLY THANK YOU FOR
JOINING. FROM FOR JOINING ME IN
A JOURNEY TODAY IN MEMORY OF
LESS FOR A PERSON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JOHN FIRE THE
CERVANTES. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO ASK THE ASSEMBLY
TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
CORPORAL SUSS OUT OF FRODO. BE
UNORTHODOX OF RIVERSIDE AND
PRIVATE FIRST CLASS BRIAN ONE
CARLOS BOTH THE IRAQ OF CORONA.
BOTH YOUNG MEN WERE ASSIGNED TO
THE FIFTEENTH MARINE
EXPEDITIONARY UNIT OUT OF CAMP
PENDLETON. MORE AMONG THE NINE
SERVICE MEMBERS KILLED WHEN AN
AMPHIBIOUS ASSAULT VEHICLE SANK
OFF THE COAST OF SAN CLEMENTE.
DURING A ROUTINE TRAINING
EXERCISE ON JULY THIRTIETH. AT
JUST TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD
CORPORE BE ON ONE OF OUR HAVE
BEEN SERVING IN THE U. S.
MARINE CORPS FOR FOUR YEARS. HE
WAS A NEWLYWED LOOKING FORWARD
TO STARTING A FAMILY OF HIS OWN.
CECIL'S MOTHER MIGHT BE ON HIS
WIFE SARAH AND HIS FRIENDS
RECALL HIM AS SOMEONE WHO WAS
KIND OUTGOING EXEMPLIFIED THE
MEANING OF HARD WORK. ALWAYS
TRY TO DO THE RIGHT THING AN
OVERALL A GREAT MAN WITH A
BEAUTIFUL SOUL. PRIVATE FIRST
CLASS BUT THE ITEM. WAS ONLY
EIGHTEEN AND HAD JUST MARKED
HIS ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF
BEING SWORN INTO THE MARINE
CORPS THE DAY BEFORE HIS DEATH.
HE WAS FUN LEVINE ENJOYED
PAINTBALL AND GOING TO CONCERTS
AND FOUND GREAT JOY IN THE
CAMARADERIE AND THE MARINES. IN
THE BOND HE FORMED WITH HIS
BROTHERS. RIGHT MOTHER- RECALLS
HIM AS A WONDERFUL MAN. WHO
RADIATED POSITIVITY AND
EXPRESSES WONDERFUL SMILE TO
ALL HE MET. BOTH CORPORATE BE
UNAWARE GOT AND PRIVATE FIRST
CLASS BUT YOU GOTTA FOUR SONS
BROTHERS FRIENDS AND PROUD
MARINES WHO EXHIBITED
TREMENDOUS BRAVERY AND WE'RE
EAGER TO SERVE OUR COUNTRY. ALL
OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND IN
PARTICULAR CITIES OF CORONA AND
RIVERSIDE. ARE IN DEEP MOURNING
OVER THEIR PASSING COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE DURING
IN THE MEMORY OF CORPUS I
THOUGHT OF FRODO. AND WEBER AND
PRIVATE FIRST CLASS BRIAN FUNG
CARLOS BUT DHEA FOR TAKEN FROM
US FAR TOO EARLY. THANK YOU
RESTAURANTEURS. MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DEATH
THREE PRINT IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUESTS FOR JOURNEY MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
YOU HAVE. TO
LITERACY AGAIN MY NAME THE BILL
YEAH. RIGHT I SEE MY NAME YEAH.
ARE YOU READY FOR NOW. MARC
LEVINE EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
I TO KNOW. THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ASSEMBLY SEVENTY FIVE I
TO KNOW.
WE WERE KINDLY TELL
YOU. BECAUSE MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING BACK. ON THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILES OR
CONCURRENCE ITEMS. WE WILL
START WITH FILE ITEM THREE OH
ONE AB ELEVEN FORTY THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME REAL LEVIN
FORTY BY SOME MEMBER MARK STONE
OTHERS LEYVA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT. IT'S JUST ON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
WAS SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED IN
THE SENATE BECAUSE WE NEED TO
SOLVE A PROBLEM FOR TO LOCAL
FIRE DISTRICTS IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY THAT WERE TRYING TO
CONSOLIDATE IN THE TRYING TO
CONSOLIDATE FOR EFFICIENT.
PROVISION OF FIRE SERVICE AND
FOR THE FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT OF
THE DISTRICTS. THE EMPLOYEES
MANAGEMENT THE BOARD ALL CAME
TO AGREEMENT ON HOW THIS WOULD
HAPPEN BUT WE HAD A PROBLEM
WITH HERS BECAUSE THEY WERE TWO
DIFFERENT AGENCIES THAT HAD
NEGOTIATED. BENEFITS A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENTLY RETIREMENT
BENEFITS THROUGH PERSONAL
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY. AND
PURSE CANNOT WRITE A CONTRACT
WITH THOSE DIFFERENCES IN IT
WITHOUT THE LEGISLATURE
STEPPING IN. WE WENT TO PERS
AND CAME UP WITH THIS BILL AS
A- CREATIVE SOLUTION TO ALLOW
THAT THE CONSOLIDATION TO MOVE
FORWARD. MEANTIME ITS AUTHORITY
FOR PERSON WHEN THEY DO OFFER
THAT CONTRACT TO THIS
CONSOLIDATED DISTRICT TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
FIREFIGHTERS GET THE BENEFIT OF
THE BARGAIN THAT THEY HAD. BEEN
NEGOTIATING ALL ALONG IN THEIR
TWO SEPARATE AGENCIES SO THIS
IS A TECHNICAL FIX IT'S VERY
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THESE TWO
AGENCIES FROM A DEFICIENCY
STANDPOINT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. YOU MISTER
STAND SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED EITHER. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED THERE TO VOTE.
PAUL MEMBERS WHO THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. MARK THE. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE OLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS FORTY FIVE NEW ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED
IN.
FILE ITEM THREE TWO AB
TWENTY ONE OH ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE OH ONE BY THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
MAKING APPROPRIATION- FOR. THIS
ORDER IF YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARE PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE OH
ONE WHICH IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE CONCURRENCE. SENTIMENTS
COMBINE THREE SEPARATE
TECHNICAL CREAM TO BILLS THAT
WERE INTRODUCED FOR CALPERS
COASTERS IN THE NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN ACT COUNTY RETIREMENT
SYSTEMS. INTO THIS ONE SINGLE
COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL ARE
STRICTLY OFF PRIVATE. THANK YOU
MR- RODRIGUEZ. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
THIRD OF IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE FIVE FIFTY FOUR NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MEMBERS THE SENATE
HAS TRANSMITTED THESE ASSEMBLY
BILL THAT ARE LISTED IN THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE ONE THEIR
ITEMS THREE OH ONE THREE THREE
FORTY SIX. SEVEN OF FILES
POSTED ON THE FAMILY'S WEBSITE
AND HAS BEEN EMAILED TO
ASSEMBLY OFFICES THE MEASURES
AND ANALYSES ARE ON YOUR TABLET.
WE WILL NOW GO BACK TO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE WITH NUMBER
THREE OH THREE AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
SIXTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OLD ON ONE OTHER SNORKELING THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT MR
O'DONNELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AS
AMENDED AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
SEVEN CLARIFIES THAT A LOT OF
PUBLIC AGENCY MAY NOT AMEND.
ITS CONTRACT WITH CALPERS
RECYCLING GROUPS OF EMPLOYEES
THAT WERE. PREVIOUSLY INCLUDED.
CIVIL SERVANTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA CONTRIBUTE. A
PORTION OF THEIR EARNINGS TO
THEIR CALPERS PENSIONS.
TRUSTING THAT THIS INVESTMENT
WILL PROVIDE A- AB A SOLID
RETIREMENT FOR THEM USE
LIMITING ACCESS TO CALPERS-
RUNS CRITICAL PUBLIC SAFETY
WORKERS OF THE PENSION BENEFITS
AND FINANCIAL SECURITY THEY
DESERVE. AND COULD DESTABILIZE
THE RETIREMENT FUND FOR ALL
EMPLOYEES AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
SEVEN IS NARROWLY TAILORED BILL
TO ENSURE PUBLIC AGENCIES USE
THE CALPERS AMENDMENT PROCESS
AS INTENDED. NOT TO OUT AND NOT.
TO NOT TO CUT OUT SELECT A
GROUPS OF EMPLOYEES I ANSWER
AND I BOTH. THANK YOU MISTER
DONALD CLEAN HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
BOTH WHO DESERTED VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLUES VERRALL AND
TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY SIX
NO SIX SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONFERRED IN. FILE ITEM THREE
OH FOUR EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
SOMETHING ONLINE SEVENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
ANOTHER'S FACULTATIVE
CORPORATIONS. HOLDING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TONIGHT TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SEVENTY NINE. AB NINE SEVEN
NINE HAS BEEN A PART OF A
LARGER EFFORT TO ENSURE PEOPLE
OF COLOR. HAVE EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO UPWARD MOBILITY AND AMERICAN
SOCIETY. WHEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA SAID IN A WAY SO WHEN I
WHICH HERE'S THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
LATINO AND BLACK CAUCUS. WE
WORK TOGETHER TO ADDRESS RACIAL
AND GENDER DISPARITIES AT TECH
COMPANIES IN SILICON VALLEY.
THAT WAS IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. DESPITE OUR EFFORTS
AND DATA ILLUSTRATING THE LACK
OF DIVERSITY DATING BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. THE
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE OF COLOR
BEING HIRED AND PROMOTED HAS
NOT CHANGED. UNFORTUNATELY THIS
PROBLEM IS NOT UNIQUE TO TECH
COMPANIES. CORPORATIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HAVE CONDUCTED
REVIEWS OF THEIR WORKFORCE AN
INMATE PROMISES TO INCREASE
DIVERSITY. FOLLOWING THE
SUCCESS OF SB EIGHT TWENTY SIX
ASSEMBLY BRO NINE SEVENTY NINE
REQUIRE A MINIMUM OF ONE
DIRECTOR BERMAN UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITY ON ALL
BOARDS OF PUBLICLY TRADED
CORPORATIONS HEADQUARTERED IN
CALIFORNIA BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE BILL WILL ALSO
REQUIRE A MINIMUM OF TWO
DIRECTORS FROM UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES FOR BOARDS THAT
HAVE FIVE TO EIGHT DIRECTORS
AND A MINIMUM OF THREE
DIRECTORS FOR BOARDS WITH MORE
THAN NINE DIRECTORS BY THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WELL
CALIFORNIA PRIDES ITSELF ON
BEING AN ECONOMIC POWERHOUSE.
AND HAVING A MAJORITY MINORITY
POPULATION. CORPORATIONS DO NOT
REFLECT THE VAST CULTURAL
WEALTH OF THE STATE. FOR
EXAMPLE THE TOP TEN CALIFORNIA
BANKS ONLY 30% OF DIRECTORS ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THIS STATISTIC
PALES IN COMPARISON TO THE 67%
OF CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION
PEOPLE OF COLOR. ON AVERAGE
BLACK AND LATINO TECH EMPLOYEES
MAKE LESS THAN 10% OF WORKERS
AT PREMIER TECH COMPANIES. THIS
PERCENTAGE IS DISPROPORTIONATE
TO THE ROUGHLY 20% OF COMPUTER
SCIENCE GRADUATES THAT ARE
BLACK AND LATINO. THE FACE OF
THOSE THE CONTROL WEALTH AND
OUR STATE HAS NOT CHANGED EVEN
HOME REPORTS SHOW THAT
DIVERSITY ON CORPORATE BOARDS
BENEFITS THE CORPORATION. WE'RE
GOING TO ADDRESS THE RACIAL
INJUSTICE AND INEQUALITY IN OUR
SOCIETY. WE MUST BE INTENTIONAL.
PEOPLE OF COLOR MUST HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE WERE
OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF WEALTH
IS BASED. ESPECIALLY IN A STATE
AS DIVERSE AS CALIFORNIA.
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY NINE CENTS
A FRAMEWORK FOR CALIFORNIA TO
ENGAGE IN THIS CRITICAL AND
TIMELY ISSUE. THIS BILL IS THE
PRIMARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS.
LATINO CAUCUS API CAUCUS AND
LGBT CAUCUS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN MISS
GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR CHAMBER YES THANK YOU
OF THANK YOU MEMBERS I'M HERE
SURPRISED OR NOT THEIR BABY.
NINE SEVENTY NINE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION IS 39%
LATINO BUT 87% OF CALIFORNIAN
CORPORATE BOARDS DO NOT HAVE
LATINO REPRESENTATION. AB I
MAKE UP A COMBINED 60% OF THE
POPULATION YET ONLY THREE POINT
7% OF THE RECORDS OF FORTUNE
FIVE HUNDRED COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA. EVERYTHING USC
REYES AND EQUITY CENTERS STUDY
ALSO SHOWS THAT BLACKS TEND TO.
BE EMPLOYED IN THE LOWEST PAIN
AT LEAST POWERFUL POSITIONS WE
MUST AND WE CAN DO BETTER THAN
THAT. THERE IS ALSO SHOW THAT
RATIONS WITH MORE THEIR BIRTH
AND EQUITABLE BOARDS IMPROVE
COMPANY GOVERNANCE AND HAVE
BETTER DECISION MAKING. WHICH
LEADS TO A BETTER COMPANY OVER
ALL. THE ONE QUESTION WE HAVE
AN ANSWER IS WHY NOT WHY WE
CAN'T WAIT ANY LONGER OVER THE
LAST FEW MONTHS WE'VE SEEN
REACHED THE RACIAL RECKONING.
TRIGGERED BY THE KILLING OF
GEORGE FLOYD. THE PUBLIC
ENTITIES TO PROTEST THAT AND
DEMANDED THAT WE TEAR DOWN
RACIAL BIASES. IN ALL OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS. THE MESSAGE IS
CLEAR AND THE LEGISLATURE MUST
DO ALL THEY CAN TO PRIORITIZE
EQUALITY AND EQUITY NOW. WE CAN
NO LONGER WAIT TO ANSWER THE
CRIES FOR JUSTICE. FOR THOSE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MISTER DAVID CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AS THE CHAIR THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN THE JOINT
AUTHORS OF THIS BILL. I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. IN RECENT MONTHS
RACIAL DISPARITIES HAVE BEEN
ELIMINATED IN EVERY ASPECT OF
OUR COUNTRY. THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THAT LEADERSHIP ON
OUR CORPORATE BOARDS MUST BE
DIVERSE TO GUIDE CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES TO MAKE STRATEGIC
DECISIONS. THAT ARE INNOVATIVE
AND SERVE ALL CALIFORNIANS. AT
THIS TIME ABOUT THREE QUARTERS
OF FORTUNE ONE THOUSAND
COMPANIES DO NOT HAVE A SINGLE
ASIAN AMERICAN PERSPECTIVE IN
THE BOARDROOM. IN THE TECH
INDUSTRY AND SILICON VALLEY THE
PERCENTAGE OF API EXECUTIVES IS
ONLY A LITTLE MORE THAN HALF OF
THE PERCENTAGE OF API'S IN THE
OVERALL WORK FORCE. THE LARGEST
NEGATIVE DISPARITY BETWEEN THE
REPRESENTATION OF EXECUTIVES
AND WORKFORCE AMONG ALL ETHNIC
GROUPS. IN CALIFORNIA RECENT
STUDIES SHOW THAT ASIAN
AMERICANS ARE LEAST LIKELY TO
BE PROMOTED TO MANAGEMENT AND
EXECUTIVE POSITIONS. OR AT THE
HISTORIC INFLECTION POINT IN
THE SOCIETY WE NEED TO RISE TO
THE CHALLENGE ANSWER THE CALL
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
URGE FOR YOUR OTHER. THANK YOU
MISTER TO. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MR HOLDEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU. THIRTY
MINUTES LATER. I WOULD SIMPLY
JUST ASK FOR YOUR ARRIVAL. BUT
I THINK IT IS AS MINE JOINT
AUTHORS OF. ALIGNED IN A VERY
CHALLENGING YEAR. I LIKE WE ALL
WITNESSED THE GEORGIA FLORIDA.
MURDERED IN THE STREETS OF
MINNEAPOLIS THAT WE THOUGHT
THAT. OUR SOCIAL CONSCIOUSNESS
HAS BEEN ROCKED TO ITS CORE.
WHEN E SEE HOW EVEN IN WEEKS
PRECEDING AND AFTER ABOUT. HOW
IT JUST SEEMS TO CONTINUE TO
REPEAT ITSELF. AND SO WHEN WE
LOOK AT. HOW CAN WE MAKE A
CHANGE AND- THERE'S AN EFFORT
UNDERWAY UNDER THE DOME. TO
FIND WAYS TO CREATE MORE
EFFECTIVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT AND THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY.
AND HOW EXCESSIVE FORCE IS
HANDLED. WE ALSO HAVE THE ISSUE
PLAYING OUT. IN ORDER CITIZENS.
AND AS WE THOUGHT ABOUT HOW WE
COULD MAKE THIS BILL AFFECTED
AND MEET THE TIMES. I RECOGNIZE
THAT. WHEN YOU LOOK. A
DEDICATION GAP. AND THE BLACK
AND BROWN CHILDREN FALLING
BETWEEN. THE GAP. WHEN YOU LOOK
AT MINORITY BUSINESSES I HAVE A
HARD TIME GETTING ACCESS TO
CAPITAL. YOU SEE IT IS SO MANY
DIFFERENT LEVELS. REALIZE THIS
IS A PLACE. THAT WE HAD STARTED
THIS CONVERSATION. BACK IN. TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. AN ATTACK
COMMUNITIES DID NOT. RESPOND
WITH A SENSE OF URGENCY. I WANT
TO SAY TONIGHT THAT. WITH THE
EFFORT THEY WERE PUTTING FORTH
AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY TO MAKE A
REAL CHANGE IN THIS AREA. THERE
ARE SOME COMPANIES. IN
CALIFORNIA. BEEN ON THEIR OWN
ACCORD ARE DOING THE RIGHT
THING. AND SO THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPUR OTHERS ON.
TO TAKE THE SAME COURSE.
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU MR HOLDEN CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. VERY VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE A.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY ONE
NO SIX AND AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN LIVING A FILE ITEM
THREE OH FIVE AB SEVENTEEN TEN
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN TEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD NATURALLY THE
PHARMACY SECTOR WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THINK ABOUT A
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SEVENTEEN
TEN WAS AMENDED IN THE SENATE
TO ALLOW PHARMACISTS TO
ADMINISTER FDA APPROVED OR
AUTHORIZED KOBE TAXIS.
CURRENTLY PHARMACIST MAYBE AND
ADMINISTER VACCINES RECOMMENDED
BY THE FEDERAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON IMMUNIZATION
PRACTICES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE COMMITTEES VACCINE
RECOMMENDATIONS THIS BILL
MERELY ADDS THE CODE BAXEEN TO
THE LIST OF VACCINES THAT COKE
THE PHARMACISTS ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. WITH THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN THE GOAL
OF NOT JUST RAPID DEVELOPMENT
BUT ALSO DEPLOYMENT OF A
VACCINE WOULD BE VALUABLE TO
HAVE PHARMACIST BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THIS VACCINE SHOULD BE
READY BY THE END OF THIS YEAR
OR EARLY NEXT YEAR. THIS BILL
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DR ED SEEING
HEARING OVER DEBATE ON MATTER
WILL OF THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
WHO THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALITHA
I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED AND
FILE ITEM ZERO SIX B. B. TWO
SEVENTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVENTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN AN
ACCOLADE TO TAXATION'S TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
THREE MEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THIS IS NOT A TAXATION BILL.
THIS IS A B. THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR NOT TO SEVENTY SIX. IF YOU
HAVE THE WRONG NUMBER I'M BILL
NUMBER ON THE SCREEN. I'M SORRY
MISS REMEMBER FILE ITEM THREE
OR SIX IS AB TWO SEVENTY SIX
PERSONAL INCOME TAXES. OKAY
SORRY. OKAY I'M SORRY I THOUGHT
IT WAS THE OTHER BILL THAT'S
WHAT I SAW ON THE FILE HI THIS
BILL IS A BILL THAT WOULD HAVE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CONFORM
THE CARERS ACT FEDERAL TAXES
pTAX RULES WITH THE BILL WILL
ALLOW YOU TO DO IS FOR PEOPLE
TO WITHDRAW MONEY FROM THEIR-
SAVINGS RETIREMENT ACCOUNT FROM
THEIR THEIR EMPLOYER TO FIND
SAVINGS ACCOUNT TO BE ABLE TO
BORROW THAT MONEY TO PAY FOR
COVERT EXPENSES BUT THEN TO PAY
THAT MONEY BACK. INTO THEIR
RETIREMENT ACCOUNTS THAT THEY
HAVE MONEY DOWN THE ROAD WHEN
THEY WANT TO RETIRE WITHOUT
HAVING TO PAY A TAX PENALTY
OTHER STATES THEY DON'T HAVE TO
PAY THE TAX PENALTY BECAUSE
THEY'VE CONFORMIST FEDERAL
REGULATIONS BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
DONE THAT IN CALIFORNIA OUR
RESIDENTS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
PAY A TAX FEET THAT OTHER
RESIDENTS OF OTHER STATES DON'T
HAVE TO USE THIS WILL PUT US
INTO ALIGNMENT WITH THOSE OTHER
STATES WITH THAT I WOULD
REQUEST FULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THIS IS A BILL THAT HAS
PASSED THROUGH THE SENATE AND
PASSED THROUGH. ON A BI
PARTISAN AND ARE COMMITTEES ON
UP WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN THINKING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THERE.
MEMBERS. VOTED VERY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIGN TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD
VOTE. WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT I'D FIFTY FOUR NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
INCURRED IN FILE ITEM THREE OH
SEVEN AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME AGO
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE AND I
BELIEVE IN TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY
BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU AB SEVENTY SET FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE IT'S A STRAIGHT FOR
A BILL THAT INTEREST MALL
BUSINESSES THAT RECEIVE A LOAN
FROM THE PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAM UNDER THE CURES ACT
WILL NOT HAVE. THEIR FORGIVEN
LOANS TAXED AB FIFTEEN TIMES
ENJOY STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT RECEIVE NO NO BOTH I
REQUEST. WE CAN KERR IN
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISS
BURKE SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER.
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS ARE
REQUIRED OF IT. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT AYE
SIXTY WHO KNOWS ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONFERRED IN FILE ITEM
THREE OH EIGHT EIGHTY FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME AGO FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
BY SOME MEMBERS CERVANTES.
ANOTHER'S MACLAINE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. YOU ARE. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ESTABLISH A
PILOT PROJECT TO SUPPORT THE
ENHANCEMENT OF A REGIONAL
TRAINING CENTER NETWORK. WHICH
CAN WORK HAND IN HAND WITH
BUSINESS OWNERS SMALL BUSINESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND OTHER
WORKFORCE PARTNERS TO GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK. OVER EIGHT
POINT SIX MILLION UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE CLAIMS HAVE BEEN
FILED IN CALIFORNIA BETWEEN
MARCH FOURTEENTH AND AUGUST
FIFTEEN TWENTY TWENTY. MANY OF
THE INDUSTRY SECTORS MOST
IMPACTED DURING THE PANDEMIC
ARE NOT EXPECTED TO RETURN TO
PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS. OF
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY FOR SEVERAL
YEARS INCLUDING BUSINESSES IN
THE HOSPITALITY ACCOMMODATION
AND TOURISM SECTORS. EVEN IN
THOSE SECTORS. THERE ARE
ANTICIPATED TO RECOVER MORE
QUICKLY MANY LOW SKILL JOBS
WILL BE PERMANENTLY REPLACED OR
SIGNIFICANTLY MODIFIED. THROUGH
AUTOMATION E. COMMERCE BUSINESS
MODELS. A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED NEGATIVE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS DUE TO THE PANDEMIC OR
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR WITH
LIMITED EDUCATION. AND TRAINING
BEYOND HIGH SCHOOL. AB FORTY
FIFTY SEVEN LEVERAGES EXISTING
PROGRAMS. AND COMPETENCIES TO
RESPOND TO THESE KOBE NINETEEN
UNEMPLOYMENT CHALLENGES QUICKLY
AND HELP GET PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU MR ON
K. THINKING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
BOTH. HOME MEMBERS VOTERS THERE
TO VOTE. PAUL MEMBERS VOTED
VERY VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALITHA ICCA NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COULD
HURT AND FILE ITEM ZERO NINE
EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE A QUICK
WILL REACH SOME LEGAL TO
SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ALMOST ANOTHER SNACK RELATING
TO NATIVE AMERICAN CULTURAL
HERITAGE. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWO SEVENTY FIVE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE WITH US
SENATE AMENDMENTS THAT UPDATE
KALINAK PRO WITH RESPECT TO THE
POSSESSION OF HUMAN REMAINS AND
ITEMS BY REQUIRING TRIBAL
TRADITIONAL KNOWLEDGE TO BE
FACTORED INTO THE REPATRIATION
PROCESS. IT ALSO REQUIRES
MUSEUMS AND INSTITUTIONS TO
BEAR THE OBLIGATION TO CONTACT
TRIBES FOR REPATRIATION
CONSULTATIONS N. CREATE TRAVEL
LATEST SCIENCE POSITIONS TO BE
RELEVANT WITH STATE AGENCIES
AND INCREASING TRIBAL
CONSULTATION IN THE FUTURE MORE
BROADLY. THIS BILL ALSO LEVELS
THE PLAYING FIELD BETWEEN
INSTITUTIONS IN POSSESSION OF
TRIBAL ITEMS AND REMAINS AND
THE TRIBES THEMSELVES DURING
THE REPATRIATION PROCESS AS
WELL AS BRINGING REPRESENTATION
TO THE TRIBAL COMMUNITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AGENCIES.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECT YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS THERE TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS SAID WHO'S THERE
TO VOTE. OUR MEMBERS THIRTY
DESERVE BOTH THE CLERK WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALITHA RISE
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN
FILE ITEM THREE TEN EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETY THREE CLERK WILL
READ SOME LEGAL SEVEN NINETY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING
ANOTHER PERSON ACCOLADE INTO
RECYCLING THINKING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THE SEVEN NINETY THREE
ESTABLISHES A TIME FRAME FOR
BOTTLE BEVERAGE MANUFACTURERS
USE MINIMUM RECYCLED CONTENT IN
THEIR PLASTIC BOTTLES. STARTING
WITH 15% RECYCLED CONTENT IN
202225% AND TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND 50% BY TWENTY THIRTY. WILL
BE THE FIRST TIME WILL BE THE
FIRST STATE FRANKLY THE FIRST
COUNTRY TO ASK FOR A 50%
RECYCLED CONTENT IN OUR
BEVERAGE BOTTLES BY TWENTY
THIRTY LAST YEAR WE WERE ABLE
TO GET SEVEN NINETY TWO PASSED
THE FORTUNATELY WAS BE FILLED
WITH THE GOVERNOR. HE SPENT THE
LAST YEAR WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ALONG WITH MY
JOINT AUTHORS FROM THOUSAND
OAKS AND ALSO WITH THE STATE
AGENCIES THEY WERE VERY PROUD
OF THE PRODUCT THAT WE HAVE
TODAY AS WE ALL KNOW. PLASTIC
IS A MAJOR CHALLENGE THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE WORLD WITH THE
DISPOSAL PLASTIC WE THINK BY
HAVING MORE RECYCLED CONTENT
AND BEVERAGE BOTTLES THIS WILL
HELP REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
PLASTIC WE CONSUME BUT ALSO
CREATE MORE BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES HERE IN OUR STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. HI THIS BILL THE
BIPARTISAN BILL THE LEFT THE
SENATE WITH ZERO NO VOTES AND
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOU I
DON'T. THANK YOU MR TANG FENG
OF HER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
HELLO NEVER MISTER WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. AS AS A- PROUDCO
AUTHOR I DO WANTED. THANK MY
COLLEAGUES SAN FRANCISCO THIS
BILL HAS BEEN AT LEAST A FOUR
YEAR EFFORT AND THERE WAS AN-
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF.
COLLABORATION TO GET TO THE
POINT WHERE WE REALLY DID GET
THROUGH THE SENATE WITH. NO NO
VOTES AND I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE AGAIN. THIS IS FIFTY
PERCENT. RENEWABLE CONTENT BY
TWENTY THIRTY THE HIGHEST IN
THE WORLD. SO WE REALLY HAVE
SOMETHING TO BE. PROUD OF A ON
THE COMPANY'S OF ALL. OF THE
WORK VERY HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE THIS CALL SO. THANK YOU
MR KING AND- APPRECIATE A- FEW
MINUTES ONE. NOW SEEING HERE
OVER THE ON THE MATTER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE- ROMAN. ALL
MEMBERS GO TO THEIR. TO CLARK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLAND THE VOTE
I'D FIFTY SIX ZERO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED IN FILE
ITEM THREE ELEVEN EIGHTY TWELVE
EIGHTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE EIGHTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI AN
ACCOLADE MOBILITY DEVICES
AMERICANS WHO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS BILL IS MY E. SCOOTER
SHARED BIKES PUBLIC SAFETY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION BILL THIS
BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES THERE WERE
A SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS TAKEN
AND THE SENATE THAT HAS REMOVED
THE OPPOSITION OF TACK NAT.
BIRD LINE THE CITY IS THAT
REYES LAST MINUTE CONCERNS- BE
BICYCLE COALITION. GROUPS ALL
OF THAT OPPOSITION HAS BEEN
REMOVED. THIS BILL REQUIRES
LOCAL CITIES TO COME UP WITH
THEIR OWN. SAFETY ROLES ARE
ASKED TO THE OPERATION PARKING
AND MAINTENANCE OF SHARED BIKES
AND E. SCOOTERS. ARE ALSO
REQUIRES A MINIMUM INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED IN THERE TO
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL COOL LOS GROWING TALENT
ABOUT ICE FORTY SEVEN NO TWELVE
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM THREE TWELVE MAYBE
FIFTEEN FORTY FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME REAL FIFTEEN
FORTY FOUR BY SIMPLY BECAUSE
ANOTHER PERSON I BELIEVE THE
COMMUNITY PARAMEDICINE IT'S A
GOOD THING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR IS BACK ON
CONCERNS THE SENATE MEMBERS
WERE TAKEN- AT THE DIRECTION OF
THE AGENCY AND THE
ADMINISTRATION SOME OF THESE
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE SUNSET OF
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
REVISE THE SELECTION CRITERIA
FOR MEMBERS OF THE E. M. S.
COMMISSION. ACCEPTS AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. TO X. TO. THE VICE
THE PARAMEDICINE AND TRIGGER
AUTORES DESTINATION PROGRAMS.
AS THE AS WELL AS ENSURE THAT
THE UNDERLYING E. S. M.
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IS NOT
DISTORT DISTURB- AND INCLUDE
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE. THAT THIS
AGREEMENT MAINTAINS THE
INTEGRITY OF THIS VIDEO MEMBERS
BUILDING WORKING ON FOR ALMOST
TWO YEARS WAITED FOR THE
MINISTRATION TODAY WE HAVE A
BILL. THAT IS A VERY THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
AIBO AIBO ON FIFTEEN FORTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MR GIVES THEM
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
BOTH THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO'S THERE TO VOTE. ON
NUMBER THIRTY THEIR TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW IT ABOUT AYE AYES FIFTY
KNOWS FIVE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE AND THREE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
AGO NINETEEN SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOCK RBIO AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE THE SECOND
HAND GOODS. THIS RUBIO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB NINETEEN SIXTY NINE
IS BACK WITH FOR US FOR A
CONCURRENCE VOTE. THE BILL
WOULD PROTECT THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION OF UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS. WHO USE PUNCH UPS
IN OUR STATE AND MEASUREMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE WHERE THE
REQUEST OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND DELAY IN PLAN DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION. BEFORE CLOSING
I DO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
REMEMBER COLLEAGUES. AND FOR
OUR FOR MANY OF US OUR DEAR
FRIEND FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BILL THE PC. AB NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE WILL BE THE FINAL MEASURE
MOVING THROUGH THIS HOUSE WITH
MISTER TO PIECES PERSONAL
ADVOCACY AND INPUT. MR TO
PLEASE HE WAS PASSIONATE IN HIS
SERVICE BOTH INSIDE AND OUTSIDE
OF THIS BUILDING. AND I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT THIS BILL
TODAY IN FONG MEMORY OF MR TO
PLEASE SEE. WHAT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. RUBIO THINKING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO THEIR TO VOTE. OUR
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS DESERVE A-
WELCOME CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLY
THAT ICE FORTY TWO KNOWS FIVE
SETS ARE CONCURRED IN. AB F.
VIOLATED THREE FOURTEEN AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRANDMOTHERS AN
ACCOLADE THE HORSE RACING IN
MAKING APPROPRIATION FOR. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MATT MCMAHON
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AFTER RECEIVING
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS RESPECT FASTER AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER GRACING
HEARING OVER THE DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR OWN. MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JIM ADEMA SPEAKER AS A
JOINT AUTHORIZED IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FROM OUR
SET FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON HIS
BILL OUR CENTER NEED TO PARK IS
ACTUALLY LOCATED IN MY DISTRICT
ARE SINCE JULY TWENTY EIGHTEEN
A POSSIBLY SEVENTY HORSES HAVE
DIED FROM RACING AND TRAINING
INJURIES. AT THE PARK OBSCENITY
TO PARK AND THE HORSE RACING
INDUSTRY HAVE BEEN TAKEN STEPS
TO IMPROVE THE SAFETY OF HORSES
IN CALIFORNIA BUT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE EFFORTS IN
THIS AREA AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR MAKES A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT CHANGES TO THE
HORSERACING LAW TO FURTHER
PROTECT AND ADVANCE THE HEALTH
SAFETY WELFARE AND ALL AFTER
CARE OF OUR RESOURCES IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHOW SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE. ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE MOVE. ALL MEMBERS THAT YOU
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS OF THE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALITHA I SAID YOU KNOW ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONVERTED
FILE ITEM THREE FIFTEEN AB
TWENTY ONE OH FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME LEGAL TWENTY ONE
OH FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AN ACCOLADE A
HAZARDOUS WASTE THIS GARCIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED YES MEMBERS AB
TWENTY ONE OH FORCE BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AND HAS. ENJOYED A
UNANIMOUS. YEAH MOST VOTES
ALONG THE PROCESS. ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS GARCIA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER.
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY TO THEIR VOTE WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY TWO NEWS ONE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM THREE SIXTEEN AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME LEGAL
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN BY
SIMPLY MEMORY IS ANOTHER'S
MICHELENA CONVICTIONS. THREE IF
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN ALLOWS A FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL THAT
HAS SUCCESSFULLY PARTICIPATED
IN IT IN MAY FIRE AS AN INMATE
FIREFIGHTER. TO APPLY FOR AN
EXPUNGEMENT. IF WE REALLY WANT
TO BRING ABOUT CHANGE IN LOWER
OUR RECIDIVISM RATES. WE HAVE
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO HAVE
SERVED THEIR SENTENCES HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEANINGFUL
EMPLOYMENT. AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN DOES JUST THAT WOULD ADD
MUCH NEEDED BALANCE TO OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
ALLOW THOSE INDIVIDUALS. THAT
WE ARE COMFORTABLE ENOUGH TO
CALL ON TO HELP FIGHT FIRES AND
DEFEND PROPERTY AND LIVES. TO
ALSO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SEEK AN EXPUNGEMENT. SENATE
AMENDMENTS PROVIDED CLARIFYING
AND TECHNICAL CHANGES. ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS READ.
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. ON HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER HERBAL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE EYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS TEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM THREE SEVENTEEN. AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME LEGAL TWENTY TWO
THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIMóN AND OTHERS MEDICAL
EMERGENCY SERVICES. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN
WAS AMENDED IN THE SENATE TO
RETIRE CAL OH YES AND CAL
VOLUNTEERS TO DEVELOP PLANNING
GUIDANCE TO IDENTIFY VOLUNTEERS
AND DONATIONS MANAGEMENT
SERVICES. TO ASSIST IN
RESPONDING AND RECOVERING FROM
DISASTER THE BILL RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I HAVE A. THANK YOU
MISS LIMóN. SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS VOTER THERE TO VOTE. ALL
SAID WHO'S THERE TO VOTE. ALL
RESERVE A- WHERE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALITHA I SIXTY KNOWS
YOUR SENTIMENTS ARE CONVERTED
FILE ITEM THREE EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME LEGAL
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO
ANOTHER'S MEDICALLY THE CHILD
SUPPORT. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FIVE IS BACK FROM CURRENT
CURRENTLY AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE SENATE REMOVE THE
WORKGROUP. DUE TO THE COST IN
LIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC AND ADDED
CO AUTHORS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MATH CARILLO SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WILL BE THERE TO
VOTE. THE AFTER NOT MAKING THE-
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD OF A.
UHHUH YEAH. AFTER. BURKE WELL
CLOSER ROLE ON TELEVISION EYES
FORTY ONE. KNOWS WHERE THE NOSE
ON KNOWS TO IMPAIRMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS BACK ON
THE. FOR ORIGINAL CONCURRENCE
FILE THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINETY SIX. FILE ITEM NINETY
SIX. AB TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEEKS ANOTHER RESPECTFULLY TO
HEALTH FACILITIES MR BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
IT REQUIRES AN EXTENDED PUBLIC
NOTIFICATION PERIOD OF A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS FOR
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH FACILITIES
PROVIDING EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES BEFORE THEY CAN REDUCE
OR ELIMINATE THOSE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR CONCURRENCE. THANKS
BONTA SAY NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE REMOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE START OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A DESIRE TO VOTE.
BOB.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
TIED ABOUT EYES FORTY TWO KNOWS
ELEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT. BACK ON THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE. IN VERY
SMALL PRINT. RIGHT I. I BELIEVE
THIS IS. FILE ITEM THREE
NINETEEN AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN. KERKORIAN SOME
AGO TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID CHIU
ANOTHER RESPECTFULLY TO HEALTH
AND CARE FACILITIES. MISTER
DAVID CHIU YOU MAIL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER CLLEAGUES AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
WOULD ADDRESS A RECENT
DISTURBING TREND OF CLOSURES OF
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
WHICH SERVE SOME OF OUR STATE'S
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS.
INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESSES AND OTHER CHRONIC
CONDITIONS THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH STRONGER COLORS
REQUIREMENTS AND GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE TOOLS TO ENSURE
THAT THESE FACILITIES STAY
OPEN. SENATE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
TECHNICAL CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE WITH
THAT- I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOOSING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON THE
ITEM CARCLUB. THE SERVER ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE
TWENTY AB. TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN. CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
ANOTHER SNACK LEAD TO WORK
PLACE OF SAFETY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ. THANK MISPERTON
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THE SENTIMENT AMENDMENTS LOWER
DEPARTMENTS FOR HOSPITALS
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO MAINTAIN
STOCKPILE FOR SIX MONTHS IT
WOULD NOW BE THREE MONTHS. THEY
ALSO EXPAND WHO MUST BE COVERED
IN THE BILL FROM EMPLOYEES WHO
ARE PROVIDING DIRECT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO ALL HOSPITAL
WORKERS RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU. THEY MISS RODRIGUEZ
SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ADAM CORPORAL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE. YEAH. ALL MEMBERS
SERVICE OUT OF A. BURKE WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FORTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FIVE THREE TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY. CORPORATE SOME AGO
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK ANOTHER'S
MACULATUM THE WATER QUALITY DR
COURT. THANK YOU SPEAK FOR A
MEMBER OF THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTEEN
AUTHORIZES STATE WATERS FOR
DIVISION OF BREAKING WATERS. IN
DECEMBER THE POLLUTANT FROM THE
PUBLIC PROCESS CREATED BY THIS
BILL YEAH THE- DIVISION OF
BREAKING WATER. FINDS BETTER
CONTAMINATED ITS POTENTIAL FOR
HARM TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. THERE WAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT MORE VISION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIVE-
THANK YOU TO COURT. SEEING
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CARCLUB ROLL. VARIABLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF THE- ALL
MEMBERS THAT ARE DESIRED OF A.
CARDWELL CLOSER ALL CHILD BUT I
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE COULD HURT HIM
FILE ITEM THREE TWENTY TWO. AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
CORKERY. SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA AN
ACCOLADE TO EMPLOYMENT MISTER
KALRA. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS YOUR REPRESENTATIVE
CURRENTS FOR AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT OF THESE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THE
PROVISION OF EXISTING LABO
CODE TWENTY EIGHT TO APPLY TO
THIS BILL AS SPECIFIED IN
PLEASE PROVIDING DIRECT PATIENT
CARE. IN A GENERAL ACUTE
HOSPITAL WE ALSO ADDED WHAT
TRAINING IS NOT INCLUDED- SUCH
AS A LICENSING CERTIFICATION OR
REGISTRATION LEGALLY REQUIRED
TO PRACTICE THE SPECIFIC JOB
CLASSIFICATION OR EDUCATION OR
TRAINING VOLUNTARILY TAKEN BY
THE WORKER AFRICAN. AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT MAKE CERTAIN
THAT THE UNETHICAL PRACTICE
FROM POSING A PLAYER MANAGER
TRAINING COSTS TO OUR CENTRAL
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE IS
PROHIBITED IF THE TRAINING IS
REQUIRED AS A CONDITION OF
EMPLOYMENT. ALL RIGHT SEE NOTE
DEBATE ON THE COURT THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRABLE.
WELL
CLOSER ALL HIGHLIGHTS FORTY TWO
KNOWS ELEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE INCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE
ITEM THREE TWENTY THREE AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
BIAS AND WE WERE CERVANTES AN
ACCOLADE TO EMERGENCY SERVICES
MISTER MANTAS MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY WILL REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND AGENCIES TO
WORK TOGETHER TOGETHER TO SHARE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SERVICES
SUCH AS PARA TRANSIT VEHICLES
DRIVERS AND MEDICAL EQUIPMENT
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
REMOVED FOR SMALL TRANSIT
AGENCIES AND ENSURE SERVICES.
UNDER SUCH AGREEMENTS BE
AVAILABLE TWENTY FOUR HOURS PER
DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK THIS BILL
IS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND IN THE SENATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK THIS BY. C. THEIR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CARCLUB RURAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS CEREMONY.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
MARKWELL CLOSE ROLE TYLER I
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS. ARKIN CURTAIN FILE
ITEM THREE TWENTY FOUR IS AB.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
SIX. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LIMóN AND OTHERS FACULTY INTO
INSURANCE THIS LAMONT. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER FIRST I WANT
I THINK I MAY SEE ME IN CALLING
FROM SANTA MONICA FOR WORKING
ON THIS BILL FOR WITH ME. AND
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX WAS
AMENDED IN THE SENATE TO
STRENGTHEN PROVISIONS THAT WILL
ENSURE HOMEOWNERS ARE AWARE
WHEN THEIR HOMEOWNER'S
INSURANCE POLICIES HAVE
DRAMATICALLY CHANGED THIS BILL
RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES AND
THERE IS A ASK FOR AND I HAVE A-
THANK IS AMONG. C. NOTICED. OF
A- THE CLUB IN THE WORLD. IS
THERE A VITAL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CULTURAL TIE BUT I SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO CENTER MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRENT WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM THREE
TWENTY FIVE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
THREE TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES MISTER
GLORIA MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE SENTIMENT
SIMPLY ADD CO AUTHORS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WAS GLORIA SEEING NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM CORPORAL
OF THE ROLE. SEVERAL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSER
ALL TADARISE FIFTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED.
MEMBERS I KNOW YOU'D LIKE TO DO
MORE TONIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
SAVE SOME FOR TOMORROW. MEMBERS
WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON CALL.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON. FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY NINE SB ELEVEN AT NINETY.
CLICK A POST ALL MEMBERS WHO
WISH TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
WILL RESERVE THE. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSER ROLE. TALBERT EYES
FORTY TWO KNOWS SIXTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS. WITH. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. YEAH THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR MOTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
GENERAL SIX TO A DEFAULT NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO CHANGE THE
MEETING TIME OF LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE TOMORROW
MONDAY AUGUST THIRTY FIRST SO
THAT THEY CAN MEET UPON CALL OF
THE CHAIR. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS. MEMBERS BEFORE
WE ADJOURN I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE MR HOLDEN FOR A BRIEF
ANNOUNCEMENT MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I JUST WANTED TO
LET THE MEMBERS KNOW THAT THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS MET. COUPLE WEEKS AGO
AND WE RE ELECTED. AS ARMCHAIR
DOCTORS REALLY WEBER FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEAR CYCLE. SENATOR
MARTYRS AND SENATORS AND JIM
COOPER ZURCHER. THANK YOU MR
HOLDEN THANK YOU MEMBERS
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
MONDAY AUGUST THIRTY FIRST
FLOOR SESSION. ROMPUY AT TEN
AM. ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL PASS RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING A FOR THE BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MISTER BLOOM MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS. THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY AUGUST THIRTY FIRST AT
TEN AM WE ARE JOURNAL.
ALL
RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM-
VOTE CHANGE- AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT I TO NOT VOTING.
YEAH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH AB
TWENTY ONE OH FOUR NO TO AYE
OKAY CHANGE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM SOME PEOPLE THIRTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT I DO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH AB TWENTY
ONE OH FOUR NO T<c.cyan>. ASSEMBLY</c>
MEMBER SMITH ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE OH FOUR NO TIME. S.
S. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
SB ELEVEN NINETEEN NO TO NOT
VOTING. CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN SENATE BILL ELEVEN
NINETY NO TO NOT VOTING.
YEAH I
GOT. AGUIAR-CURRY A. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT I DON'T KNOW
VOTING. CHANGE ASSEMBLY BILL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
SOME A BILL ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
ALL RIGHT HIGHS NOT VOTING. SB
TWO EIGHT EIGHT HI THE NOT
VOTING. AGUIAR-CURRY SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTY EIGHT I DO NOT
VOTING. YEAH. AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN MONTHS PREGNANT.
OF. OH FIVE. YEAH AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN BY BRIGHAM
FOR CHANGES BOTH FROM I TO A
MAP OF THE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COURT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN I DO NOT VOTING. I.
YEAH. I'M SORRY- I CHANGE MY
VOTE ON THE- AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN RODRIGUEZ BERMAN I
WOULD NOW. I DUNNO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN I TO
KNOW.